JUDICIARY WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF REMOTELY
PARTICIPATING OUR MEMBERS
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY ARE
SENATORS STERN. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR STERN IF YOU'LL AND IF
YOU HAVE STAFF ASSISTING YOU
TODAY WOULD YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY
THEM NOW. YES. SAYS SENATOR
HENRY STERN OF MY DISTRICT
OFFICE WITH MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR GERMINAL. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU. US SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS AND I WILL
DO THAT MYSELF RIGHT NOW- THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND I
ASKED THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH
TO BE RECOGNIZED- YOU USED THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN YOUR
PROGRAM AND WE'RE TALKING NOW
TO SENATOR STERN. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP IN THE WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT A NEW TO
BEFORE BEGIN SPEAKING. ARE HI
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE AND
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN THE AND STATE YOUR
NAME. AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT. THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO.
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ALSO ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX THREE TWO
EIGHT SIX EIGHT SIX LET ME DO
THAT AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE. SIX THREE TWO
EIGHT SIX EIGHT SIX. AND FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS
THERE'S ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT AND PERHAPS
TODAY AS I UNDERSTAND IT WILL
BE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WILL
BE CALLING IN IT MIGHT BE A
LITTLE LONGER THAN THAT SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
BE ASKED TO WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALLED
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
HE WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU WERE
NOT READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. I'M GONNA SAY IT NOW
AND I'LL PROBABLY SAY IT
SEVERAL TIMES WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WITNESSES EACH WITH A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES TOTAL.
FOR THEM TO PRESENT. AS THE
MAIN WITNESSES AFTER THAT WE
WILL ALLOW. UP PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE. TO GIVE US THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEY
EITHER THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL OR THEIR OPPOSITION WE
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTING
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WE HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
CALL. AND YOU'LL HAVE TO
FORGIVE ME BUT I WILL BE- FIRM
ABOUT THIS AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT WITNESS NAME
AFFILIATION SO IF YOU'RE SIMPLY
CALLING SAYING HELLO ARME.
TAXPAYER MY POSITION ON THE
BILL IS I SUPPORTED OR OPPOSED
IT WE WILL THEN GO ON TO THE
NEXT PERSON. PLEASE FOLLOW
THEIR PROTOCOL IF YOU WILL I'M
SURE THERE ARE MANY STORIES
MANY CONCERNS. BUT WE ARE JUST
GOING TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. WITH THAT
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
THE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK THAT
WOULD INEVITABLY HAPPEN YOU
HAVE TO MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE HEARING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN IS CLOSE TO THE
MANNER. AS HIS CUSTOMARY AND
THE PRACTICE OF THIS BODY FOR.
DECADES THERE ARE THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGY PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE THIS IS MY LAST.
FORMAL HEARING AS CHAIR OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I
THINK I HAVE BEEN TRYING THIS
FOR ABOUT SIX AND A HALF YEARS.
AND IT HAS. WELL IT'S CERTAINLY
BEEN AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE
TO BE THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR. ABOUT SIX SIX
AND A HALF YEARS DURING THAT
TIME WHETHER PEOPLE AGREE OR
DON'T IT IS CERTAINLY BEEN MY
DESIRE MY INTENT WORKING WITH
THE WONDERFUL MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE I THINK. OF MR
MAKOWSKI AND- AND MR BANDT
MINING AND I HAVE BEEN SERVING
TOGETHER IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR
MANY YEARS WE HAD MORE HAIR AND
CERTAINLY LESS GRAY OF IT WHEN
WE STARTED- BUT WE HAVE THIS
COMMITTEE I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE DEALING WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS. ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE EVERYONE WITH ACCESS TO
JUSTICE MAKE SURE THAT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS RECEPTIVE AND
ACCOMMODATING EVERYTHING FROM
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO PRIVACY
RIGHTS WE'VE HAD HEARINGS
DEALING WITH. THE RIGHT OF
PEOPLE TO SPEAK- EVEN THOUGH
THAT SPEECH ISN'T NECESSARILY
PREFERRED BY THOSE TO WHOM THAT
SPEECH IS BEING DIRECTED THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS SUCH A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. AND THERE
ARE SO MANY OTHER AREAS SO I
WON'T GET INTO BUT I JUST
WANTED TO SAY IT HAS REALLY
BEEN AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE
AND I HAVE PROBABLY. WILL IF
NOT THE BEST ONE OF THE BEST
STAFFS. ON THIS DAY SHERRY
COMMITTEE WHEN I STARTED- IT
LOOKED VERY DIFFERENT THANKS TO
OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT MARCHES
STRADA WHO IS DONE AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB PUTTING
TOGETHER. AMAZING TEAM. REUTERS
TO MAKE THIS I THINK ONE OF THE
BEST COMMITTEES AND CERTAINLY
ONE OF THE MOST THOROUGH- AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE QUALITY
THAT THIS. AUGUST PARTY IS
CAPABLE OF SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU MARCHING AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE STATE. SO WITH
THAT. WE ACTUALLY NOW HAVE
SEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA-
I'M SORRY MR VICE CHAIR. IF I
COULD JUST TAKE THIS PLEASE
OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO THANK I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF. FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE AND WELL YOU AND I
PHILOSOPHICALLY MAY NOT ALWAYS
BE IN ALIGNMENT I NEVER.
THOUGHT THAT YOU DIDN'T ACTED
OUT OF WHAT YOU BELIEVE WAS THE
RIGHT COURSE OF ACTION. AND I
ALWAYS RESPECTED THAT. AND EVEN
THOUGH YOU AND I'VE HAD SOME
VERY INTERESTING CHANCE TO
BREATHE THROUGH THIS. SOME
CHALLENGES. YOU RUN THE
MEETINGS I THINK WITH A HIGH
DEGREE OF EXPECTATION IN
COORDINATION. I THINK IT IS
SHOWN THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING
THAT HIGH PERFORMING COMMITTEE
LIKE THIS HOW WE CAN BE DONE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR STAFF. THANK. BOB US
SENATOR TO RUSH I REALLY
QUESTION INTENDING THIS TO BE
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD I KNOW A
MANAGER YOU WERE INTENDING BUT
I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO RECOGNIZE
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE. AND I'M A
NEWBIE HERE BUT EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYONE SAYS ABOUT YOU AND
I'VE SEEN WHAT I'VE SEEN IN MY
SHORT TIME ON THIS JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IS. WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP
ROLE AND HOW PASSIONATE YOU ARE
BUT ALSO NOT JUST PASSIONATE
YOU SO FAR ABOUT THE ISSUES.
AND YOU GET INTO THE WAY YOU
WANT. TO HAVE THE VISION YOU
GET INTO THE WEEDS AS MUCH AS
AS ANYTHING ELSE SO I JUST WANT
TO PUBLICLY THANK YOU I KNOW I
THANK YOU BUT LEE BUT PUBLICLY
THANK YOU ACKNOWLEDGE YOU. OKAY
YOU BURY MY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT. SENATOR
MORNING YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I KNOW YOU'RE ANXIOUS
TO GET ON WITH THE HEARING
THAT- WE'RE GONNA SPEND A LONG
TIME HERE TODAY AND I THINK WE
CAN TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN.
IN THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF YOUR
STAFF YOUTH ASSEMBLED AN
AMAZING TEAM I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SERVE ON JUDICIARY MY ENTIRE
TENURE BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
NOW IN THE SENATE- AND- IF
NOTHING ELSE YOU'VE BEEN A
FIERCE DEFENDER OF THE
CONSTITUTION. OF THE- BILL OF
RIGHTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND WHILE IT IS
SUBJECT TO DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OBVIOUSLY. I
THINK THAT'S BEEN YEAR GUIDING
COMPASS IN YOUR NORTHSTARS
PROTECTING CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS IN WITH RESPECT YOUR
STAFF MARCHING ON YOUR TEAM.
SOME OF THE ANALYSES THAT ARE
GENERATED. ARE BETTER THAN
COURT OPINIONS I'VE SEEN IN
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO OUR
COURT SYSTEM- THE WORK FIT YOUR
TEAM DOES IS INCREDIBLE I'VE
SHARED A COUPLE OF THE RECENT
ONES SOME ON THE HISTORY OF
SLAVERY AND ITS IMPACTS- IN
CALIFORNIA. I'VE SHARED THAT
WITH FRIENDS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
AS JUST AN EXCELLENT HISTORICAL.
PRIMER IF YOU WILL SO THANK YOU
AND ALL YOUR TEAM FOR YOUR WORK
IN MADAM CHAIR JUST SPIN GREAT
SERVING TOGETHER AND- WE'VE
ENJOYED BEING ON THE SAME SIDE
OF MOST ISSUES- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR- CONTINUED WORK
AFTER SERVICE HERE AND- HOPE WE
CAN MAINTAIN A COLLABORATION IN.
CONTINUING TO FIGHT TO PROTECT
OUR US AND STATE CONSTITUTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND
I WANT TO ALSO THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR-
PENDING. WELL I'M SURE IT'S NOT
A RETIREMENT BUT TO. WE WILL BE
LEAVING AT THE SAME TIME AND IT
HAS BEEN A REAL PLEASURE
WORKING WITH YOU- I'VE ENJOYED
YOUR INSIGHTS AND YOUR- PASSION
YOU YOU EXPRESS A PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT. MORE KIND OF LEVEL
HEADED THAN I DO ON OCCASION.
BUT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE TO
THE ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO THE PEOPLE. THAT WE SERVE IN
THAT YOU SERVING YOUR DISTRICT
THEY'VE BEEN VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
YOU AND IT'S BEEN MY PLEASURE
AND HONOR TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. CAN GET SENATOR
GONZALEZ I WAS GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE BILL BUT NOW THE NUMBER
GETTING- I ALSO WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE HERE AND YOU'RE NOT
ONLY REVERED IN SANTA BARBARA
AND SACRAMENTO BUT BACK HOME IN
LONG BEACH I HAVE- FANS OF
YOURS THAT REALLY JUST
APPRECIATE- THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING THAT JUST FOR YOUR
DISTRICT BUT FOR MANY OF OUR
DISTRICTS SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH AND I'VE LEARNED
SUCH. A GREAT DEAL BEING HONEST
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BEING
THROWN IN HERE AS A FRESHMAN
SENATOR AND THEN HAVING TO
CAMPUS COMMITTEE AS A NON
LAWYER I'VE LEARNED SUCH A
GREAT DEAL AND FOR THAT I
ATTRIBUTE A MOSTLY TO YOU IN
YOUR GOOD WORK SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH INTO MARGIE'S HALL THE
ANALYSIS USUALLY ARE ARE
ALWAYS- REALLY INSIGHTFUL AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TOO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF WE HAVE A
CENTER STERN YOU HAVE YOUR HAND
UP WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK. I
WOULD. LIKE TO BE THE LAST.
ALMOST LAST WON THE LEAGUE
DURING THE- SINISTER WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU. CAN WE TRY TO GET. IN
HERE. I THANK YOU TIME IS WELL.
ALL RIGHT CENTER STERN LET'S
GIVE IT ANOTHER TRY. WE TRIED.
ARE WE THERE YET YEAH WE GOT
YOUR- I ALWAYS LIKE TO. JOINT
AND SORT OF APOLOGETICALLY YOU
DON'T TRY TO GET A FEW WORDS IN
THIS COMMITTEE YOU WITH ME IN
THIS SHAPE HERE. AS A SENATOR
AND IS A MEMBER OF A VERY
POWERFUL COMMITTEE AND I JUST I
WHAT I HAVE TO. JOIN THE CHORUS
BECAUSE THE ADMIRATION THAT I
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR- TENACITY AND AT TIMES
PROTEINACEOUS TENNIS CITY AND
I'M WILLING DOGGEDNESS IN YOUR
FIGHT FOR- YOU KNOW UNSEALING
DOG IS YOUR FIGHT FOR TRUTH FOR
JUSTICE AND THOSE PRINCIPLES
THAT BIT. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
WHEN I HEAR YOU SAY. BRING ME
YOUR TIRED YOUR HUDDLED MASSES
YOU KNOW YOU YOU YOU ARE OUR
CONSCIENCE IN SO MANY WAYS IN
THE SENATE MAN CHAIR AND I
SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR BEING A
MENTOR AND A TEACHER AND A
TOUGH TEACHER. AT THAT. WELL
LIKE ME NEEDED AND THE WORLD
NEEDS IT TOO IT'S NOT TIME FOR
THE MAKE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER STERN AYE MUCH
APPRECIATED. CENTER WHAT KASKY
BEEN A MANAGER SOME OF US KNOW
WHAT A DIE HARD BOSTON RED SOX
FAN YOU ARE WHETHER IT WAS THE
ERA OF TED WILLIAMS. CARL
YASTRZEMSKI LOUIS TIAN. RICO
PETROCELLI OR EVEN THE OLD
MOOKIE MOOKIE BETTS BEFORE YOU
WENT TO THE L. A. DODGERS THE
ONE THING EVERYBODY IN THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE WITH
MEMBERS THAT SERVED HER KNOW
THAT. YOU COME TO PLAY BALL.
EVERY TIME YOU HIT TECH APPLE
HEARING JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO
MY INVITATION TO IS LET'S PLAY
BALL NOW SOUNDS GREAT PERFECT
PERFECT SEGUE THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE ARE. OH
I'M SORRY CENTER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I DON'T
HAVE ANY BASEBALL REFERENCES TO
MAKE- AND I'M NOT KNOWN FOR
BEING TERRIBLY EFFUSIVE ON THE
MICROPHONE BUT I WILL SAY. I
HAVE ENJOYED BEING ON THIS
COMMITTEE- I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR
SOME TIME NOW SINCE I GOT TO
LEGISLATURE AND I- I RESPECT.
THE FACT THAT YOU. STAND UP FOR
WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN COMMON YOU
DON'T BACK DOWN I IN MUCH THE
SAME WAY THAT WE ARE OBVIOUSLY.
A FEW MILES APART IN WHAT
THERE'S THINGS ARE THAT WE'RE
STANDING FOR BUT I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED RESPECTED THE FACT
THAT YOU STAND YOUR GROUND AND
YOU DON'T. WAFFLE DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM ON
ISSUES I DO APPRECIATE THAT AND
I AND I WANT TO SAY THAT- THIS
THIS COMMITTEE. ISN'T PRONE TO
BEING TERRIBLY BRIEF BUT I DO
LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU YOU TRY
TO KEEP IT MOVING ALONG YOU TRY
TO KEEP EVERYBODY ON TASK. YOU
ADHERE TO THE RULES OF THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU MAKE SURE
EVERYONE ELSE DOES TOO AND THAT
HELPS IT RUN MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND LORD KNOWS WE NEED THAT IN
THIS BUILDING SO THANK YOU AND
I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AS WELL WE SHOULD LOCK
ON THIS COMMITTEE THIS. THIS
COMMITTEE IF. YOU GET A READ
THIS STUFF AND IF YOU'RE NOT A
LAWYER- I'M I CAN IMAGINE IT'S
TOUGH AS A LAWYER CAN BE TOUGH.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THE- BAN ALLEN
RESPONDED- TO A SENATOR STERN'S
COMMENTS BY SAYING- THAT I
SHOULD HAVE TAUGHT HIM. MORE.
SO WITH THAT. WITH THAT I HAVE
TO SAY THAT THOSE ARE ALL KIND
WORDS BUT I JUST GOT A TEXT
FROM MY DAUGHTER WHO'S
LISTENING FROM CHICAGO WHO SAID
I AM SO PROUD OF YOU. SEVEN
THAT MEANS A LOT. AS SUCH
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE ALL SET
IT'S REALLY BEEN A PLEASURE AND
AN HONOR AND TOUGH. I WISH YOU
WELL GOING FORWARD WE ARE IN
DIFFICULT TIMES THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT I JUST ASKED
THAT WE REMEMBER WHY WE'RE
HERE. AND THE PEOPLE WERE
FIGHTING FOR AND TO JUST DO
YOUR BEST. SO WITH THAT. LET'S
PROCEED WE HAVE WE HAD A BILLS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY THREE OF
WHICH ARE IN CONSENT. WE HAVE
JUST LEARNED THAT FILE ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CORK SILVA
IS BEING PULLED. SO WE WILL NOT
BE HEARING THAT BILL TODAY THAT
DOES LEAVE US WITH FOR BILLS
BUT- THESE ARE GOING TO BE FOR.
VERY INTERESTING AND
COMPLICATED AND IMPORTANT BILLS
THAT WILL BE HEARING. SO WITH
THAT IN MIND LET'S BEFORE WE
GET STARTED LET'S ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM- MAN CONSULTANTS WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YES
OF THE THUNDERS AND PLEASE TURN
THEIR MICROPHONES ON THIS IS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. JACKSON
HERE JACKSON HERE PORGES
RESIDENT BORDERS PRESENT DID US
ALL YEAR IT ALSO HERE GONZALEZ
HERE GONZALEZ HERE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ HERE MONNING YEARS
MONEY HERE STERN FROM HERE
STERN HERE AMBERG YEAH NUMBER
CARE OR Y. CASKEY- WHY CASKEY
HERE ALL MEMBERS ARE HERE A
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED THANK YOU
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. R. S.
SENATOR UMBERG'S CAR WILL START
THIS MORNING. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU BUT I THERE WAS A
CONSTANT NIGHTMARE I HAD ABOUT
TAKING THE BAR EXAM YEAH. THAT
MY CAR WOULD NOT START I HAD
SOMEONE FOLLOW ME EVERYDAY THE
BAR EXAM BECAUSE TO MAKE SURE
REALLY OKAY SO I'M NOT ALONE.
IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN MANY YEARS
AND I STILL HAVE THREE. SO YOU
GOT TO LIVE IT TODAY CENTER
OVER BUT- WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
CENTER ON BERG. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE A RETURN I WANTED TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE TODAY I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S A
HARDER WORKING. A CHAIR IN ANY
THE COMMITTEES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND- I'VE LEARNED
FROM YOUR EXAMPLE WHAT
DEDICATION AND DILIGENCE AND
HAVING SUCH A WONDERFUL STAFF
MEANS IN TERMS OF PUBLIC POLICY
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT IS A GREAT STAFF. ALL RIGHT
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO REITERATE TO FOR SENATOR
UMBERG SAID- WE NOW HAVE-
BEFORE BILLS TO HEAR TODAY- WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE FIVE BUT A
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY FIVE BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORK SILVA HAS BEEN PULLED. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. AND
SO WE HAVE- SEVEN BILLS ON FILE
THREE OF WHICH ARE. CONSENT
ELIGIBLE AND SO LET'S GO TO
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR- AND-
IDENTIFY THOSE BILLS THEY ARE.
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU WITH
AMENDMENTS. AND FILE ITEM
SEVEN. AB THIRTY TWO FIFTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVED BY SENATOR
BORCHERS ALL ADAM. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS SENATORS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. JACKSON YES
SORRY TEXAN II BORJAS OR
DECIDED US SO I WRESTLE I
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I'M
MELINDA'S BLEND IS AYE MONNING
AYE MONNING AYE STERN. STERN I
AM BURKE NUMBER GUY- BURKE I
WAY CASKEY HI THE CASKET BY
NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT THEN THE
VOTERS NINE ZERO IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WAS ADOPTED. SO HERE'S HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS- HEARING
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM TO. WHICH IS AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU THAT WILL
GO FIRST. AFTER THAT WE WILL
RETURN AND FILE ORDER TO FILE
ITEM ONE. AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARIA TUCCI
AND THEN WE WILL CONTINUE IN
FILE EITHER- THERE AFTER FROM
TWELVE THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY WE
WILL BE TAKING A LUNCH BREAK.
AND WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF CHU AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MON. THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND- IF
OF I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
PROTOCOL BUT- IS OUR WAY WE
COULD HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MON COME FORWARD IS THE- DO WE
HAVE A CHAIR FOR HER. LETTER TO
COME A LITTLE CLOSER. LIKE BOX
EVERY TIME. OKAY ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD. LET'S GO AHEAD
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SENATORS LET ME FIRST
START AS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND LEND MY SALUTE ON THE HALF
OF OUR COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP- IN
PROTECTING THE CONSTITUTION AND
HELPING TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL WHICH IS
TRULY I THINK INDICATIVE OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
COMMITTEE- TO YOUR COLLEAGUES-
YOU'RE AMAZING SHARES SPENT
MANY MEETINGS WITH US- WE HAD
MANY DISCUSSIONS- AND THAT IS
NOT ONLY INDICATIVE THROUGH THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS BUT- NOT
THROUGH THE MANY AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE ADDED TO THIS BILL-
TO IMPROVE THE BILL. BUT TO
THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING THIS AND
I ALSO VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOU COMING ON TO THIS BILL AS A
AS THE SENATOR- PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WAS
WRITTEN TO AVERT A CRISIS. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON WHICH MADAM
CHAIR SERVICE RECENTLY DECIDED
TO LIFT ITS STATE WIDE
TEMPORARY FICTION MORATORIUM.
ON SEPTEMBER THE FIRST. WHEN
THE TEMPORARY FICTION BAN
EXPIRES. ALL RANCHERS IN OUR
STATE. WILL IMMEDIATELY- ANY.
AND ALL UNPAID RENT AT ONCE.
AND IF WE DON'T CHANGE STATE
LAW IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS. WE
WILL SEE A MASSIVE WAVE OF
EVICTIONS. THIS WILL BE
CATASTROPHIC FOR TENANTS.
PROPERTY OWNERS HOMELESSNESS
AND COVERED NINETEEN SPREAD.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
MANY TENANTS HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO PAY THE RENT. RENTERS HAVE
HAD TO STAY HOME. TO COMPLY
WITH SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS
AND COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS HAVE
LOST JOBS IN INCOME AS ECONOMY
HAS BEEN SHUT DOWN. WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION MANY WILL
LOSE THEIR HOME AT A TIME WHEN
COVERED CASES ARE STILL
DANGEROUSLY HIGH. I THINK EVERY
MEMBER OF OUR LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTANDS HOW UNFAIR THIS HAS
BEEN. GOVERNMENT ORDER PEOPLE
TO STAY HOME TO PREVENT COLDS
FRED. WE HAVEN'T PASSED NEW
LAWS TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE DON'T
LOSE THEIR HOMES. AND FOR SENSE
OF THE SCALE THE CRISIS. US
CENSUS DATA FROM JULY NINTH TO
THE FOURTEENTH INDICATED OVER
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA RENTERS REPORT QUOTE
LITTLE OR NO CONFIDENCE IN
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY NEXT
MONTH'S RENT. WELL ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS HAVE INDICATED THE
SAME LITTLE OR NO CONFIDENCE
ABOUT MAKING THEIR NEXT
MORTGAGE PAYMENT. AND WE KNOW
THAT SINCE JULY NINTH TO THE
FOURTEENTH THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR IN WEEKLY FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS EXPIRED. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX ALLOWS
TENANTS HOMEOWNERS AND SMALL
LANDLORDS IN FINANCIAL DISTRESS
TO TEMPORARILY THE FOR RENT AND
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS UNTIL
HOPEFULLY THE WORST OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS PASSED. BUT I KNOW
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
FULL EVENTUAL REPAYMENT OF ALL
DEFERRED AMOUNTS. THIS BILL HAS
TO HOUSE PROTECTIONS FOR
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
PROTECTIONS FOR STRUGGLING
PROPERTY OWNERS AND LANDLORDS.
ON THE TENNESSEE SIDE IF WE
DON'T CHANGE STATE LAW TENANTS
WILL BE AFFECTED AND LANDLORDS
WILL NEVER GET THE MONIES THAT
THEIR OWN. THIS BILL SIMPLE IT
SAYS TENANTS SHOULD BE SHOULD
NOT BE AFFECTED. FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO PAY THE RENT DURING.
OUR COVERT STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE SOME TIME
TO EVENTUALLY PAY THE BACK RENT
THAT THEY WROTE. OUR GOAL IS TO
GIVE RUNNERS A CHANCE TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET. WHILE
GIVING LANDLORDS AWAY TO
RECOVER RENT WITHOUT EXPENSIVE
EVICTION CASES. AND AGAIN LET
ME STRESS OUR BILL DOES NOT
CANCEL RENT OR RELIEF TENANTS
OF THEIR OBLIGATION TO PAY.
INSTEAD TO GIVE TENANTS A BREAK
TO WEATHER THE ECONOMIC CRISIS.
DISCUSS THE PROPERTY OWNER
AMANDA PROTECTIONS OF THIS BILL.
POLEMIC WE MUST PROTECT
STRUGGLING TENANTS FROM
EVICTIONS AND STRUGGLING
HOMEOWNERS AND LANDLORDS FROM
FORECLOSURE WE SIMPLY CANNOT
ALLOW A MASS WAVE OF EVICTIONS
AND FORECLOSURES TO OCCUR IN
CALIFORNIA ON OUR WATCH. THE
HUMAN SUFFERING WOULD BE
EXTRAORDINARY. IT WOULD LEAD TO
ENORMOUS INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS AND COVERED SPREAD
AND IT WOULD TURN A DEEP
RECESSION INTO A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY GREAT DEPRESSION. THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
WITH AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THIS BILL IS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THE TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS ARE
NOT AFFECTED FORCED OUT ONTO
THE STREETS GERMANY GLOBAL
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND I WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
ALMOST TWENTY CO AUTHORS OF OUR
BILL. AND TURN IT OVER TO THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BANKING
COMMITTEE AND OUR LEAD TO JOINT
AUTHORS SIMPLY NEVER MEDICALLY
MONTH. TO DISCUSS. A NUMBER OF
OTHER PROVISIONS BILL. MISSING
ON. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU N. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEóN
THE FLOOR SHORES. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND SENATORS AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX ADDRESSES CRITICAL
QUESTION THAT HAS BEEN FORCED
UPON US DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN
TECHNOMIC. DUE TO THE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THE VIRUS THAT
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
CONTAIN CONTAIN MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS OR HAVE SEEN DRASTIC
REDUCTIONS IN THEIR INCOMES.
THE FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THAT WERE HELPING
HOUSEHOLDS TO KEEP THEIR HEADS
ABOVE WATER HAVE EXPIRED. WITH
RENT MORTGAGES AND OTHER BILLS
COMING DUE. HOW ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES GOING TO
COPE WITH THIS TEMPORARY
REALITY. AS POLICY MAKERS WHAT
WE SHOULD DO IS PREVENT THE
WORST OUTCOMES THAT WILL RESULT.
IF NOTHING GETS DONE. WE CANNOT
STAND BY AND HOPE FOR THE BEST
WHEN SO MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR FRIENDS OUR
FAMILIES OUR NEIGHBORS ARE
FACING DIRE THREAT OF BEING
DISPLACED FROM THEIR HOME. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX IS A
PROPOSAL FOR STABILIZING THE
HOUSING SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA
AS WE CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO
FIGHT THIS HEALTH PANDEMIC.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU HAS MADE A
STRONG CASE FOR THE TENANT
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL. AND I
WILL FOCUS ON THE HOMEOWNER AND
LAMBERT PROTECTIONS THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE BEST
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. WOULD
BE THE MEDIA ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING TO HELP TENANTS
LANDLORDS AND HOMEOWNERS WHO
ARE FACING FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS
DUE TO THE VIRUS. BUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED
TO ACT AND WE KNOW FROM PASSING
OUR OWN STATE BUDGET IN JUNE
THAT THE STATE SIMPLY DOES NOT
HAVE THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
TO EXPLORE THAT OPTION. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO SUPPLEMENTING
THE INCOMES TODAY AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX PROPOSES MECHANISM
FOR DEFERRING EXPENSES UNTIL
THE WORST OF THE CRISIS HAS
SUBDUED. MR TO DESCRIBE HOW
THESE MECHANISMS THAT WOULD
WORK FOR TENANTS BUT THE BILL
ALSO PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND LANDLORDS TO
RECEIVE SIMILAR RELIEF BY
SEEKING MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE
THROUGH THEIR SERVICER. AS
REFLECTED INTHE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE PROVISIONS OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BUILT
AROUND AND LARGELY REFLECT THE
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED TO BARS
UNDER THE FEDERAL CARES ACT.
WELL THE CURES ACT PROVIDES
PROTECTIONS TO BAR IS A
FEDERALLY BACKED MORTGAGES
SIMILAR LEGAL PROTECTIONS DO
NOT EXIST FOR OTHER MORTGAGE
BORROWERS WHICH REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY 30% OR MORE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MARKET. THE
PRIMARY OBJECTIVE OF THE
MORTGAGE PREVENTS OF THIS BILL
ARE THE FOLLOWING. FIRST
PROVIDE A SIMILAR LEGAL
PROTECTIONS FOR BARS OF NON
FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS AS THE
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED FOR THE
FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS. SECOND
ENSURE THAT HELPFUL INFORMATION
IS PROVIDED TO BORROWERS SO
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE TERMS
OF FORBEARANCE. AND THE
POTENTIAL REPAYMENT OPTIONS
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE TO THEM
AFTER THE FORBEARANCE PERIOD
ENDS. THIRD PROVIDE A LEGAL
REMEDY TO BORROW SO THAT THEY
CAN PROTECT THEIR HOME FROM FOR
CLOSURE IN THE EVENT THAT
AMERICA MORTGAGE SERVICER HAS
NOT OFFERED THEM FORBEARANCE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CARERS ACT.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE NOT
REQUIRING THAT PAYMENTS BE
CANCELLED OR FORGIVEN. WE ARE
NOT SAYING THAT ANYONE CAN STOP
PAYING THEIR MORTGAGE THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE LIMITED TO ONLY
THOSE WHO ARE EXPERIENCE THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. WHAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR IS MORE TIME TO MAKE
PAYMENTS AND TO GIVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS SOME FORM OF
STABILITY IN THESE VERY
UNCERTAIN TIMES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND- WILL NOW GO TO
ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS. AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I HAVE INSTITUTED
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY THOSE
MAIN WITNESSES AND IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED
A TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT
BECAUSE I'M TOLD WE'VE GOT AT
LEAST THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE NOW.
LINED UP WHO WISH TO INDICATE I
BELIEVE IT WERE ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE OF THIS SO WE ARE GOING TO
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
LISTENING. AFTER WE HAVE OUR
TWO MAIN WITNESSES WE ARE GOING
TO SIMPLY ALLOW YOU TO GIVE US
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION
WHETHER IT'S AN ORGANIZATION OR
WHETHER YOU'RE JUST A TENANT OR
JUST A PERSON ON THE STREET.
JUST TELL US WHO YOU ARE. AND
THEN YOUR POSITION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I DON'T MEAN
JUST THE PERSON ON THE STREET
YOU ARE AS IMPORTANT AS ANYONE
ELSE BUT- WE WANT YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. AND IF
YOU KEEP TALKING I'M GOING TO
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE WHEN IT
CUTS OFF. WE'VE GOT- TOO MANY
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO. STEP IN AND
STEP UP AND WE WANT TO LET EACH
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR YOUR NAME
SO WITH THAT. I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
JEREMY MILLER GENEVIEVE A-
PRICELESS. AND BRIAN A GUSTO OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF MODERATOR
IS THAT CORRECT. I'M JUST LIKE
pA BRIAN IS HERE YES HI. THEY
LIKE TO NINE- GERMAN
FORTUNATELY IS WAS OUR TENANT
ADVOCATE AND HE'S IN THE
HOSPITAL SO HE WILL NO THAT'S
OKAY THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT AND
WE WISH. MR MILLER A QUICK
RECOVERY SO WE WILL HAVE A
GENEVIEVE A- AND BRIAN AS OUR
WITNESSES BRIAN IS HERE
PRESIDENT TO DO WE HAVE
GENEVIEVE ON THE PHONE. YES WE
DO HAVE A HEN- REVERT YOU FLUFF
ON THE PHONE SHE'S ME HEAD OF
THE MY APOLOGIES- SO WHY DON'T
WE START WITH YOU HAVE A VISA
AND- AGAIN TOGETHER YOU HAVE
FOUR MINUTES AND I'M GOING TO
BE. KIND OF STRICT ABOUT THIS
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
SHARE THOSE TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD. OF THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AND ALL
THAT BY EACH LAP I AM A
LANDMARK AMONG OTHER LABOR
LABELS I'M ALSO AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL A MOM A FRIEND AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE AND IN NEED OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. I AM
FAIRLY NEW TO BEING A LANDMARK
HARPER I AM NOT NEW TO POLICY.
AND I KNOW THE JOB OF POLICY IN
THE JOB OF GOVERNMENT IS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE DOES THEIR
PART. FAIRLY AND EQUITABLY TO
SUPPORT STRONGER SOCIETY. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX DOES THAT I
HAVE EXPERIENCED. QUITE A LOT.
AT TEN MILLION FELLOW CAL. AT
THE LAND I YOU NEED TO PROTECT.
JUST LIKE THE TENANT WHO LIVE
IN MY HOME AND OTHER. AND
COURSE. EVERY DAY. LIKE THEM I
TO KNOW THAT I WILL NOT BE AT
MY HOUSE. I NEED TO KNOW THAT I
WILL BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN MYSELF
MY FAMILY- THAT'S QUITE THAT.
UNDER CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES. AN
IDEAL WAY TO AVOID A LOOMING
HOUSING CATASTROPHE AND
WORSENING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN CALIFORNIA. IT
TURNS YOUR LEGISLATION
ADDRESSING THE FINANCIAL MEANS
ABOUT. MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY QUICKLY BACK. I NEED AND
FOR THAT WE I SUPPORT IT I HAD
CHOSEN QUICKLY CLIMB FROM DAY
TO DAY COULD CLASSIFY BECAUSE I
SUPPORT THE- DEPT IN WORD LOOK
AGENT. HAVE NOT TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE TENANTS MANY OF
HOMES IN MY- CLICK AND PREPARE
THE FOOD. THANK ME KEEP OUR
PARKS RECREATION. THEY CAN
CLEAN AND CARE FOR OUR KIDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EIGHT
VOTE FOR MY SAFETY AND SECURITY
FOR MY NEIGHBORS THANK YOU. AND
FOR OUR STATE THANK YOU UNCLE.
THIRTY FIVE PM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TEST FROM MR GUSTER THE-
YOU YOU GO ABOUT TWO MEN CENTER
SECONDS. OUT OF CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RYAN ADDRESSED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. A PART OF A GROUP
OF ORGANIZATIONS SPONSORING
THIS MEASURE. JUST A FEW
POINTS. NEAR THE STATE WE'RE IN
A ONCE IN A GENERATION.
ECONOMIC CRISIS AS A RESULT OF
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND LIKE
MUCH OF THE DECISIVE ACTION
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN. TO DATE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH WE
BELIEVE EQUALLY BOLD. AND
DECISIVE ACTION IS NEEDED TO-
STABILIZE THE RENTAL HOUSING
MARKET AND PROTECT RENTERS FROM
THE FOLLOWING CATASTROPHE OF
THE POTENTIAL OF MASS
EVICTIONS. WE ALSO NEED TO
ENSURE AS WE JUST HEARD FROM A
PREVIOUS WITNESS THAT WE
PROTECT SMALL LANDLORDS WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A CRISIS FOR. ALL
SECTORS. BERMAN BUT ONE
CRITICAL PIECE OF THE POLICY TO
SOLVE THAT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY
AN ESSENTIAL POLICY OF THIS AS
AS BOTH AUTHORS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT. IS THAT WE SHOULD NOT
PUNISH TENANTS. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THROUGH ADDICTION FOR SOMETHING
THAT WAS BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
THE STATE HOME THEY DIDN'T GO
TO WORK WE ASK THEM TO DO THAT
THEY'VE DONE THAT AND NOW WE
NEED TO PROTECT THEM. FROM
EVICTION. BUT ONE CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE IS THAT THIS HAS
IMPACTED FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS 31% OF.
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA MAYBE
AS MUCH AS 42% OR MORE WE DON'T
KNOW BUT WE KNOW. THAT THOSE
FOLKS FACE A CLIFF IF WE DO NOT
ACT BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
ADJOURNS AND ONE WAY IN WHICH
WE CAN ACT IS TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT THEM FROM THE VENTURA
TAKING AFFECTION OFF THE TABLE
BUT AS MR CHIU HAS SAID THAT WE
ARE NOT. WAVING THE RENT. BUT
TO ALLOW A MASSIVE REDUCTIONS
WILL NOT SOLVE THIS CRISIS IT
WILL NOT PUT MORE MONEY IN
ANYBODY'S POCKET WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT ALL
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS. AND WE AND
PUT THIS POLICY IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THOSE MILLIONS OF
RENTERS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
FIND THEMSELVES DISPLACED OR
HOMELESS. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ALL WITHIN THE
TIME LIMIT MUCH APPRECIATED AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE.
TO ASK IF THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO THREE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANYONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY SCENE NO ONE. WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR AS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND AGAIN I WANT TO
REMIND YOU NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE WAITING TO
GIVE US THAT INFORMATION WE
HAVE GOT TO MOVE THIS ALONG SO-
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WE WILL BEGIN. SIX AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY
NEED TO PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE FOUR THREE SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD. LINE TO
TWENTY NINE NINE TWO TWO NINE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING YOU MAY PROCEED MORNING.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BOBBY
LOPEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF BOX
THE CARD TIED TO INCREDIBLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN LINE AT
ONE EIGHT ONE NINE THE LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALAN KNIGHT I'M HOMELESS MEMBER
ADVANTAGE UNITED NETWORK IN LA
COUNTY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE LINE
TWO SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MENEMEN. THE HEAD. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU. A CERTAIN THE LINE IS OPEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
NOT GETTING ANY RESPONSE
REMOVING NINETY LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE LINE TWO
TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR CHRISTOPHER SANTIAGO
CHILE THE COALITION REMAINING
ARRIVED IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN LINE FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WOULD
BE FANTASTIC SEIU CALIFORNIA
INCOME SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE LINE LINE THIRTY
ONE LINE THREE ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. BAGGY GRAY WILL MAKE YOU
HAPPY W. LECTERN STATE COUNCIL
AND STRONG SUPPORT YEAH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
TO LINE TWO SEVEN EIGHT YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. YEAH ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BOTHER GOING TO HUNDRED AND
FORTY LINE TWO FOUR ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO OF NEOVIA
NEW YORK FROM THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN LINE TWO SEVEN
SEVEN GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
RUSH COPLEY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
TWENTY ONE LINE TWO ONE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ALEXANDER EARNED AN INNER CITY
LAW CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
LINE TWO ONE ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING POSITION
DEFENDER CABRERA WITH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COLISTIN FRESNO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
LINE ONE TWO THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME'S
VIRGINIA MADSEN I'M AN ELDERLY
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIANS
IS STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS. WE
WOULD SAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND.
TWENTY FOUR NINE FOUR TWO FOUR.
BURKE AND WITH THE SAME THE-
THANKS FOR TWENTY FOUR WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN IF YOU WANT
TO CHECK YOUR MUTE. GOOD
MORNING. SO SIX WITNESS PLEASE.
HERE THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LINE TWO FIVE ZERO. ONE
CONCERN. I WOULD GO AHEAD LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO FIVE
ZERO THE LINE IS OPEN. I WILL
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO LINE TWO
NINE TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LOOKING AT A
LONG LONG TIME TO TAKE
INTRACTABLE TENANTS TOGETHER WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THE
LINE NINETY NINE NINE NINE NINE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WELL I NINETY
NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN. PLEASE ON ANIMAL
AMADA A COUPLE SCOTT HAD MULTI
FAMILY MANAGING AGENT AND I AM
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WILL
GET THANK YOU WILL NOTE THAT
WE'RE HERE NOW ASKING ONLY FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. BUT NOW HE'S A
GENTLEMAN AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FOUR THREE SIX YOU MAY JOIN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AGAIN WE ARE
ON SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU WE GO TO
LINE NUMBER. SEVENTY NINE NINE
SEVEN NINE CAN'T VERY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER JANET MAY I AM
NOT OPPOSITION. LITTLE CHAU
NOTED WE ARE NOW THOUGH TAKING
SUPPORT ONLY SUPPORT ONLY
PLEASE THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MADAME. MODERATOR SHOULD GO
AHEAD TO THE NEXT NUMBER. THANK
YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO EXIT THE QUEUE YOU CAN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU DO NOT
WISH TO BE IN THE QUEUE I WILL
GO TO MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN LINE TWO ONE SIX GO
AHEAD. WHAT HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY TWO LINE SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MICHELLE PARRIS THAT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE SPEAKING ON BEHALF- AB
ONE TO THIRTY SIX CO SPONSORS
WHICH INCLUDE HOUSING NOW
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL POLICY LAND
AND PUBLIC COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. EXCEPT
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT MINE EACH
EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS GRANT RICH
I MAY- TENANT IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M AND VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT
IS MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX NINE TWO SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO BROAD ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
IT'S NOT LIKE TO GO AND GET THE
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THE GOVERNMENT OF. THE I NEVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN LINE
FOUR ONE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOW DO YOU SEE WHAT THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YEAH ALL ORGANIZATION. AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOUR NEXT
NUMBER NEXT WITNESS PLEASE OUT
OF SORRY ABOUT THAT ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE LINE ONE EACH
NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING MADAM CHAIR FUNDING TO
PJ JOHNSON AND AMERICANS
REPRESENTING PASADENA TENANTS
UNION AND I AM VERY STRONG
SUPPORT I AM GARGI TEACHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. EXIT ALSO.
INPUT IS ALWAYS ON. THANK YOU
THAT IS LINE NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN LINE AT NINE SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. YOU. PEOPLE
SECTION THANK YOU THANKS GOING
HEADLINE NINETY SEVEN. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT NOW
WITH THE FINAL POINT EIGHT
EARNINGS IN STRONG SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
WE HAVE OUT. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE LINE ONE
TWO ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS HORRIBLE COVER WITH A
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE Y.
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE TWO SEVEN ZERO. WITH
EIGHT LOT OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
EMPOWER. AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE JUST A MOMENT. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHT SIX WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU GO
AHEAD. OKAY HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GIOVANNA MORALIS WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY A CO SPONSOR
OF THE SPELL IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. BY NUMBER
THIRTY THAT'S LINE NUMBER THREE
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. IAN
GAMELIN WITH THE RENTER IN
MENTOR- WITH THE VENTURA
KENNETT UNION AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FOUR SEVEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE LINE
FOUR SIX FIVE BILLION. HI MY
NAME IS NOT ANOTHER YES AT A
MANILA CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE SOMEWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT WILL BE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THAT FINE THREE EIGHT ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY.
RIGHT CALIFORNIA AND FROM THE
PORT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THAT IS
LINE FOR THREE ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY LINE THREE SIX ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. EXACTLY GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
CALLING IN FRIENDS MEDIUM
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
LINE THREE SEVEN SIX YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOE WE
PLAY GOMES LOVE I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE LINE
TWO EIGHT FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ONE OF THE AS MY
NAME IS AND I THINK THAT MY AND
I DIDN'T AND I AM PROUD OF THEM
NOW IF UNITED BELL GARDENS AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE FILL. OUT
MY NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY LINE. THREE THREE ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS FALL YEAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
LEGISLATIVE TENURE MANAGER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE LINE FOUR NINE
THREE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE AFFILIATION ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI'S REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
ONE NINE FOUR ZERO ONE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JENNY AND NKOSI I'M THE
REGIONAL ADVISER FOR FAITH IN
THE VALLEY REPRESENTING OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DIRECTLY
IMPACTED RESIDENTS IN THE
FRESNO KERN MERCED STANISLAUS
BAND JOAQUIN COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE LINE FOUR NINE FIVE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CAN'T BE ON
BEHALF OF NEW A. W. LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
REPRESENTING OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND ACADEMIC STUDENT
EMPLOYEES THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE THREE HUNDRED AND CANNOT
LINE THREE ONE ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN SENATORS
KIANA SAID TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA AND PART OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE LINE
FOUR THREE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. MARK MY NAME IS POONAM
ARE MAJORITY ON BEHALF OF THE
POLITICIANS AND LEADERS OF
TOMORROW GROUP FROM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT LINE TWO FIVE EIGHT
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. A LINE TO
FIFTY EIGHT WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. HELLO HELLO WE'VE
GOT TO PUT TELL US YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION PARTY. HELLO
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR-
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR YEARS
OF SERVICE TO THINK THANK YOU
SO MUCH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BERMAN HOW WONDERFUL I KNEW
TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU MY
NAME IS OPEN THE STATE
AFFILIATION. IS SHAME ON THIS
LEGISLATURE MY POSITION IS
BLAME THE FED YOUR YOU THINK
HE'S HER AND THANK YOU YOU SEE
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY LINE FOR ONE EACH YOU
NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
GET MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND-
LEGISLATORS. MY NAME IS
ANASTACIO ANNAPOLIS I'M A
SENIOR TENANTS AND MEMBER OF
SAN FRANCISCO TENANTS UNIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND.
EIGHTY SIX NINE THREE EIGHT
SIX. MY NAME IS PATRICIA IDEA.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOR LYING TO EACH FOR YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU READY FOR
THE LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. HELLO GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BE TO BE OF AN EXACT I
AM A MEMBER OF EIGHT. LOTS TO
AND HOMELESSNESS NOW AND I WILL
CONSTITUENT OF MISTER HERTZBERG
I SPEAK FOR ALL THAT NIGHT WHO
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET THE
AID THAT THEY NEED BUT WE ARE A
100% APPROVING AND SUPPORTING
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF A PROMOTIONAL
DURING. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR
NINE. NINE FOUR YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI MARY INTELLISENSE AND
I'M A CANNIBALISTIC COULD HURT
HOUSING ACTION COMMITTEE AND I
FOUND THAT AB. EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE LINE TWO TWO FIVE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. AS THE STORY
TRICHET WITH THE RESIDENTS
UNITED NETWORK AT HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND- FORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX LINE FOUR
FOUR SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME BUT THE EXAMINE THE BOX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EIGHT AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX BECAUSE I'M A SINGLE
MOM THANK YOU AND I HAVEN'T
WORKED SINCE MARCH TWENTY SIX
PRECIADO TESTIMONY THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR ACTUALLY WE HAVE LINE AT
NUMBER FOUR FOUR FIVE ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE THE LINE
IS OPEN. HEADLINE FOUR FOUR
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. NINE FOUR FORTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN EVEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY YOUR
RESPONSE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FOR FIVE NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS
A LOT OF THOSE FOLLOWERS AND A
MEMBER OF A SAN DIEGO AND THE
INVEST IN SENEGAL FAMILIES
COALITION. I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
LINE TWO SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING THIS INSURANCE
FOR OLD WITH A SANTA- A RANCHER
AND GENITALIUM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. BLIND
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE LINE THREE FIVE FIVE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
RACHEL MARKETS I AM A RENTER
AND CANTERO THAT CALIFORNIA AND
I'M WITH THE- AND UNION AND WE
ARE IN. PART THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EACH
LINE OF ONE ZERO EIGHT YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ERIC FIRTH I MEAN INTERCOUNTY
TEN AT YOUR IN OXNARD OF
POLLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YEAH WE HAVE Y. NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE AT
LINE TWO EIGHT THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ONE
ALTHOUGH THE REPRESENTING THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE IN
OAKLAND AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO FOUR NINE. YES MY NAME IS A
PRINCESS CUT TAURUS FROM. COSTA
COUNTY AND YES ON A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK AND
OTHER SPANISH SPEAKERS ON THE
LINE. ONE EIGHT SEVEN WE GOT
BEAT UP WITH A LOT. GO AHEAD
LOOK. OKAY MY NAME IS JUANITA
RANGEL IN I MEMBERS OF THE H.
FOUR CALIFORNIA AND I
INTRACTABLE FOUR DAYS WELL SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
BOTH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND
LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE ONE FOUR SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JUGGLING GOT A DONOR AND A
MEMBER OF ANY ANIMAL BUSINESS
OWNER AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR LINE
THREE FORSWORN EVEN GO AHEAD.
WE WANTED WE ARE- WE NEED
SERGIO VARGAS- TO PREVENT THEM
NEED THAT COME IN WE NEED TO
ACT AT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX SO
WE ARE IN TERMS OF POWER AND
WITH A THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO LINES FOR EACH
TO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING. THIS IS IGOR TRIANGLE.
I AM AN EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY LEGISLATION CHAIR OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AT A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND ALL THREE
OF THE BODIES I FOR ONE. HAVE
PROBABLY ENDORSED FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
LINE TWO ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
AS I DO AND- I'M A TENANT AND A
MEMBER OF THE UNION THEN IT'S
NOT OF BELL GARDENS- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR TO DATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN LINE FOUR EIGHT
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ARGHA RODRIGUEZ AND
I AM WITH THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ENVIRONMENT ALLIANCE. I AM ALSO
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL TULARE
COUNTY AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE Y. NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. A LINE FOR FIVE
TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS LANA POP I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EVICTION
DEFENSE NETWORK I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL LAWYERS
GUILD ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT- THE
HEALTHY LA COALITION WHICH IS
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
ORGANIZATIONS. ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU. YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT I HAVE MY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
LINE THREE TO. GO AHEAD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE THREE TWENTY TWO.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE NUMBER OF MEN
THINK OF ANY FELONY EIGHT I AM
A STRONG SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I HAVE LINE JUST
A MOMENT. I HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
LINE TWO NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MLS'S OR. SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YOU DON'T KNOW. THANK YOU. I
WAS A LITTLE THAT'LL BE GOOD
FUN. OKAY THANK YOU I WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THE LINE IS
OPEN LINE FOR ONE TO. HI MY
NAME IS JOHN NOLTE I'M WITH
PUSH WHICH IS PRAMANA UNITED
FOR STABLE HOUSING AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY LINE Q.
EIGHT ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
ORGANS WITHOUT ALL THAT WOULD
HAPPEN LONG BEFORE YOU. AND MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI NINE TWO EIGHT ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. BEAR OKAY
WE'RE GONNA CROSS THAT LINE.
WELL I ON A CUTE YES TO MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT WITNESS PLACE. A
NUMBER THREE TWO NINE THREE
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
MY NAME IS IBRAHIM BANGOR- AND
I'M AN ORGANIZER WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT
PERSON IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU.
I HAVE A LINE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BABY ALONG
ARMENIAN SUPPORT I'M AND THEN
ALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE Y.
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE LINE FOUR FOUR THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
HEAD. ALL RIGHT MY NAME IS
DONALD LANG AND I AM A MEMBER
AS I'M A RESIDENT AT ITS- AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT. THE
MEASURE SB. FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
WITNESS- WILL BE MY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN ONE
THREE ONE SEVEN GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE ONE
SEVEN. ALL AMID COMMITTEE UP ON
THOUGH AND I'M A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS I HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THEM SINCE MARCH
PLEASE VOTE NOW. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WERE TAKING CHANNEL
MANAGER IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AT THIS POINT TIME BUT
WE WILL NOT YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE FOUR THREE
SIX. WE WILL GO OUT TO LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE NINE THREE EIGHT ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELEN DOHERTY A
MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AT THE COURT HEARD IN
SAN JOSE AND PEOPLE ACTING IN
COMMUNITY TOGETHER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
NINE THREE THREE EIGHT YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AN
INSPIRATION A MULTILINE FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT AND I IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND THREE LINE FOUR
ZERO THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR ZERO THREE WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU. ONE FOUR
ZERO THREE IF YOU WANT TO CHECK
YOUR MUTE FEATURE WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN. LET'S MOVE ON
NATIONAL MODERATOR. I WILL GO
TO. MY NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE FIVE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. LET'S MOVE ON AND- ADAMS
WELL OR NOT KILL NEXT TO LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN. THAT IS LINE THREE ONE
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU. GOOD MORNING CATHERINE
THIS IS MARTHA CORDERO LANDLORD
AND A MEMBER OF- EIGHT AND
ENTERING SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE LINE
THREE FIVE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. A LINE THREE FIFTY THREE
THE LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WANT TO
CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE. ONE
MORE TIME AND THEN WE'LL GO ON
NOT GETTING A RESPONSE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S GO ON. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER STE. JUST A
MOMENT. WE HAVE MY NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIVE SIX THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY SPEAK. GOOD MORNING
WHERE MEMBERS VOTED OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE A FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FIVE THREE SEVEN.
INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITED HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE ONE SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE SEVENTY THREE WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. YEAH HI- MY NAME IS
NORMAL- AMERO- THE REDLANDS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M A MEMBER
OF H. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT-
MEASURE FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE. A LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX
LINE THREE EIGHT SIX YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GO AHEAD LINE THREE
EIGHTY SIX WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. ARE THERE IS NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PERSON IN THE QUEUE. THAT
IS LINE NUMBER. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE BLIND NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO NINE
THREE THREE TO THE LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
THREE Q. LET'S MOVE ON MATHEMA
MODERATOR IS LIMIT LET ME ASK
THIS IS THERE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL GLITCH HER PEOPLE
JUST SIMPLY NOT ON THE PHONE
WHEN WE CALL SHOULD WE TRY TO
GET BACK TO THEM. OR IS ARE
THEY JUST SIMPLY HANGING UP. I
AM NOT SURE IF THEY'RE HANGING
UP BY I AM NOT SURE OKAY FAIR
ENOUGH. LET'S GO AHEAD WITH THE
NEXT WITNESS IN. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOUR LINE FOUR ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESEARCH THAT
CAN WITH THE NATIONAL HOUSING
LAW PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND EACH LINE FIVE ZERO
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS THE ONTARIO CUT A HOLE ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER REPORTS WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX NINE FOUR
SIX SIX THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SHE ON A
POLITICAL IRATE OVER AND
REPRESENTING POLICY LINK A CO
SPONSOR OF THAT BATTLE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE Y. NUMBER. FOUR HUNDRED
LINE FOUR ZERO ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE FOUR
HUNDRED YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S JOSE LOPEZ I'M CALLING
FOR- THE ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT IN SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. I NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE NINE FOUR SIX
NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA LIVINGSTON I
AM BLESSED WITH THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY GROUP
EIGHT BUT RATHER THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBER FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX SACRAMENTO THE WINNING
ELECTIONS AND I'M THAT WILL
DEVASTATE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT. NINE
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING OF
FOUR SEVENTY WE HAVE AN OPEN.
LONDON OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON IN
THE QUEUE ARE DEADLINE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR
SIX. NINE FORTY SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
LET'S MOVE ON THEN OKAY AND
THANK. THANK YOU. I HAVE MY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR LINE FIVE FOUR FOUR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FOUR WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. LET'S MOVE
ON. HE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
HAVE MY NUMBER. FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN ONE MMHM ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE I GET THE
LINE OPEN LINE FOR SIX SEVEN
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU. OKAY WELL LET LEVINE ONE
MOMENT. THAT LINE DISCONNECTED
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY LINE
FIVE FOUR ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY. HI MY
NAME IS MARTHA BRADY KIM I'M A
LAWYER IN SAN FRANCISCO I WORK
IN THE STATE PLANNING AND ON
HOLD BY A COLLEGE HERE ON
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES VERY
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
MY NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
THREE LINE THREE ZERO THREE YOU.
CAN OKAY HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH
AGREEMENTS ALLEN HILL I'M A
MEMBER OF SACRED HEART HOUSING
ACTION COMMITTEE AND I'M
CALLING IN IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE NEEDED
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED AND. TWENTY TWO
ONE FIVE TWO TWO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE
TWENTY TWO WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. HELLO YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
MELVIN THE LOCAL MEMBER OF
EIGHTH AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
RICHMOND CITY COUNCIL AND I'LL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORKING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE NINE ONE EIGHT NINE
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY YES INDEED. HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY AND BRANDON AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE YWCA SILICON
VALLEY AS A HOUSING SPECIALIST
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN LINE AT FIVE ONE EIGHT
FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE AT FIVE ONE FIVE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN. LET'S
MOVE ON MANTA MODERATOR OKAY.
WE ARE MOVING ON TO LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
LINE ONE SEVEN FIVE. HI GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. GO AHEAD
YES NUMBER ONLY KHADI. YES YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES INDEED. ALL
RIGHT GOOD MORNING MEANS
FINDING IT ON THE CARD YES I
REPRESENT I WAS ON VACATION
EIGHT SO I AGAIN I BROUGH A
HUNDRED PERCENT. A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE LINE TWO FIVE ONE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. IN THE QUEUE IN
PUBLIC COUNCIL ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EACH
LINE AT ONE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE ONLY
HEADLINE ONE EACH. CITY ONE OF
THE OF THE NUMBERS OF LOCAL
TORTILLA. MEMBERS OF THE ABSENT
OF THE CONDO IN THE FRONT THAT
COMES UP WITH. THANK YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE BEEN ON OKAY WE THE
SO THAT AVERAGE POSTED IN A
STATE BUT ALSO WOULD OKAY LOOK
DO NOT. AND THAT'S A LOOK
WALDRON THEY ON OPEN BUT OUR
POWERLESS TO. THANK YOU NUMBER
YOU IN OUR- IN THE STATE
LARGEST THANK YOU MUCH. US
SENATOR ROGER WE YOU HELP FOR
THAT FOR ME. THANK YOU FOR. BUT
SO. NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU OUR NEXT IS
A LINE SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
LINE SIX ONE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS
JACKIE IS MERRY I AM WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNION POWERMAT ACE AND I AM
CALLING FROM OAKLAND TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ALLOWED TO RESELL LIANG-
THERESA WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN
FOR YOU. YES SHE RECENTLY AND
THEN THE OFFICE ON CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PREVENTION AND THAT
THE H. N. STRONG OPPOSE. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
WE ARE TRYING TO REMINDER GET
ONLINE ONLY THOSE AT THE MOMENT
IN SUPPORT AND WELL- I MENTION
THAT- MATTER MODERATE HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE.
OSTENSIBLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE I'VE GOT THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT EIGHTY PEOPLE HOW
MANY ARE LEFT. IHAVE- PROBABLY
ANOTHER- EIGHTY STILL IN THE
QUEUE. RIGHT AND THIS IS IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT IS THAT
CORRECT. ODD THAT IS CORRECT
ONE SECOND PLEASE. AGAIN AS A
REMINDER PLEASE THOSE IN THE
QUEUE NOW SHOULD BE CALLING IN
SUPPORT. OF A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX WERE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT ONLY. WITH THAT. BETTER
MODERATORS LET'S PROCEED WITH
THE NEXT WITNESS. OKAY THANK
YOU WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
ZERO TWO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE TWO
ZERO TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SERRA KELLY I'M AT
TEN AND THE NUMBER OF EIGHT
NINE IN STRONG. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE LINE TWO
SIX FIVE WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
MANY MANY COLLECTED ONE DAY I'M
A GRADUATE STUDENT AT THE UCLA
FIELDING SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
UNION ANYTHING EDIBLE GARDENS
WHERE OVER 85% OF RESIDENTS ARE
RENTERS. AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE THE COURT AB. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ARE WE HAVE
Y. NUMBER OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE ONE MOMENT. ONE FIVE
SIX FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
CLEAN UP THERE THIS CANNON KILL
FOR THE SALE OF PRODUCTS JONES
PORT FOOTBOARD THIS IS AMY SURE
WITH ACE OF THE QUESTIONS
REALLY DO MEAN MORE DEATHS YES
ON THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. AND MADAME CURIE
BELIEVE WE ONLY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SIX IN THE
QUEUE NOT EATING BECAUSE I WAS
LOOKING ALSO AT SOME PHONE
LINES THAT HAVE DISCONNECTED OR
DROPPED FROM THE MEETING- WE
HAVE Y. NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN NEXT THANK YOU SO I
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
MUCH APPRECIATED. PLEASE
PROCEED GO HEAD. I HAD ONE
MORNING THAT MEANT. GOOD
MORNING YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU MORNING MY NAME IS
REYES ONSITE OFFENSE I HAVE
MANY MEMORIES ON BIKES AND I
AND THE COMMUNITY GROUPS EIGHT
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT AND I
STRONGLY AND YOU KNOW URGED YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT AB. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE WINE NUMBER. FIVE
THIRTY AM TWENTY EIGHT LINE
FIVE TO THE ONE MOMENT. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
VERONICA WITH CATHOLIC
CHARITIES ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PROGRAM AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE
EIGHT FIVE. I'M SURE MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE NINE TWO
SIX NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JOE
THROUGH BY LINE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION WITH A LARGER THREE
NOTHING COLLECTION IN THE
COUNTRY WITH THREE HUNDRED
MEMBER ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. I HAVE Y. NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT POINT
SIX FOR EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
A SIX FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. THEY'RE NOT
WORKING THIS IS KARL KELLY FROM
SANTA CRUZ CAN BE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. JUST
A MOMENT.
THE OPERATOR YOU JUST
HAVE TO REFRESH MY SCREEN ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AB ONE NUMBER
SIX FIVE THREE. FIVE THREE WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NUMBER SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THREE. SIX FIVE THREE
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY I NO
RESPONSE JUST A MOMENT. YEAH.
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE SIX TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS BILL
TRIP AND I'M ORIGINALLY RAN OUT
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND A
MEMBER OF A I STRONGLY FORTY
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HE ONE MOMENT. I HAVE. MY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND. THIRTY
THREE NINE FIVE THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NAVNEET FUND DAHLE ON
BEHALF OF THE SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
Q. ONE MOMENT. I MY NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVEN LINE IS SIX
ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. YEAH WHY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE LINE FIVE SIX NINE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FIVE SIXTY NINE. ARE THEY HAVE
TO. DROPPED OUT WE'LL LET ME
FIND THE NEXT PERSON IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER'S
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
LINE IS THREE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ARIELLE SHINE IN THE REGION IN
OAKLAND I'M FINE WITH YOU THINK
FOR EVERYONE IN THE ACTION AND
SHAUN. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. AND MY NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO POINT
SIX SEVEN TWO THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIX SEVENTY TWO.
LAUREN PETTY IN YOUR
INVISIBILITY ACTION SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN LINE AT
FOUR ONE NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS TASHA POWELL
DIRECTOR OF ONE REDWOOD CITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. HAVE Y. NUMBER
SEVEN HUNDRED AND. SEVEN LINE
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN AND YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YEAH GOOD MORNING HI
DONNA HERE PRICE OF THE BEND
THE ARC SAN LUIS OBISPO BRENT
MILLION FAMILIES WELL IN THE
FAMILY FILE COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. WERE ALL WRONG SUPPORT
AND AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. HE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. I HAVE Y. NUMBER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWELVE POINT SEVEN
ONE TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS TO BE PUT ON I AM A
YIMBY ACTION NUMBER CALLING
SOME OF THE MORE AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU. A
MOMENT. I HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWO NINE SEVEN
THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YES MY NAME AS WELL
AS HIS I'M SO SUPPORTER OF AB
FORTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE HI. AND. THANK YOU I ONE
MOMENT PLEASE LET THEM EIGHTEEN
HE MATTER JUST NEED TO REFRESH
THE SCREEN ONE MOMENT. OKAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE FOUR THREE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FOUR THREE
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO. WE HAVE Y. NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN TWO
NINE SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN.
FORMALIZES THOMASON SAPPORO YOU
TO SIX THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
HOMELESS THANK YOU SO MUCH YES.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU AYE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FOUR THREE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY I
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT.
THAT'S OF THE HOPE HOLD ON WE
APPARENTLY DO HAVE PEOPLE SO IF
YOU WOULD GIVE US A MOMENT TO
WORK WITH YOU. MADAM MODERATOR
I AM I. NINETY THEM ON MY
SCREEN NOW OKAY WE DO HAVE FOR
ABOUT THIRTY MORE. TO CONTINUE.
FIFTY THREE OKAY I'M HERE FIFTY
THREE MORE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
AND AGAIN I'M GOING TO ADMONISH
FOLKS WE WANT YOU TO RESPOND IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT WE WILL THEN
HAVE TIME. FOLLOWING THIS FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION BUT PLEASE
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE YOU SHOULD BE LINED UP
IN THE QUEUE IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL CALL UPON
YOU TO CALL IN AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME RIGHT NOW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ONLY AND
SO WITH THAT MADAME MODERATOR
WHICH WOULD YOU BRING UP THE
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
LINE EACH TO ONE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD A
TWENTY ONE. HELLO THIS IS OUR
NAME ONLY A AND THE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT HEALTH
CARE FOUNDATION HOUSING
ADVOCACY DIVISION I'M BASED OUT
OF OS ANGELES AND I WANTED TO
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY VITAL AND THANKS SO
MUCH SO MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. Q. ONE MOMENT.
I HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FROM READING A NOTE OUT TO
CLIENTS OF OUR HERO RECALLING
THEM TO PLEASE CALL BACK IN A
REGIONALLY HANDLING OUR HEROES
ONLINE WHAT HOLD ON ONE SECOND
PLEASE HOLD ON HI. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. BOTH HOLD ON ONE SECOND
COMMISSION. CURRENTLY WE'RE
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. CAN YOU JUST A
COUPLE. A COUPLE OF. I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE CO
HOST OF MUTE THEIR PHONES
APPARENTLY WE'RE HEARING YOU.
INSTEAD OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CALLING IN SO IF WE COULD ASK
THE CO HOST TO MUTE THEIR
PHONES. WE CAN GET ALONG WITH
THOSE HO ARE WANTING TO
TESTIFY SO WITH THAT. MADAME
MODERATOR WOULD YOU QUEUE UP
THE SO I THINK THERE'S SOMEONE
ALREADY ABOUT TO SPEAK SO LET'S
LET HIM SPEAK. YES WE HAVE MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KAYLA DONLIN WITH
STRATEGIC ACTIONS FOR A JUST
ECONOMY LOS ANGELES IN ORDER
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN TO SIX. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY FOUR
NINE FOUR SEVEN FOUR. GO AHEAD
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOR THE LINE IS OPEN. WE CAN
HEAR SOME MUSIC IN THE
BACKGROUND SO IF YOUR GIVE GOT
MUSIC IN THE BACKGROUND PLEASE
SPEAK UP WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT WITNESS. I WILL GO ON
TO LINE SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE ONE SIX THREE NINE THE
LINE IS OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
YES I BELIEVE I AM CALLED.
HELLO. BETTER MODERATOR DID
THAT PHONE GET DISCONNECTED IT
APPEARED TO HAVE GOTTEN
DISCONNECTED I AM WAITING FOR
MY- PHONE QUEUE DAY RETURN ON
MY SCREEN JUST A MOMENT. I'M
HERE I HAVE TO GO BACK. WHAT
HAPPENS MONOCOQUE YOU MUST NEW
YOUR PROBLEM RIGHT I WILL POUR
WE WILL YOU'VE DONE ALL RIGHT
SO HERE'S THE DEAL FOLKS IF YOU
ARE A CO HOST IF YOU DO NOT
REBOOT YOUR PHONE. OR THE BY
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE CO
HOST OF THE PRIMARY WITNESS CO
HOST- IF YOU DON'T MUTU PHONE
WE WILL DO IT FOR YOU AND I
DON'T THINK YOU'LL BE PLEASED
WITH THAT RESULT SO. PLEASE IF
YOU ARE A PRIMARY WITNESS CO
HOST PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE
IT'S INTERFERING WITH THE
WITNESSES BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY.
ALL RIGHT MADAM MODERATOR LET'S
PROCEED. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
NOW WE'RE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES LINE NUMBER EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. LINE EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
GOOD MORNING. NINE EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BORDERLINE OF EIGHTY ONE. ONE
IS ZERO TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
IS ONE THEN IF ZERO. JUST
BEFORE. BOB THAT IS PART WE ARE
HAVING SOME ISSUES WITH PEOPLE
CALLING IN SO WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE. ABOUT A FIVE MINUTE BREAK
TO LET THE TECHNOLOGY FOLKS
FIGURE THIS OUT WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY GETS
THEIR CHANCE TO TESTIFY SO WE
WILL TAKE THAT BREAK. MY
APOLOGIES- CARE WE ARE LET'S GO
AHEAD AND- MEET BACK AT ABOUT
ELEVEN O'CLOCK BUT A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK THANK YOU.
SHERRI
COMMITTEE HEARING IS BACK IN
SESSION FOLKS WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS THE LINES ARE BEING SO
OVERWHELMED- AND CREATING ALL
SORTS OF PROBLEMS WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO NOW IS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WE ARE GOING TO
ALLOW THEIR TWO MAIN WITNESSES
TO PRESENT A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES- I'M TOLD HER FOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BUT I'M
GOING TO HOLD YOU TO THE FOUR
MINUTE MAXIMUM SO- WILL GIVE
EACH OF YOU A MINUTE. AND THEN
I'LL CUT YOU OFF OF MY
APOLOGIES IN ADVANCE THEY WERE
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES CALLING IN
WITH THEIR NAME. AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION ONLY BUT WE WILL BE
GOING BACK TO THOSE IN SUPPORT
SO WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A CHANCE
FOR SOME OF THE OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK NOW AND THEN. HOPEFULLY
WE WILL. BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
IN SUPPORT. TO TESTIFY AFTER
THAT SO WE'RE TRYING TO CLEAR
THIS UP SO THAT THE SYSTEM IS
NOT BEING OVER RUN WHICH IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW SO WITH
THAT AGAIN I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT THE- PARTICIPANT NUMBER.
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
1-116-364-3844. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. WITH THE
ACCESS CODE. SIX THREE TWO.
EIGHT SIX EIGHT SIX PENTIUM.
SIX THREE TWO EIGHT SIX EIGHT
SIX AND IN ORDER TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. YOU HIT ZERO AND ONE. NO
EXCUSE ME YOU HIT ONE THEN ZERO
MY APOLOGIES YOU HIT ONE THEN
ZERO ONLY ONCE IF YOU HIT IT
MORE THAN ONCE THAT'S CREATING
PART OF THE PROBLEM IF YOU HIT.
ZERO NO IT'S ONE FIRST. ONE ONE
ONE ZERO EIGHT ONE ZERO AND
THEN YOU WAIT. AND YOU WILL BE
IN THE QUEUE JUST HIT IT ONCE
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT GOT FOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I BELIEVE
AND ARE ANY OF THEM IN THE ROOM
HERE OR ARE THEY- ON THE PHONE.
THEY'RE ALL ON THE PHONE OR DO
WE HAVE NAMES FOR THOSE THIS IS.
WE HAVE THEM ON THE PHONE.
RIGHT IF YOU GIVE ME ONE SECOND
HERE PLEASE. WE HAVE DEBORAH
KERR CARLTON ROBERT WILSON
KARIMA DRESS DRESSY DRESSY AND
ADAM REGALING AND I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME
IT'S LIKE THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL THE TEACHER ALWAYS GETS
YOUR NAME WRONG MY APOLOGIES
AGAIN DEBRA CARLTON ROBERT
WILSON KAREEM TRYS DRESSY
DRESSY AND ADAM REGALING. ARE
ON THE LINE AND AGAIN TO THOSE
FOLKS YOU'LL EACH GET ONE
MINUTE AND LET'S START- IF WE
COULD DO WITH A TO GIVE ME ONE
SECOND TO GET MY CLOCK ROLLING
DEBRA. THE FLOOR SURE SURE OF
ONE MINUTE. YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING DOES IT EVER CROSS WITH
A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT FIFTY
THOUSAND OWNERS AND MANAGERS
AND OVER 75% OF THOSE ARE OUR
MEMBERS OWN LESS THAN TEN UNITS
THESE ARE THE OWNERS WHO WILL
LOSE THEIR PROPERTY AS A RESULT
OF COVERAGE. AND THEY ARE THESE
OWNERS WHO CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO RECEIVE
UNPAID RENT AS SET FORTH IN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX OUR GOAL IS
CERTAINLY TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T SEE AFFECTIONS AND THAT
WE WORK ON A REASONABLE
PROPOSAL. FROM A RECENT UC
BERKELEY TURNER CENTER REPORT
25% OF SMALL MOM AND POP OWNERS
HAVE ALREADY BORROWED MONEY TO
HELP PAY THE BILLS AND ALMOST
40% OF THOSE OWNERS REPORT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO COVER
COSTS FOR THE NEXT THREE
MONTHS. MANY SENIOR OWNERS
DON'T EVEN HAVE MORTGAGES AND
THAT'S REAL INCOME IS THEIR
ONLY INCOME THESE OWNERS WILL
LOSE THEIR RENTAL UNITS AND
TENANTS WILL EVENTUALLY LOSE
THEIR HOMES WE ASK THAT YOU
VOTE NO TODAY. THANK YOU. YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S ALMOST A MINUTE
OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE PROCEED.
YES THE MORNING CARE JACKSON
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX AMONG THE MANY CONCERNING
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL THE MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE
MAYBE FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX DOES
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY HELP SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS NOT RECEIVING
RENT. IT'S BEEN A REAL AND
RENTAL INCOME TO PAY
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR COSTS
TAXES AND OTHER EXPENSES
RELATED TO THE PROPERTY IN
PARTICULAR SMALL SENIOR HOUSING
PROVIDERS MANY OF WHOM DON'T
HAVE A MORTGAGE SO FORBEARANCES
USELESS RELYING THAT RENTAL
INCOME TO NOT ONLY PAY THOSE
PROPERTY EXPENSES BUT ALSO PAY
FOR THEIR FOOD AND MEDICAL
CARE. IN SHORT EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX HARM SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS WERE STRUGGLING TO
STAY AFLOAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING SAFE HOUSING FOR
THESE AND OTHER REASONS T. R.
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS AND NO
VOTE ON AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR OUT ALREADY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION. A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX AND
UNFORTUNATELY A JOB KILLER THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION
INADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS AND
UNREASONABLE TIME FRAMES SHIFT
THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT FROM CODE
NINETEEN OUR RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS BUT FAILED TO HELP THEM
CARRY THAT BURDEN. BY PROVIDING
ANY FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THE
BILL FAILS TO STRIKE A BALANCE
THE PROTECTING RENTERS. AND
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS IN THE
IMPACT OF STATE IMPOSED
ECONOMIC SHUTDOWN THE BANKING
LINK IT WILL CAUSE MORE
PROBLEMS THAN SOLUTIONS. MOST
IMPORTANT PRETTY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THE CASE LAW FROM THE
NINTH CIRCUIT TO THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT IT'S CRYSTAL
CLEAR. THANKS ARE GOVERNED BY
UNIFORM FEDERAL STANDARDS THAT
REVAMPS STATE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY. AT THE ASSEMBLY
BAGGY COMMITTEE OPINED EARLIER
THIS YEAR ON THE EXACT LANGUAGE
QUOTE DUE TO FEDERAL PREEMPTION
LAWS AND NOT ADDRESS MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO CANNOT. REPAY
THEIR LOANS WITHOUT MAJOR
CHANGES THE BILL EXACERBATE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
WITH A RISK OF INCREASED
FORECLOSURES IT ADAPTED IN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING AND
CONSTRUCTION AND FURTHER
DIALOGUE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL NEARLY MOVED
CALIFORNIA FROM ONE CRISIS. TO
THE NEXT WE ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE LAST. GOOD MORNING
CHARACTER BROWN WILSON THE CAL
CREDIT LEAGUE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STOP BY-
FORBEARANCE PIECE AND NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON SMALL PORTFOLIO
LENDERS AND COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER MORTGAGE
SERVICERS LARGE AND SMALL
STEPPING UP AND HELPING
CALIFORNIANS BY OFFERING
FORBEARANCE FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT IS HAS BEEN. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. NOTHING YOU
CREDIT. WE ALWAYS WORK IT'S
JUST THE ARM IN THE- COULD YOU
JUST VANISH CAPITA MAKING.
HOLDING THEM IN. CALL OR
SELLING AGAIN BY. NAME
GOVERNMENT SPONSORED
ENTERPRISES. SECTARIAN FREDDIE.
LOW SO THE GSES AND NO LONGER A
BUCKET CARE ACT BY ITSELF BUT
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT A MONTH
TO KEEP AND PORTFOLIO. I
UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE FOR
UNIFORMITY TO MODEL TIME ONE
AFTER THE TONE CARE ACT. WHAT
ARE OPPOSITION IS ROOTED. THE
LOAN HELD IN COURT. LIKE THOSE
OWNED BY. IS EXTREMELY PROBLEM
THE G. CARE GO BANK AND KALRA
WILL BE ABLE OUT. PREVIEWS
OTHER SMALL PLACE. TO DO NOT
HAVE THE LUXURY. VINYL US WORK
DIRECTLY WITH OUR MEMBERS ARE A
CASE BY BASIS BASIS OUR MEMBER
CREDIT. WILL CO. WHAT CAPITAL
START DECREASE WILL BE UNABLE
TO MAKE ONE OUR COMMUNITY AND
CAP LEVEL DECREASING UPGRADE
YOU'LL BE FORCED MARK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR TEN
FORTY THREE SIXTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES
EXCUSE ME BEFORE WE DO THAT ARE
THERE ANY PEOPLE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEEING NONE LETS GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. DANCING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE NOW MADAM MODERATOR
WE WILL TAKE IT TO THE PHONES
YOU CAN ASK YOU TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE HIT
ONE. AND THEN ZERO AND YOU DO
THAT ONLY ONCE. MADAME
MODERATOR FOR LET'S GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED IN WOULD YOU GIVE
US AN IDEA OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE IN THE QUEUE TO OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. FAMILIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY IN THE QUEUE. I WILL
GO FIRST TO ONE HUNDRED NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR NINE
NINE THREE FOUR YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS ROGER
BURNING I'M A PROPERTY OWNER.
AND I WOULD LIKE YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO NEXT IN LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND. TWENTY EIGHT TO
NINE ONE TWO EIGHT YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AMY
EMERSON I AM A LANDLORD AB
PLEASE VOTE NO AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN LINE ONE EIGHT
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- WHEN THE- MY NAME IS
SHE'LL BE A BRILLIANT ORAL AND
I'M A BROKER AND HOUSING
PROVIDER. A STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX LINE ONE NINE SIX. HOLLY
FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ON I CAN SHOW. AND ADDRESS
CONCERNS HAVE WITH THE MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE LANGUAGE I WOULD IT
IS ALSO A LENDER AND I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN GET AN EXCEPTION
BUT ARE OFTEN BETTER A LOT FOR
SMALL SERVER THANK YOU I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND. THIRTY
ONE NINE TWO THREE ONE. HI
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE. HEY WE
DO HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. HELLO YES.
HELLO GO AHEAD YES. WE CAN HEAR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK THANK YOU THAT IS
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS SANDRA SLIKA I
AM A SENIOR WITH ONE RENTAL
UNIT I HAVE RECEIVED ZERO
DOLLARS IN RENT SINCE APRIL
FIRST THANK YOU. POSTED ABOUT
NOW I THINK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE PLEASE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ONE THIRD HE
DOES I AM A PROPERTY RENTAL.
CAR OWNER AND I. E. STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
NINE NINE EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
RACHEL CALLAHAN PROPERTY OWNER
AND LANDLORD STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE LINE
TWO THREE NINE. BOB ABRAMS
SENIOR SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY ONE
LINE EACH ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHTY ONE WE HAVE A LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHTY ONE.
WE CAN HEAR YOU IF YOU'LL SPEAK.
R. LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ONE PLEASE. THAT IS WHY NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY EACH
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EACH FOR
EACH. OKAY. HELLO HELLO REALLY
I A PROPERTY OWNER IN A OPPOSED
MEASURE THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE NINE
FOUR TWO NINE. HIGHLINE FOR
TWENTY NINE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
HELLO HERE I CAN HEAR YOU. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CHERYL ROSSI ON THE
LANDLORDS ON SENIOR. CLOSING
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
WE GO NEXT IN LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND. FORTY NINE NINE
SEVEN FOUR NINE. SEVEN FORTY
NINE. WE HAD WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO MY NAME. MADNESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GO ON THE
NEW WITNESS THANK YOU. I NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND ONE LINE TWO
ZERO ONE. HI MY NAME'S JAMIE
FREEZE- A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU KNOW THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WELL TIMELINE OF FIFTY
EIGHT KLEIN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY IN FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
PHOTO TORY. THREE EIGHTY FOUR.
THREE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MORE TIME AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MATT A
MODERATOR. DID WE LOSE YOU TO.
WE HAVE A SO MANY PEOPLE
CALLING IN ITS PRESENT A
PROBLEM SO FAR LET'S JUST
COLLABORATOR ALL RIGHT ARE WE
HAVING A PROBLEM AT A MEMBER
MODERATOR. I AM CHECKING OUT
WE'RE GONNA TRY LINE SIXTY NINE
NINE SIX NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JEFF EACH
MELANOMA PROPERTY MANAGER
MANAGER IN LA PLEASE GO NOW.
THANK YOU OKAY OUT WE WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
LINE FIVE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS THE END OKAY
I'M BUT I RUN CARBONDALE NOT.
CLEAN THE HOLDEN. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YES ARE WE
GOING NEXT YEAR MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LINE FOR FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO. REALLY MURKY
PLEASE VOTE NO THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO LINE TWO
FOUR TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DIANA PRASAD. BY MODERN
TOKYO NOT PLEASE BOTH KNOW.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE WINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE WINO FOR
SIX ONE. YOU MAY GO AHEAD. JOHN
JAN I'M ALARMED ABOUT THE I'M
NOT A HOMEOWNER I TOOK A BIG
LOAN I NEED TO BE AROUND TO PAY
FOR THE TAXI SO MUCH OAK YOU
KNOW ALL THE COSTS THANK YOU
YOUR IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THE BILL THANK YOU YEAH I
OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATED NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. HE ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED AND.
NINETY NINE SEVEN NINE ZERO.
MAY HAVE DROPPED LET ME GO ON
TO LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE THREE SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU YES I AM CURRENTLY
UNEMPLOYED BUT HOME OWNER STORY
AGAIN THIS OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER FORTY SIX THAT
IS MY NUMBER FOUR SIX. AND YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY SIX THE
LINE IS OPEN. FORTY SIX PLEASE
CHECK YOUR MUTE CREATURE WE DO
HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU. LET'S
MOVE ON MADAME MODERATOR. THANK
YOU. I HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE. ONE NINE
EIGHT ONE ZERO NINE. PLEASE GO
HERE. HI MY NAME IS JAXON- I'M
A SENIOR AND A SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER. EAST BALL NOW THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL BE JUST
A MOMENT. I HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE LINE THIRTY NINE.
IN YOU MAY GO AHEAD LINE THIRTY
NINE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
INDEED HELLO. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA MORE LANDLORDS AND-
FULL TIME WORKERS WE NEED AND
THE PROVIDE B. AND ANY THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
IN OPPOSITION ONLY NEXT WITNESS
PLACE. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
LINE NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED AND.
NINETY NINE SEVEN NINE ZERO.
MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER NINETY
SIX LINE AT NINE SIX THE LINE
IS GOING TO BE OPEN ONE MOMENT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NINETY SIX.
MY NAME IS PATTY GOOD LAND I'M
A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER PLEASE
VOTE NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. I HAVE MY NUMBER SEVEN
NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVEN NINE SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
WE CAN HEAR THE BACKGROUND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LET'S GO ON
NEXT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I AM CLOTHING LINE. SEVEN
NINE SIX. WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
TO FIVE FORTY FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
THREE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET'S MOVE ON. WELL TO
ALIGN. SEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURKE
MADAM MODERATOR LET'S GO AHEAD
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MADAM
CHAIR IS THERE ANY CHANCE THAT
WE COULD TAKE A RECESS TO RESET
THE SYSTEM BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WHO AREN'T BEING
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY. PARDON
NO NO THAT'S FINE I THINK IT I
THINK IT'S STE IF WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK GETS A CHANCE TO- I
THINK WE WILL DROP THREE LINES
RECENTLY WE DID HEAR WHAT
SOMEONE BEFORE THEN- IF THERE
IS A PROBLEM WE WILL. KNOW THIS
FROM OUR STAFF PERSON HERE-
BUT- I THINK THE PROBLEM IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE CALLING IN AND
THEN DROPPING OFF. BUT BUT
PLEASE IF WE COULD BE
ELIMINATED BY THE EXPERT I I'M
NOT QUITE CLEAR EITHER WHAT'S
HAPPENING. ONE ZERO A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE HITTING STAR ZERO
FOUR THEY HAVE TO WAIT THERE'S
A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE
WAITING TO SPEAK THE BALLOT.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE YOU NOT
WANTING TO WAIT FOR HIS THEIR
SPECIFIC RIGHT AFTER THE ONLINE
NUMBER IT'S JUST. NOT THE CASE.
THEY KEEP HITTING STAR ZERO.
JUST OVERWHELMING THE SYSTEM.
IF WE- ARE GETTING FOR HELP
HELP HELP. SO WHAT WE SHOULD DO
IS MAKE IT CLEAR AND I DID THIS
BEFORE I DO IT AGAIN. IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL HIT ONE. THEN ZERO.
AND WAIT. THAT WILL PUT YOU IN
THE QUEUE BUT THEY ARE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE YOU HAVE GOT TO WAIT ONLY
HIT IT ONCE WHEN YOU START
HITTING IT MORE THAN ONCE THE
SYSTEM COLLAPSES SO HIT ONE.
ZERO AND WAIT. PLEASE ONLY HIT
ONCE OR WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GET YOUR TESTIMONY WOULD REALLY
TRYING HARD TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S HEARD. ONE ZERO
WAIT ALL RIGHT WITH THAT LET'S
GO BACK MADAM MODERATOR TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO HERE.
ZERO MORE
THAN ONE. WHILE WAITING WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU A REMINDER
THAT THE TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE ARE POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN ADDITION
THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IT IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS
CODE IS SIX THREE TWO. EIGHT
SIX EIGHT SIX RECORDS. WELL I'M
CHECKING WITH THEM RIGHT NOW I
CAN'T RESPOND. I'M CHECK WITH
THE MODERATOR MAKE SURE YEAH
VERY GOOD WE CHECK IN WITH THE
MODERATOR NOW FOR. WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE WE GET EVERYONE WHO
IS IN THE QUEUE WHO HAS THE
PATIENCE TO STAY IN THE QUEUE
WHETHER THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO SUPPORT
SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN BE HEARD.
THE NEXT SO I NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS JOHN
AND MOST SMALL AND THE LORD I
STRONGLY STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE PROPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT BOTTOM LINE AT SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE SIX NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I SIX NINETY
ONE CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR
YOU YES GO AHEAD PLEASE THANK
YOU I MISS MOMENT AT ERA HOW.
AND THAT LAND LINE AND I'M A
RETIRED AND I'M NUMBER OFF THAT
BAY AREA HOMEOWNER NETWORK I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO. MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXAVAR LINE OF EIGHT FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN EIGHT FIFTY
ONE. EIGHT FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT LINE IS NINE ELEVEN
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAULA
RANSOM AND MY JOB DEPENDS ON
RENTAL HOUSING PLEASE CLOSE NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT CALL COMES FROM
THE LINE OF SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS STELLA
CHAIRMAN THE RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS. I DON'T KNOW THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE AT.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY EIGHT ONE FIVE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KARMAS A DROPPED
SORRY WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE
OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS DAN A MEMBER OF THE
H. MAN ALL OF THE COMPANIES
BUYING WE ARE TRYING TO LEAVE
THE VOEPEL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AREN'T OUR
NEXT LINE WILL COME FROM LINE
OF EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KAREN
BECAUSE THEY KIND OF MOTHER
EARTH TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I
OWN ONE RENTAL PROPERTY MY CAN
FIND NOTHING TO FOLLOW I MEAN
HUGE FUNDING FOR THIS THANK YOU
SO MUCH PLEASE PEOPLE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND
ACCESSIBLE TO ALIGN. ONE MOMENT
WHILE A LINE OF THREE SEVENTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY THREE
SEVENTY A LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SORRY HI MY NAME IS
TIFFANY I AM BAY AREA HOUSING
NETWORK IN I STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. ONE FOUR THREE SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
AND THE NEXT FINAL GO TO IS
THREE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GERMAN YES I AM A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. AT NEXT FINAL GO TO IS
NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE'LL GO ON
TO THE NEXT LINE OF. THIRTY
EIGHT. I MUST HAVE DROPPED I'M
SORRY LINE IT IS SIX ZERO SIX
LINE IS OPEN. SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE OF THE OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A
ON MUTE. OKAY MONTEL LINE OF
THREE NINETY COULD WE HOLD ON
LINE IS OPEN. ARE WE GONNA
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO. YOU MUST TO DROP. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WOULD USUALLY OF
THIRTY FOUR ONE THIRTY FOUR
YEAR LINE OPEN. ALSO.
HELICOPTERED IT ALSO ONE MOMENT.
WELL I TOLD YEAH YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY FOUR. HI I AM
A PROPERTY. I MY NAME IS MADE
AND I THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WOULD PLEASE.
ONE MOMENT. NEXT TO A TO LINE
OF IT. SEVEN SEVENTY THREE ONE
I GET THAT LINE. ALAINA OPEN
LINES OF. THREE I HAD TO OPEN.
WE HEAR YOUBY. SEVENTEEN HELLO
ARE YOU THERE WE CAN HEAR YOU.
RIGHT OUTSIDE DEPEND ON RANDOM
AND PLEASE DON'T KNOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULDN'T. OUR NEXT.
HELLO PLEASE SO I GET THAT LINE
UP. THAT'S GONNA COME FROM.
FORTY YOUR LINE OF THE ONE. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
YEAH. MY NAME IS MARCH TAXPAYER%
I. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIX WITNESS. MY MOM
FOR NEXT. ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE OUR NEXT QUESTION FROM
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FOUR LINE ONE ZERO FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARIO
GARIBALDI ON MY RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER AND PROPERTY MANAGER AND
I AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. YEAH WE HAVE
ONLINE NUMBER FORTY THAT FLIGHT
NUMBER FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RITESH AND ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA HOME NOW
WERE. BECAUSE TO ENTER MAY BE
THE PROGRAM WE THANK YOU SO.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE Y. NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
NINETY LINE ONE NINETEEN GO
AHEAD. RICHARD ROSENBERG SMALL.
OWNER PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MY NUMBER FIFTY SIX
LINE FIVE SIX A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME TRANSACTION I'M A
DRAFT. I. A. B. THREE A THREE
SIX THANK YOU SO NEXT WITH
PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE NUMBERS
HUNDRED ONE LINE THREE IS ONE
PLEASE AHEAD. MY NAME MERYL
GREG IMUS SO AND SMALL PER
OWNER I. AB FORTY THIRTY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN LINE AT ONE EIGHT
ONE THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS OVER
HONG I AM I RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE
FOUR THREE SIX THANK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX LINE TWO TWO SIX YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SHERRY
SMITH I'M OUR RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY ONE NINE
TWO SEVEN ONE. MY NAME IS SUSAN
TURBINE I'M A PROPERTY OWNER
CLEAN DON'T KNOW THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE Y.
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE LINE AT
SEVEN NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
LET ME AYE OPPOSED THE SOME
SMALL PROPERTY OWNER MY NAME IS
KIM VERY SOUNDS A STRONG
INFLUENCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
LINE ONE NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREW ARABIAN WITH THE
NORTH L. A. COUNTY AND ANTELOPE
VALLEY SMALL LANDLORDS
ASSOCIATION WITH STRONG WITH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE Y. NUMBER NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN LINE
NINE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIRMAN SENATORS KEVIN
GOLDY CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE LINE ONE THREE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BUT THE LOCAL ROCK
BROWN PROPERTY OWNER STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK THANK YOU
NEXT WITH PLEASE. WE HAVE A
MEDIA. LYDIA'S LAW LYDIA GOING
YES LYDIA LARA ON ME RENT
PROPERTY OWNER AND I OPPOSE A.
B. WORKING THREE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU NICK
WITNESS. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
THREE OF MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE POINT
THREE FOUR FIVE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. AIRLINE AGAIN LINE THREE
FOUR FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JULIA YEAH ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU LOW. YES I MIGHT I OWN
ONE PROPERTY I RETIRED AND I
USED MONEY TO PAY MY MORTGAGE
THE PEOPLE NO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL BE JUST A MOMENT. NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
NINE FOUR SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR
SEVENTY FOUR. WE ARE NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE ONLINE FOR
SEVENTY FOUR I WILL MOVE TO
ANOTHER PERSON IN THE QUEUE
JUST A MOMENT. WHY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWO FOUR SEVEN.
YES MY NAME IS CARLENE I'M A
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER PLEASE
PLEASE VOEPEL THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
SEVEN TWO. JENNIFER COLEMAN A
RETIRED LANDLORDS SONOMA COUNTY
OPPOSING FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
VERY DEPARTMENT CANNOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ALEX WITNESS PLEASE.
THIS YEAR THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE LINE AT ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YES MY NAME IS MEGAN ABNER I'M
A SMALL LANDLORD AND I AM
OPPOSING AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
Y. NUMBER NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LINE NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THE LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE
WILL MOVE ON ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I NUMBER NINETY FIVE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YES WE HAVE LINE NINETY
FIVE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS KATHERINE FERRIS I'M A
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS PLEASE
VOTE NO. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR LINE
FIVE FOUR EMAIL GOING. I HAD
TRIED FOR. MY. NO THREE LINES
OF FOUR CAN YOU REPEAT WE ARE
HAVE TROUBLE YOU YEAH. HE WELL.
IF IT. OKAY WILL ONE WE HEARD
NO THANK YOU MOMENT I THINK
THEY HAVE DROPPED JUST MY THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
ZERO SIX. MY NAME IS JANET
LADEN I AM A SENIOR I OWN ONE
WORK FOR UNITED I HAVEN'T
RECEIVED RENT SINCE THANK YOU
FIRST THANK YOU PLEASED THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WE PLEASE. I
THANK YOU ONE.
THANK YOU I HAVE
TO RECENTLY HANG IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PROPERTY
MANAGER FOR MANY OF MY CLIENTS
AND THAT THEY ALL NEED THE RENT
PLEASE NOTE A DATE. AB FORTY
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. MY NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR LINE
SIX EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL. GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU. HI MY
NAME IS THE HIGHLAND B. I'M A
SENIOR I'M A STRONGLY.
IMPORTATION UP TO EIGHTY
FOURTEEN THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. A LINE NUMBER
NINE HUNDRED INTO LINE NINE
ZERO TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
WROTE SYSTEM BEHALF THE SEMI
PROPERTY AND THE PROPERTY OWNER
MYSELF FRESNO I VOTE NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. I HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE LINE TWO FOUR FIVE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MY NO.
I LOOKED UP ON THEIR AYE VOTE
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. I
HAVE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THREE TWO SEVEN. WELCOME
PLAN MY WIFE IN A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS IN OAKLAND THIS
INCOME FOR A- PLEASE VOTE NO
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. FROM THE MOMENT. BUT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD THREE FIVE. YES HI MY
NAME THE WAY YOU VIEW HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU YES
HELLO. OKAY HI MY NAME IS THE
WAY A LITTLE THE SMALL AND A
MEMBER OF THE BAY AREA NOW HOME
NO CAUSED OPPOSE TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU BECAUSE TO. WHY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
THREE FIVE. OKAY THAT LINE HAS
DISCONNECTED ONE MOMENT FOR THE
NEXT PERSON IN THE QUEUE. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO SEVEN
FOUR. ES MY NAME IS KEPT
CONSTANT AND I MADE SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER AND ALSO IS
SENIOR REQUIRING THE INCOME
PLEASE OPPOSE THANK YOU BILL I
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE FOUR TWO THREE.
YES THIS IS KAREN INTERCOSTAL
STEEL CUT FROM CREDIT UNION WE
ONLY OPPOSE THE WRITTEN
LANGUAGE FOR THE FORBEARANCE
MORTGAGES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESSES POLICE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND.
SEVENTY NINE NINE THREE SEVEN
NINE YEAH AND YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS CRAIG I
NAY STRUGGLING SENIOR CENTER
AND I OWN ONE RENTAL PROPERTY
AND I LIVE OFF THAT INCOME
THANK YOU SIR HUGH GRANT SINCE
MARK THANK YOU SO MUCH AND YOUR
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. FIND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU LINE
THREE NINE FIVE. YES HI MY NAME
IS DEEPLY KNOWS I'M A SMALL-
PROPERTY OWNERS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED A BILL THAT TENANTS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE FEW MANTECH
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINE HOW AND- EIGHT LINE NINE
FIVE EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT.
CAN WE CAN HEAR YOU TYPING LINE
NINETY EIGHT IF YOU WISH TO
RESPOND YOU KNOW WHAT BECAME
ALONG WITH HOUSING POLICY ORG
PUBLIC THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
ANOTHER THAT MCGEORGE OF THEM
THANK YOU ENGLISH NAME IN A
PLEASE. THANK YOU YOUR POST
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WOULD
PLEASE. HI MY NAME FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE LINE AT. FOUR
FIVE ONE. AND YOU MAY GO AHEAD
OF. MY NAME IS MICHAEL FRANCE
IN A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER WHO
HAS RECEIVED SOME RENT SINCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT HEARING STORIES GET
YOUR OPPOSED TO THE BILL. I
ASSUME. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. I
HAVE MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE FOUR NINE ZERO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI
MY NAME IS QUITE YOUNG. A
RENTAL CAR OWNER I OPPOSE THIS
BEER THANK SO MUCH NICK WITNESS.
THE MOMENT PLEASE. WHY NUMBER
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NINE FOUR
ONE. LINE NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. LET'S
MOVE ON. THERE IS NO RESPONSE
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. I HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO THAT IS WHY NUMBER
FIVE EIGHT TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY ELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. I
HAVE MY NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT NINE SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS QUICKLY I'M A
MEMBER OF. IN THE AREA HOUSING
ASSOCIATION I STRONGLY OPPOSE
IT THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU I
HAVE MY NUMBER EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN LINE EACH FOUR
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI THE
QUALITY TODAY FROM A SMART
OWNER DISABILITY INCOME YOU
KNOW BE ANOTHER STRUNG UP
STRONG THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. I HAVE MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO LINE A ONE A TWO TWO YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. I BELIEVE THEY
MAY HAVE DISCONNECTED- WHAT LET
ME TRY THAT AGAIN. ONE ONE TWO
TWO WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN. YES
I'M HERE HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU. GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS AIMING AND- I AM HI
UNION BANKRUPT THE- I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER SOUTH TWO AND THREE THAT
IS LINE NUMBER ONE TWO THREE
YOU MAY GO A- HI THIS IS STEVE
AND I'M SENIOR. OKAY OWNER I
OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PER. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER ONE TWO
FIVE. MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
JENNA AND I AM A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER I VOTE NO. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THAT IS
LINE ONE TWO ONE THREE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD WILL. BY WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS JAMIE ONE
THE RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS I
DON'T KNOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME'S
DAPHNE IN I'M A C. CITIZEN I
SMOG PROPERTY. I DO BOTH LOCAL.
H. THANK YOU SO MUCH NECK
WITNESS. IT'LL BE TO A MOMENT.
BY NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FIVE FOUR ONE. MY NAME IS KIM
LIMON I'M A RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS PLEASE VOTE NOW. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE Y. NUMBER NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE NINE FOR EACH. AND I'M
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PAT RUNS ALONG CALLING
BEHALF OF THE CAL MORTGAGE
BANKERS ASSOCIATION TO OPPOSE
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH AND BEFORE
WE GO ON I'M GOING TO REMIND
PEOPLE. OF THE CALL IN NUMBER
AND IF THEY ARE WANTING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THAT THEY SHOULD CALL IN BY
DIALING ONE THEN ZERO. AND THEN
WAIT. THE CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SIX THREE TWO. EIGHT SIX EIGHT
SIX ACCESS CODE AGAIN IS. SIX
THREE TWO EIGHT SIX EIGHT SIX
AND WE'RE TAKING OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
STATE YOUR OPPOSITION HE WILL
BE NAMED. AFFILIATION AND THE
TO OPPOSE THE BILL. AND WE WILL
BE TAKING THOSE CALLS NOW SO
PLEASE IF YOU AREN'T IN THE
QUEUE YOU DIAL. ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WAIT. DON'T KEEP DARLING IT
WILL PUT YOU IN QUEUE WHEN YOU
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WITH THAT- META MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT CALL. IS MY
NUMBER EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT FOUR
ZERO. NINE EIGHT FOUR ZERO THE
LINE IS OPEN YES I'M SORRY MY
NAME IS THE IN AREAS ON THE
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN LINE SIX FOUR SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN FOR YOU.
NOR SPONSORING A MOVEON. THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER EIGHT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE LINE EIGHTY
THREE THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
WE WILL GET MY NAME IS MARK
FROM A SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
BECAUSE THIS BILL. WE STILL
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE RIGHT
DECISION TO THE SPORT CAN PLAY
ONLINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY TO LINE FOUR NINE TWO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE FOR NINETY TWO WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU. AND
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER O'NEILL
I'M LEAVES BAY AREA HOME
OWNERSHIP NETWORK I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX COMMUNIST THAT BE ALL HE
WILL KILL YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TEST NAY WITNESS
PLEASE NAME OF PHILLY AND
OPPOSITION. PLEASE WE HAVE LINE
SO HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE AHEAD SET NINE FOR. YES
MORNING I OPPOSE. THIS IS TO
GENTLEMAN I AM BACK HOME AND A
MEMBER OF THE NOT NOT AS-
OPPOSE B. FOR SIX PLEASE HOLD
WHILE. THANK YOU SO NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST A MOM. I
NUMBER NINE NINE ZERO- PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NINE NINE ZERO WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN. HI THIS IS
ARUN KINGSTON ARE REPRESENTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION- BOTH OF THEM
WHICH- ARE FOR LOW INCOME
TENANTS- THAT THEY OPPOSE.
ENTRY APART ASSOC. ONE IN THE
BEAR. IF COUNTY AND SOME
MONSTER. ALL ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL YOU THANK YOU SIR WOULD
PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST. I HAVE
LINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. SEVEN
FOUR ZERO. I DID MORNING MY
NAME IS REBECCA TRAINING AND
GET THE- LANDLORD AND WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO PAY OUR- THE
APPRAISAL NO LONGER THANK YOU
THANKS FOR YOUR- CALL NEXT
NUMBER PLEASE NEXT. THANK WILL
BE JUST A MOMENT. FOR JUST A
MOMENT I NEED TO CLOSE THAT
LINE THANK YOU. OKAY I HAVE
NEEDED THAT LINE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LET ME GET TO THE
NEXT PERSON IN THE QUEUE COULD
YOU MADAM MODERATOR INDICATE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE LEFT IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE OF
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'LL BE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED.
RIGHT CHESTER FOR EVERYONE TO
NOTE THAT AS I STATED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING WE
WILL BE TAKING A BREAK FROM
TWELVE THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY.
WHEN WE WILL BE RESUMING SO
WE'LL TRY TO GET TO AS MUCH OF
THE OPPOSITION AS WE CAN NOW
AND- IF YOU GO AHEAD MATTER
MODERATOR. DO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE LINE EIGHT THREE ONE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
BEING GRANDSON AND- I'M
RESIDENTS. OF CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
PLEASE I HAVE LINE NUMBER NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO LINE.
NINE FIVE TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEITH
BECKER I AM PROPER OWNER
PROPERTY MANAGER AM A TO WHO
HAS. PAID RENT SO I'M- I'M NOT
TAKING ANYTHING THAN YOUR NAME
YOU'VE GIVEN US YOUR
AFFILIATION I ASSUME YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR I ABOUT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHT ZERO. HELLO MY NAME
IS DON'T TURN A RETIRED
PROPERTY OWNER BY STORM OPPOSE
AB THIRTY SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLAY. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. NUMBER NINE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NINE ZERO ZERO. THAT LINE HAS
DISCONNECTED ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I HAVE MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FOR FIVE SEVEN. IT'S GOING
HAD FOR FIVE SAID THE LINE OPEN.
OKAY THERE IS NO RESPONSE FROM
LINE FOR FIVE SEVEN. I WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PERSON IN
THE QUEUE. SIX WITNESS. NEXT WE
HAVE TO LIVE NINE SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IS A LINE
OPENED OR HAS THE PERSON OFF
THE CALL. THE LINE IS NOW
DISCONNECTED THANK YOU LET'S GO
ON THEN. ONE THREE FIVE THREE
NINE THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THREE FIVE THREE YOU MAY
BE ON YOU. PLEASE ON MUTE OR WE
CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALL.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON MR
MODERATOR
LINE OF FIVE ONE TWO. AGAIN.
FIVE TWELVE FIVE ONE TWO. MY
NAME'S KRISTINA A SMALL MAMMAL
OF THE BEAST MODE NO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE TWO FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MAGIC PRESS COULD MY
WIFE AND I ARE RETIRED PROPERTY
OWNER RELYING ON FRANKLIN.
PLEASE FOLLOW NO ON THE BECAUSE
AND GO TO. THANK YOU SIR AND I
WITNESS. NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWO
ZERO SIX. BY TWO ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS BEN
SWEET SMALL PROPERTY OWNER FROM
MODESTO EMPHATICALLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR OP ROLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE FOUR ONE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
CORNWELL SOME ARE NOT RENTAL
PROPERTY MANAGER PLEASE VOTE
NOW THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
WINE ONE THOUSAND TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE GIBSON AND MY JOB
DEPENDS ON RENTAL HOUSING
PLEASE VOTE NO. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WHITE ONE
THOUSAND SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME'S GEORGIA TELL
I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND
ALSO A SMALL OUR DENTAL OWNER
OPPOSED EIGHTY FORTY YOU SEE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE TO
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
NEWSSTAND MOMENT ME OUR SENIOR
AND MY PARENTS ALSO RETIRE
SENIOR THE POP. IN THIS IN A IS
AND THE. THEY RELY ON THE
INCOME THE GRAND THANK YOU AND
YOUR A STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PUBLISHED JIM THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. LINE ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND
ZERO EIGHT YOU BE ON MUTE. IT'S
GOING TO THE NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
ONE ONE ZERO TWO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MAYBE
YOU KNOW AND I THINK ON TUESDAY
HOME ON MONDAY AT ONE THAT
WOULD POTENTIAL OF THREE DOGS
MEMBERS. I NEED STRONG. TO
EIGHT ONE BAKRI SAID THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE THREE ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MANY MY NAME'S ADRIAN
JOHN I'M IN IN YEARS IT IS AYE
VOTE NO TO A B. ONE FOUR THREE
THREE THANK YOU SOME NEXT
WITNESS PLAY. BLIND FIVE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YEAH MY NAME
IS COLONNA I A SENIOR CITIZEN
AND RENTAL OWNERS PLEASE NOTE
NOW. THANK YOU SIR WITNESS PUT.
NINE ONE ZERO THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES PAN GUYS
ASSUMING YOU'RE PENCIL WORLD ON.
SPECT PLEASE NEXT PARKING
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS. ONE ONE ZERO THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURIE LOGAN AND MY
HUSBAND AND I ARE SMALL
APARTMENT OWNERS THIS IS OUR
RETIREMENT INCOME PLEASE OPPOSE
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE ONE ZERO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL WE'LL SEND
MOM AND POP LAST UNIT STRONGLY
OF. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLAY.
BLIND ONE ZERO ZERO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET'S
MOVE ON MODERATOR. HELLO HELLO
HELLO. BLIND ONE ZERO FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ONE SO
LET'S SEE I AM AFFECTS THAT
TAXPAYER IF FATHER OF TO THE
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER AND I'M
HERE BY MYSELF I'M NOT WITH ANY.
INSURANCE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL TRUMP THANK YOU YES NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. PINE TWO FIVE
NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
I'M TRêN READ TEACHER SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER I JUST OF.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR PEOPLE FOR
THE SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WINDS SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS JOSE BOORDA I AM A RETIRED
SENIOR. IN A SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER I STRONG. CLOSE THIS BILL
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH READ
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE ONE
ZERO FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS HELEN
CLARK I AM A SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS. WHAT THE PART IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
ABOUT NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FINE ONE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS SUZANNE
ALMOST MORE PROPERTY OWNER AND
RENTERS PROPERTY. I LIKE TO
KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WOULD PLEASE. FIND ONE ZERO TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE OPEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. I ALWAYS GO AHEAD
MY INTEGRATIVE OUT AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE I'M A SENIOR
AND A SMALL PROPERTY OWNER
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS HEATHER HILL I HAVE A SMALL
HUNTING SERVICE WITH MORE THAN
TEN. ARE STRONG OPPOSED A. B.
ACCORDING TO THE TECH THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WOULD PLEASE. ONE NINE
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIE AS I
MISSED. POP OWNER AND I. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. LINE
ONE ZERO EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FREE LOOK AT STUFF. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU HELLO. MY NAME IS LISA COOK
JONI I'M PROPERTY AND ALSO
PROPERTY. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE. ON BEHALF OF MYSELF MY
OWN THANK YOUNG OPPOSE IT
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE NINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. THE GUYS AT THE
BAR. YEAH I'M HERE HELLO GOT.
MY NAME IS CARLA MIND YOU I
MARIE PROPERTY AND I WRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WINDS NINE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD. WE CAN.
BHUVAN AND TO THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE FOUR FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHRIS FOR
TALKING FROM THE WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE THREE
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS TERRA DURBAN I AM A
LANDLORD PLEASE VOTE NO THANK
YOU THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN TWO YOUR MIND
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME BUILT MORE
MALL RENTAL PROPERTY OWNER AYE
OPPOSED FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE ONE ZERO SEVEN ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MARK ABERNATHY. I'M A RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER AND I THE STATE
THANK YOU SIR NEXT. NINE ONE
ZERO ZERO ZERO PLAN ONE
THOUSAND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
ONE ZERO ONE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT- YES ALEX HI
EVERYBODY I KNOW I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE ON A LOT A
LEGENDARY HAS GOT WHAT. MATTERS.
WHILE FOLKS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE CONVERSE IS BUT IF YOU'RE
ONE OF THE HOSTS. ARE YOUR
TRYING TO ORGANIZE YOU FOR
PLEASE GO ON WE ARE NOW TAKE
TEST OF PEOPLE BY NAME AND
AFFILIATION. IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. WE PROP STILL GET
ABOUT A FIFTY PEOPLE TO SO
PLEASE. THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
THE CALL HOST OF THIS MUTUAL
PHONE. LET'S GO BACK TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN THE WHERE TO
INDICATOR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. MON A MODERATOR. NINE ONE
ZERO NINE FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN ORDER TO MAKE MONEY
LAST. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NAY WITNESS. WITH NINE SEVEN
TWO YOUR IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BECKY. NEWS I MUST MORE LANDO.
HOLD AB THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WOULD PLEASE. WE
HAVE A NOT EIGHT ZERO YOUR IS
OPEN. HELLO MICHAEL AND BILL
EVEN WELL SPENT BEING SENT
PHARMA HOUSING STRENGTH YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THESE FOLKS
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP IT. ON THE
AND UP IN RISK OR WE'RE GONNA
IT DOWN. NAME OF PHILLY AND
PLEASE NEXT WITNESS. BLIND NINE
ZERO YOUR LINE OPEN. J. YOU
HEAR ME WE HEAR YOU HELLO. OKAY
MY IS LINK THAT AND ORDER AND
IN THE THEY ARE THE NEW YORK
ALISTER GO TO PULL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE
FOUR YOUR IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MAYOR LOU QUALITY I AM A
RENTAL OWNER AND STRONGLY OF.
THANK YOU NEXT WOULD PLEASE.
NINE ELEVEN THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE SO
CALLED ABOUT A LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
DUE TO THE MORTGAGE PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ONE ONE ONE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EIGHT THREE THREE.
HELLO THE RITA. YES WE CAN YOU
HELLO. RIGHT LEAVE A REPLY THE
I'M THE PROPERTY I'M THE OWNER.
I NO I'D LOVE KNOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH WITNESS PLEASE. HE EIGHT
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS A.
MICHELLE. THANK COOKING FOR THE
FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. PINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS A- HIDE IS CAMERA TOTAL
AMERI PROPER OWNER IN A MAN
PLEASE THAT NOW AND FOR THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU MAY NEXT WITH
PLEASE. BLIND WHY ZERO NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
JUNE ON THE CROSS OWNER I WILL
KNOW THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. LINE ONE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MELISSA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALL COUNCIL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ONE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS BAILEY
YANG I'M FROM BAY AREA ALMOST
NETWORKS NEARBY ON LAND
PRESUPPOSED THIS WE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WEEK PLAY. NINE
ONE ONE THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET'S MOVE ON THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LET'S MOVE
ON A MODERATOR FOR. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD. WE HAVE ONE ONE ONE
TWO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
US. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA. AND
I AM A BRING PROPERTY OWNER AND
I OPPOSE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE ZERO
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE PROCEED
HELLO WELL HI MY NAME. I'VE
NEVER ALL DEBATE HOME YEAH TAX
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE EIGHT
ONE. ONE FOUR THREE SIX THANK
YOU YOUR LIKE YOU THANK SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLAY. KLAIN ONE
ONE ONE YOUR LINE OPEN.
SIX
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE ONE
EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIX WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE
ONE EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON FOR ANOTHER FIVE
MINUTES TAKING OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY WE WILL OF TAKEN
ABOUT AN HOUR AND FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
AND WHEN WE BREAK WE'RE GONNA
TAKE NO MORE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. BUT
WE'LL ASK PEOPLE TO PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY THROUGH
EMAIL OVER THE PORTAL OR
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE SO FOR
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO EQUALIZE THE TIME TO THOSE%
IN SUPPORT WHEN WE GET BACK AT
ONE THIRTY SO IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE STAY
ON THE LINE WE DON'T WANT TO
DROP THE CALLS BUT WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE FIVE MORE MINUTES OF
OPPOSITION TO. WILL BE IT BY
PHONE. WILL BE IN. PLEASE
PROCEED MODERATE. LINE ONE ONE
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MANAGER PAT MORAN ERIN OF
SO WERE A SUDDEN CAL RENTAL
EXPO. IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WOULD PLEASE.
BLIND ONE TWO ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS A. MY NAME IS A CARING
A SMALL RENTAL PROPERTY I WILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET'S MOVE ALONG. LINE.
ONE ONE SIX SEVEN APPRECIATE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. WE DIDN'T
HEAR YOU- MY NAME IS MELISSA
LANE I AM MANAGER I DON'T KNOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE ONE FOUR TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TRINA
GROWTH I'M A RENTAL PROPERTY
MANAGER PLEASE VOTE NOW THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ONE ONE FOUR FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
MY NAME IS A POPULAR AND I AM
THE OFFICE PROP WITH PEOPLE. I
PROPOSAL MAYBE WANT THREE THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS. LINE
THREE EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX WITNESS PLEASE. BLIND
ONE TWO SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MERYL RECUPERO MY HOW AND
I ARE SENIOR WE ARE SMALL RED
PROPERTY OWNERS PLEASE PLEASE
NO ON THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MAY NEXT WITNESS. FIND ONE
TO FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LET'S MOVE ON WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE TWO MORE CALLS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS UNTIL ONE
THIRTY WHEN WE WILL START
HEARING FROM THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE WE'RE GONNA GIVE
THEM EQUAL TIME IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION AND I'VE NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO BE HEARD YOU CAN GO
THROUGH OUR PORTAL- TO GIVE
YOUR TESTIMONY OR THROUGH EMAIL
OR THROUGH THE COMMITTEE. TWO
MORE MINUTES TWO MORE TWO MORE
WITNESSES PLEASE LET'S SEE IF
WE CAN KEEP YOU ON THE LINE IF
YOU'RE IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE A
MODERATOR GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO. IS THERE SOMEONE
SPEAKING A MODERATOR TO WE'RE
JUST HAVING TROUBLE HEARING.
NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HERE FOR US. FIND
ONE TWO FOUR FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI HI MY NAME IS A BILL
TRUMP KERR. A PROPERTY OWNER
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH ONE MORE CALL
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
GET ONE MORE CALL ON THE LINE.
WE HAVE LINE ONE ONE THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS THE LATELY YUP I'M NOT
A REAL. BILL PROPERTY OWNERS
WILL KNOW THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO NOW BREAK A AND HAD A RECESS
UNTIL ONE THIRTY WE TOOK AN
HOUR AND FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY WHEN WE
COME BACK WE WILL TAKE NO MORE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY BY PHONE.
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO BE HEARD OR WANT TO SUBMIT
YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO DO THAT TO OUR EMAIL
OVER THE PORTAL OR THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE WHEN WE GET BACK AT
ONE THIRTY WE WILL GO BACK TO
THE SUPPORT. GROUP AND GIVE
THEM EQUAL TIME. TO SPEAK AT
ONE THIRTY THIS AFTERNOON
SUPPORT TO BE HEARD AT ONE
THIRTY THIS AFTERNOON TO
EQUALIZE THE AMOUNT OF TIME WE
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION AND
WITH THAT WE STAD IN RECESS.
TO ONE THIRTY THANK YOU.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY WILL COME TO ORDER
AGAIN. AND TO AT THIS POINT IN
TIME IS INDICATED ONE WEEK.
BEFORE WE TOOK A RECESS. A
LITTLE EARLIER. WE HAVE TAKEN
AN HOUR AND FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. TO AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. AND WE
INDICATED THAT WE WOULD BE
TAKING NO MORE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY SO IF IN FACT YOU
WISH TO. TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY THROUGH EMAIL. OVER
THE PORTAL OR THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE. AND AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THOSE IN SUPPORT. AND WE ARE
GOING TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
EQUAL TIME- WE GAVE THEM AN
HOURAND ONE MINUTE- AND THE
OPPOSITION'S HEAD AN HOUR AND
FIFTEEN MINUTES. SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND ALLOW THE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. TO
EXPRESS ITS OPPOSITION. FOR THE
NEXT FOURTEEN MINUTES AND AGAIN
WE JUST SIMPLY ASK FOR THE
NAME. OF PHILLIP PATIENT AND
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT FOUR
EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX. AND
THAT. OF WHAT'S GOING OF IS
MODERATOR CALL ON ON CALL WITH
US AND IF SO WE YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND TALK AND BRING IN
OUR FOR. OF PERSON THE QUEUE
TO. IN SUPPORT TO GIVE NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT OF THIS
MISSION THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY
AND WE ALREADY HAVE SEVERAL IN
Q. WILL FIRST MOVED TO NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON COUNCIL MY NAME
IS GERALDINE I AM A RESIDENT OF
INTER COUNTY WHICH TO EMERGENCY
ROOM HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND MY
FAMILY DURING THE ONGOING
DEVASTATING PANDEMIC. AND A
PUBLIC SAFETY MEASURE I AM
STRONGLY IN FAVOR AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU BRENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PROJECT LEVELS OF ALL THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT WITNESS NAME
AFFILIATION AND INDICATE YOUR
SUPPORT ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER SO. SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M TRYING AFTERNOON
COUNCIL I NEED IS CAITLYN
BETTER AS KNOW WE ARE FACING A
HOUSING AND ALMOST CRISES AND
WE DO NOT DO SOMETHING NINETEEN
WHAT EXACTLY IS YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION THERE'S NO
MORE TESTIMONY PERCENT INTEREST
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND THERE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL DO YOU HAVE
AN OF AFFILIATION ARE YOU
AFFILIATED WITH ANY GROUP. ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLOQUEADO MY
NAME IS RUBEN ESPINOZA AND I AM
CALLING IN. EXTENSIBLE AB SIX
HOUSING UP NORTH THANK YOU SO
MUCH WITNESS NAY OF. AND
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT. NEXA THE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACOB I'M FROM THE LOS ANGELES
TENANTS UNION. ONLY SUPPORT YOU
NEED TO CANCEL RENDON THE BARE
MINIMUM THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
WE NUMBER SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS REVEREND TIM **** MARC AND I
SERVICE MINISTER UNITARIAN
UNIVERSALIST CHURCH OF FRESNO
CALIFORNIA ALSO A MEMBER OF ST
FRESNO STATE IN THE VALLEY AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT WE KNOW SAID
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROLAND I WOULD MEAN TO
FRANCISCO I'M OF SANTA
COMMUNITY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLAY.
NEXT NUMBER EIGHTEEN OH THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE GET THE
TERM. YOUR YOUR ON THE LAW IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS A I WORK I THE
PHILLY HE NEEDED. OCT ANGELES
WHERE HOUSE LEVEL ALL BORE
MEMBER OR CALIFORNIA REMEK
CLOSE ON I THINK I YES THE
COURT THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WEEK PLEASE. NEXT WE NUMBER
EIGHTY SO. PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY.
HELLO ICHINOSE YOUR LINE IS.
LOS GOING THEN THE NEW WITNESS.
NEXT GO TO EIGHTEEN. PLEASE
AHEAD. NOT IN THE LATTER FAITH
IN THE VALOUR AND YOUR SUPPORT
BI FOR THIRTY BILLION. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NICK WE NUMBER EIGHT TEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRYING
SOMETHING UNDER OF TO GATHER IN
IT'S FORTY MEMBER ACROSS THE
STRONG SUPPORTER AB COURT
THIRTY THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE EIGHTY
NINETEEN PLEASE AHEAD. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
REMEMBER THE DALTON JONES AND
I'M IN ORGANIZED THE CURRENT
MOMENT STRONG SUPPORTER AB
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT OVER THE
LINE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD JUST. HI MY
NAME IS MONICA MEASURE I'M
CALLING WITH THE ONLINE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT. EIGHT AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTUNE PROJECTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. OUR
NEXT WE NUMBER EIGHTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE
FISHER RAYLAN IN OAKLAND AND
BECAUSE NOW. WITH FAITH IN THE
VALLEY STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY
ORIGIN THIRTY WE VOTE YES THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS. THE
NEXT WITH A LOT EIGHT FOR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY THAT
CULTURALLY FROM NEIGHBORLY
SANTA CRUZ CALLING IN TERMS.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WE NUMBERS SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ST MORITZ
NURSE PRACTITIONER BOARD MEMBER
FOR CEMETERY COUNTY HEALTH CARE
BUT HOMELESS AND FARMWORKERS UP
IN IN OF TO SIX. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
WE KNOW SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KEVIN LYMAN REPRESENTING HOW
TAKEN HIGH HOUSING ACTION
COMMITTEE WOULD STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY POINT THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. SIX OF THE EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS AFTER WHICH IS
IMMEDIATELY DAY I AM WITH BAKER
VITALI SENATE BLOCKS AND I'VE
LONG WE BOARD AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY PLEASE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT TO PLEA.
NEXT WE EIGHTEEN A ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO COUNCIL MY NAME
IS YVONNE GARY I'M A RESIDENT
OF SEVEN AND I SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY BEANS AND
HALACHA WITH CONFLICT OR
EVERYONE PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ERIC KANE AND I'M YEARS OLD AND
ON AT BE HOME ON THE NUMBER OF
IT. BROWN'S AGE CREED YESTERDAY
FOURTEEN SIX. WELL THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US NECK WITNESS
PLEASE. NEXT TO A NUMBER
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARCUS
HOME AND IN STRONG WHICH. OKAY
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. A TO
BE NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MANY IS LALIT BERMAN
I'M WITH A I STRONGLY FOR A
FORTY THIRTY COULD VOTE YES
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. OUR NEXT TO THE NUMBER
NINETEEN OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINETEEN OH ONE PLEASE GO.
WE CAN HEAR YOU YES WE CAN LET
ME. HI MY NAME IS KELLY AND I'M
A RENTER WHO PAYS THE VICUNA
JANUARY BUT THE BLATANT
AGREEMENT I NEED YOUR HELP TO
PLEASE SUPPORT AB QUITE THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE NUMBER
NINETEEN OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JORDAN CRIMES ON BEHALF OF AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY GROUPS CONTROL
FOR EVERYONE AND ONE SAN MATTEO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
WE NUMBER NINETEEN TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
MATT TO BEING A MEMBER OF THE
EIGHTH AND A RESIDENT OF NINE
ZERO ZERO TWO MAY I AM VOTING
FOR AB ONE FOUR THREE SIX.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ACTUALLY THE NUMBER NINETEEN
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
WE CAN HEAR YOU YES WE CAN. HI
ABOUT DOING WITH IN LENEXA
PARTNERS AND PUT AMERICAN BIG
AND PROPERTY AND WE HAVE. OVER
THIRTY OREGON THAT WANT TO OF
EIGHT FORTY SIX THANK YOU FOR
MUCH THANK NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE NEXT WITH A NUMBER NINETY
TO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY OUR
COMMUNITY WE CAN HEAR YOU YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY HI MY
NAME IS THE DANGER VOIGTS I'M A
MEMBER ASSEMBLY K. N. B. AND
ONE INCH CHUNKS OF THE BARE
MINIMUM THAT YOU CAN DO IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SERRA OGLESBY I'M A
MEMBER OF THE S. AND P. AND THE
INTERVENTION SAN FRANCISCO AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANKS THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS. SOME
TAX EQUITY IN CHUNKS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
CORBIN HI THERE ON BEHALF O
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HEARING WE CAN HEAR YOU
YES WE CAN YOU. HI MY NAME IS
ALFRED TO A CITY CENTER MEMBER
BECOME DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
PARTY HAD SUPPORTED MISSPELLED
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WE NUMBER EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN GOOD GOOD. HI. EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT. T. MOBILE MOVED TO NUMBER
NINETEEN OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OUT OF THE
SAND WITH LET HEALTH ACCESS AND
THE WOMEN POLICY. IN BOTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE THANK
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MIX THE NUMBER SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JOHNSON JOHNSON I'M A RENTER
LOS ANGELES AND I'M ALSO I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES STRONG BEFORE THE BELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. OUR NEXT WINTER
NINETEEN THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
MORALIS I AM WITH ACE AND I
SUPPOSE EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIX
PLEASE VOTE YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PER. NEXT IS
NOT NINETY THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MEYER I AM A MEMBER SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AT SACRED
HEART IN SAN JOSE AND WE
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO NUMBER SEVENTEEN NINETY
ONE POINT OPEN. YES WE CAN. WE
CAN HEAR YOU ALK TO. HELLO
NAME ONLY AND I'M OUT LANDLORDS
REAL. BOB WORKING. THANK YOU
ARE TAKING ONLY AT THE POINT IN
TIME PLEASE NEXT WE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT THING
NUMBER NINETEEN THREE YOU MAY
AHEAD. I'M CALLING. I BELIEVE
THEY MAY HAVE DROPPED WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE NINE FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALEX. WITH
CREEK VALLEY AND A RECORD
BREAKERS OKAY. I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB WORKING
THIRTY SIX PLEASE VOTE YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
WE'VE GOT TWO MINUTES LEFT.
THANK YOU LINE ONE TWO NINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD WE
HEAR YOU. R. LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PERSON PLEASE. THAT IS
MY NUMBER ONE EACH ONE EACH
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THIS IS WILLIAM CEDAR
GOOD AFTERNOON COUNTY. I'M WITH
SAINT CAP NEWMINSTER AND BASED
ON THE BACK. STRONGLY SO EIGHT.
ONE FOUR TWO SIX THANK YOU SO
MUCH POSITIVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE AT
ONE ONE FIVE TWO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ELIZABETH
COMMON THE ARM RENTER IN SANTA
CRUZ ADEQUATE ACTION IDEA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND OUR LAST.
OUR LAST WEEK SINCE. GO AHEAD
WHO THE LUCKY PERSON IN. IT IS
NINE ONE NINE TWO FOUR YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU. ALL MY NAME IS
WILLIAM. I AM A RESIDENT OF
POLTAVA PRISON DISCOUNT HIGH
SCHOOL DEMOCRATS AND POTENTIAL
FOR EVERYONE. CALLING FOR
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO HAS CALLED THE IN
OR HAS BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING
IN LINE IF YOU WERE NOT GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY THROUGH
EMAIL OVER THE PORTAL OR
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE
GIVEN EQUAL TIMES A TO BOTH
THOSE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
BUT IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
IN THE QUEUE OR BE HEARD.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO GET YOUR
POSITION TO US THROUGH EMAIL
OVER THE PORTAL OR THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO
BRING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSION. AND AS THE
CHAIR I'M GOING TO TAKE THE
PRIVILEGE TO SAY A FEW WORDS ON
THIS BILL- THAT- I KNOW HAS
BEEN A- SOURCE OF. GREAT
CHALLENGE TO ITS AUTHORS AND
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S. NATIONAL
POSITIONS- EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. FIRST OF ALL WE ARE
IN A CRISIS THAT I DON'T RECALL
HAVING DURING MY LIFETIME AND
I'M A LITTLE OLDER PERHAPS BY
TWICE AS MANY OF YOU IN THIS
ROOM WE ARE EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC AND A HEALTH CRISIS-
THE A PANDEMIC THAT WE HAVEN'T
HAD A HUNDRED YEARS WHICH IS
OLDER THAN I. AND THESE CALLS
FOR HELP OUR REAL THEIR
IMMEDIATE THEY ARE JUSTIFIABLE
WE CAN'T IGNORE THEM. THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THOSE
COMING UP SHORT IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO PAY RENT RIGHT NOW
ARE COMING UP SHORT THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN. AND WE HAVE
A DUTY TO HELP. WITH EACH
PROPOSAL FOR TENET RELIEF WE'VE
HEARD HOWEVER WE'VE ALSO HEARD
AN UNDERSTANDABLE RETORT FROM
LANDLORDS WHAT ABOUT US WHAT
ABOUT ME. WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED
TO DO WE DON'T WANT TO KICK
TENANTS OUT BUT WITHOUT RENT
PAYMENTS WE CANNOT PAY
MORTGAGES OR TAXES OR
MAINTENANCE AND- OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS UPON WHICH WE DEPEND. ON
THAT RENTAL INCOME FOR AS WELL.
WE HEARD IT AGAIN TODAY AND
WE'VE BEEN HEARING IT
THROUGHOUT. IT IS CLEARLY A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN SO I GREATLY
WELCOME AND SUPPORT THE
OPPORTUNITY. TWO APPROACHES
BILL WHICH I BELIEVE IS MORE
BALANCED IT GIVES TENANTS TO
BREAK IF THEY NEEDED IN A GIVE
SMALL LANDLORDS AND HOMEOWNERS
A BREAK IF THEY NEED IT AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR
BECAUSE I THINK THE MANY OF
THOSE WHO WERE A TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION DID NOT REALIZE THAT
THIS BILL INCLUDES BOTH THE
TENANT. AND THE LANDLORD THE
SMALLER LANDLORDS WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THEM TESTIFIED TODAY SO
I WOULD ASK THAT THOSE WHO ARE
STILL LISTENING WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS ANY
HELP FOR THE LOOK FOR LANDLORDS
SUPPORT FOR HOMEOWNERS PLEASE
LISTEN CAREFULLY IT IS INDEED
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. AND OF
COURSE NOT SURPRISINGLY THE
NEXT LINK UP IN THE FINANCIAL
CHAIN WHICH IS BANKS AND
LENDERS NOW RAISE THEIR VOICE
TO SAY DON'T MAKE US BEAR THE
BURDEN OF HAVING TO WAIT TO GET
PAID BUT HERE'S THE TRUTH THAT
WE ALL I THINK HAVE TO CONFRONT
NONE OF THIS WANTED THE
SITUATION. NONE OF US ARE HAPPY
WITH THE SITUATION BUT ALL OF
US ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BEAR
SOME PART OF THE BURDEN
OTHERWISE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OUT IN THE STREET. WE
ARE GOING TO SEE. HOMEOWNER AND
SMALL LANDLORDS. FORECLOSED
UPON. AND WHAT WOULD LIKELY
HAPPEN THEN IT IS THOSE WHO
HAVE HAD THE FINANCIAL MEANS TO
WEATHER THE STORM. COULD VERY
WELL BY UP ALL THOSE
PROPERTIES. ENHANCE THEIR OWN
FINANCIAL WEALTH. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE AVERAGE
PERSON. THE AVERAGE SMALL
LANDLORD WHO FINDS THEMSELVES.
TO THE PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING.
THOSE ARE NOT OUR VALUES. AND
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY.
EVERYONE INVOLVED FROM BANKS
AND LENDERS. ARE AND THOSE WHO
ARE WILLING AND ABLE TO STEP
UP. AND ARE IN THE BEST
POSITION TO DO SO I BELIEVE
MUCH TO HELP AS WELL. AND IF
NOTHING ELSE UNLIKE LANDLORDS
TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS THE
BANKS AND LENDERS. ARE SECURED
CREDITORS. AT THE END OF THE
DAY THEY'VE GOT THE GREATEST
ASSURANCE OF GETTING THE FULL
BENEFIT OF THEIR BARGAIN.
THEY'VE GOT THE PROPERTY. AS
THEIR ASSURANCE. I RECOGNIZE
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LIMITS OF STATE
AUTHORITY TO MANDATE
FORBEARANCE AND IT WAS
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH IN THIS
BILL WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE INDEED SOME OF PREEMPTION
ISSUES THAT ARE INVOLVED- THERE
ARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS- AND
WITH RESPECT TO FEDERALLY
CHARTERED BANKS SO WE HAVE
ENGAGED MYSELF AND MY STAFF IN
VERY FRANK CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS AND- BY MERGING THE
AUTHOR. OF THE AUTHORS TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THIS BILL IS ON THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE LEGAL
FOOTING. IT WOULD BE MY HOPE
THAT THE BANKS AND THE LENDERS
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO SOME FOR
PARENTS BE WILLING TO BE PART
OF THIS DISCUSSION RATHER THAN
POTENTIALLY RUN INTO THE COURTS
ARE- ASSERTING FEDERAL
PREEMPTION ISSUES AND FRANKLY
PART OF THIS DISCUSSION IS
WE'VE TRIED TO CREATE SOME
PARALLELS. SO THAT WHAT WAS
DONE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL WITH
THE CARERS ACT WILL BE
AVAILABLE- OVERALL TO OTHERS
BUT- THIS IS NOT AN EASY TASK
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT BILL
IT'S OF. DIFFICULT SITUATION-
BUT THE THIS BILL AND IT'S
CONCEPTS HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AND PART OF THE
SOLUTION SO. I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I DON'T
USUALLY IT'S NOT BEEN MY
PRACTICE TO. SUPPORT A BILL
PRIOR TO OUR HEARING BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS WAS NOTED. IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE OPENING
I AM HONORED TO BE. ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AND AS THE PRINCIPLE
COOPER FROM THE SENATE HAVING
WORKED FOR HEART IN THIS BILL I
KNOW IT FAIRLY WELL- WE NEED TO
CONFRONT A POTENTIAL WAVE OF
EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES ON
AN UNPRECEDENTED SCALE. AND
DOING NOTHING IS NOT AN OPTION.
CAN WE CLOSE. HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT SO- THE- TO THE LANDLORDS
OPPOSING THE BILL BECAUSE
YOU'VE NOT GOTTEN RENT FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS WE HEAR YOU EVEN
IF I DID CUT YOU OFF ABSOLUTELY
IT'S A PROBLEM AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT GOTTEN RENT
WHICH THEY NEED TO MAKE THEIR
PAYMENTS AND TO MAINTAIN THE
PROPERTY. THIS IS A CRISIS FOR
THEM AS WELL AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL ALSO GIVES YOU THE
RIGHT TO DEFER YOUR MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS AS WELL. AND IF YOU IF
YOU HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT IT IS IN THIS BILL AS IT
HAS BEEN CRAFTED. YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A FORBEARANCE AS WELL.
THE BILL DOES NOT CANCEL
ANYONE'S RENT. IT DOES NOT
CANCEL MORTGAGES. AND I KNOW
THERE IN THAT- ACTIVISTS OUT
THERE DEMANDING THAT WE CANCEL
THINGS BUT- I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
FAIR. AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE. FOR SMALL
LANDLORDS HOME MORE OWNERS AND
TENANTS ALIKE THE BILL
TEMPORARILY DEFERS THOSE
PAYMENTS. BUT EVERYONE STILL
HAS TO PAY THEM EVENTUALLY.
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS WORKED
REALLY HARD ON THIS AND- TO TRY
TO IDENTIFY EVERY INCENTIVE
REPAIR POSSIBLE AND URGE THAT
TO THEIR LANDLORDS. IT IS PART
OF THIS BILL THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO MAKE CLEAR THAT UNDER THE
BILL LANDLORDS CAN EVICT
TENANTS FOR ANY LAWFUL REASON.
ANY LAWFUL REASON WHETHER IT'S
NUISANCE OR DAMAGING PROPERTY
OR BREAKING MATERIAL TERM OF
TE LEASE THE ONLY EXCEPTION IS
THAT IF THE REASON FOR THE
EVICTION. IS THAT THE TENANT
HAS FALLEN BEHIND ON THE RENT
DURING THIS CALL OF A DYING
TEEN PANDEMIC THEN THE LANDLORD
MUST GIVE THE TENANT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEFERRED THOSE
PAYMENTS BY SIGNING AN
ATTESTATION THAT THE TENANT HAS
A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. DUE TO
COVERT NINETEEN AND I WILL SAY
WE'VE ALSO HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHAT THAT ATTESTATION
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND THAT I
THINK IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION. GOING
FORWARD IN THIS BILL. BUT THE
KEY TO NOTE. THAT THIS BILL
PROTECTS HOMEOWNERS FROM LOSING
THEIR HOMES TO FORECLOSURE AS
WELL. NACHOS PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS AND SMALL LANDLORDS BUT
FOR HOMEOWNERS AND THE LAST
TIME WE HAD THIS IN THE GREAT
RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT THIS LEGISLATURE WAS
CALLED UPON TO TRY TO CLEAN UP
A MESS. THAT WAS CREATED
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THOSE
FORECLOSURES. WE ARE TRYING TO
ACT PROACTIVELY IN THIS CASE TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING AND
AS THE ANALYSIS DISCUSSES-
THERE ARE. OF COMPONENT TO THIS
BILL WE HAVE CREATED AN
EXCEPTION FOR CREDIT UNIONS AND
SMALL LENDERS- HOW FOR COMMUTE
HUMANITY COMES TO BEAR TO MIND
IS ONE THAT. THAT WE SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZING DOES UNIQUE AND
EXTRAORDINARY WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AND I
THINK THAT- AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN IN OPPOSITION- THERE
PLEASE TAKE NOTE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO. CONSIDER WHAT'S BEST
AND WHAT IS FAIR FOR SMALL
LANDLORDS I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE BANKS- AND IN THOSE
FOLKS WHO HAVE COME IN
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO IT THAT MY
FRIENDS AT THE CHURCH COMMERCE
TO VIEW SUCH. A MAKES NO SENSE
TO ME BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL
IT A WHAT'S YOUR PLAN. HOW ARE
WE GOING TO PEOPLE SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THIS CATASTROPHIC
EVENT AS A RESULT OF THE
CATASTROPHIC EVENT THAT WE ARE
IN NOW.AND SO- AGAIN- THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT-
THE AUTHORS HAVE DONE TO TRY TO
ASSIST THE OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL- I WON'T GET INTO THAT IF
OTHERS WANT TO DO THAT TO
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS OF IT WE
CERTAINLY COULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION. BUT AGAIN THE
SPIRIT OF THIS BILL IS TO BRING
EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE REQUIRE
EVERYBODY OF LITTLE SKIN IN
THIS GAME NO ONE'S GONNA
BENEFIT AND MAKE OUT LIKE A
BANDIT IF YOU WILL AS A RESULT
OF THIS PANDEMIC NO. BUT IT
SHOULD. REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU
LIVE. FIRST HERE THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS THERE SHOULD BE
NOBODY WHO COMES OUT THE
BETTER. FOR THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE LOST. A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND LIVES IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND ELEVEN THOUSAND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO ME THAT WOULD BE
NOT ONLY DISGRACEFUL. BUT A
MORAL. AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER. FROM
THE BANKERS DOWN TO THE LITTLE
THAT. WRECK WE ALL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO MEET THOSE
EXPECTATIONS BUT IN THIS CALL
NINETY CRIED. THIS IS A CHANNEL.
THAT I BELIEVE THIS BILL TRIES
TO ADDRESS IN A WAY THAT'S FAIR
AND APPROPRIATE. THOSE ARE MY
TWO CENTS PROBABLY TWENTY CENTS
BUT I WILL GO WITH THE- SENATOR
ABOARD SHIPS AND THEN FOR BY.
RUSSELL. THANK YOU CHAIR. THAT
SUITS. WE BEGIN THIS AT AM IT'S
ALMOST THIRTY BY THE TIME WE
GOT TO THE ACTUAL SUB OF THE-
THIS COULD BE A LAW NIGHT I
THINK CENTER MY- SAID IT BEST.
I THINK IT'S AN THAT WE IGNORE
ALL THAT THERE WAS IN. IN THIS
IDEA OUR THAT THIS LEGISLATION
ALLOWS FOR ATTENTION TO BE
BROUGHT TO THE SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS AND I'LL DEFINITELY GIVE
YOU CREDIT FOR THAT I THINK ONE
OF THE BIGGEST COMPLAINTS THAT
I'VE HAD AT LEAST ON FLOOR
VOTES. WITH SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DISCUSSED EARLIER IS
THAT HE WAS ONLY THE RENTER'S.
AND THERE'S A CONTINUUM OF
INTERRELATED ENTITIES HERE
BETWEEN THE RENTERS. THE
LANDLORDS THE CAPITAL MARKETS-
IN EVENTUALLY YOU KNOW SOME OF
THOSE ARE POWERFUL IT OUT OVER
THE WORLD. SO YOU CAN'T JUST
LOOK UPON THEM BEEN SEGMENTED
WAYS IT'S ALMOST IMPERATIVE THE
YEP DO APPRECIATE. THE
CONTINUUM OF INTERESTED
PARTIES. BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
SOLVE A PROBLEM BY IGNORING
THOSE OTHER PARTIES. IF I MAY
THROUGH THE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
JUST KIND OF JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT FOR CLARITY ON AND
ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES. SO.
LET'S START WITH THE TENANT
HARDSHIP I'M FROM LET'S LOOK AT
THE LANGUAGE I THINK I HAVE A
DECENT APPRECIATION OF WHAT IT
IS I DON'T WHAT I DON'T
NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND IS WHY
WE'RE NOT HOLDING. OUR THE
ATTESTATION IN THE
DEMONSTRATION OF HARDSHIP TO A
HIGHER LEVEL. FROM WHAT I READ
THAT THERE IS SIMPLY A
REPRESENTATION THAT I SUFFER
HARDSHIP- 10% OR WHATEVER IT
IS. A DECREASE IN- IN INCOME
THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT. SO ONE
THING I WOULD WANT AND MAYBE
YOU CAN COMMENT ON. IS WHY
WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO MAKE IT A
FORMAL ATTESTATION UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. AND ALSO A
COMPANY THAT TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE WITH SOME SORT OF
REPRESENTATION SOME SORT OF
FINANCIAL REPRESENTATION.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I DON'T THINK
IT IT IT ASKS FOR THAT. IF YOU
SAID THAT HAS IMPACTED MINE
MINE ECONOMICS AND THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE I'M NOT
CERTAIN THAT WHICH IS A
REASONABLE OR FAIR AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT MEAN MAYBE IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT WHY. WASN'T THAT
ELEVATE. SURE HAPPY TO THAT LET
ME FIRST JUST START BY SAYING
THE ORIGINAL VERSION THE BILL
ACTUALLY DIDN'T HAVE THE
ATTESTATION LANGUAGE AND THE
RATIONALE FOR THAT WAS WE KNOW
THAT ALL TENANTS ARE STRUGGLING
AND THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD.
REQUIRE ANYTHING GIVEN THE
SITUATION WOULD BE CHALLENGING
BUT- AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CHAIR AND OTHERS- WE MOVE
FORWARD IN ANTICIPATION
REQUIREMENT AGAIN FOR THE VERY
POINT OF WE WANT TO OBVIOUSLY
FOCUSES ON PEOPLE HAVE NEEDS.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES FOR THAT
UNDER PENATY OF PERJURY IT IS
NOT CURRENTLY- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IF I MIGHT JUST
INTERRUPT HIM PART OF THE
REASON IT ISN'T IS IT IT'S
MODELED AFTER ACTUALLY THE
FEDERAL VERSION. CURRENTLY NOW
UNDER THE FEDERAL VERSION INDIA
THANK BE SIMPLE AT. AND DOES
REQUIRE ANYTHING MORE SO THAT
WE IT WAS MODEL YOU MODELED IT
AFTER WHAT IS THE CURRENT
FEDERAL ATTESTATION SO I THINK
THAT PUTS IT A LITTLE BIT IN
CONTEXT BUT THE QUESTION SALUTE
IS A VALID POINT I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT A IS ACTUALLY SO-
MANAGER- HAD MENTIONED. ONE KEY
POINT WHICH IS WHICH IS WHAT
SHE JUST SAID ANOTHER CHALLENGE
HAS BEEN- THEIR UGGESTION THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN DOCUMENTS
THAT SHOULD BE REQUIRED YOU
SHOW A BANK STATEMENT YOU SHOW-
SOME EMPLOYER. AND WE. KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY TENANTS
WHO. CAN WHERE THE- FRANKLY
JUST IN PA TO GET. SO IF YOU
WORK FOR. A SMALL THAT HAS GONE
ON AND YOU CAN EVEN FOR YOUR
BOSS. IF YOU UNDOCUMENTED
YOU'RE GETTING PAID- IN IN TO
THROUGH THROUGH DIFFERENT MONEY
ECONOMIES IF YOU'RE ON BANKS
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
BANKING STATEMENT SO. THE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW- YOU NEED TO PROVE
WITH DOCUMENTATION THAT YOU
HAVE SUFFERED- AND ECONOMIC IT
IS IT'S JUST FRANKLY CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT. SO THIS
CONVERSATION HAS NOT BEEN
SIMPLE BUT I WILL SAY. IT IS AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION- AND- WE
ARE CERTAINLY IN FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT'S THE
RIGHT WAY DISTRICT THE BALANCE
BECAUSE I THINK WE WANT TO
ENSURE IS. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO NEED THIS HELP SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GET IT. WE DON'T WANT
TO CREATE SUCH A DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENT TO DETERMINE THAT-
WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO SCARE
FOLKS OFF WHO- MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO AN ATTORNEY AND I
SHOULD. MENTION IN THIS
CONTEXT. TYPICALLY IN LANDLORD
TENANT THE LANDLORD TENANT.
LAWSUITS. LANDLORDS ARE
REPRESENTED NINETY PER OF THE
TIME. TENANTS WERE LESS THAN
10% OF THE TIME SO ANYTHING
THAT WERE. A YOU PENALTY
APPROACH FOR SOMEONE COULD BE
PROSECUTOR HAS A CHILLING OF
AND IF THEIR DOCTOR
REQUIREMENTS A TOUCH THAT THAT
MAKES IT REALLY HARD SO THAT'S
WHY THIS ISSUE IS COMPLICATED
BUT YOUR BEGINNER TO MY EARLIER
POINT WE ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THIS AND- AND I SUSPECT
THEY'LL BE MORE CONVERSATIONS
AGAIN I AND I DO APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK. THERE ARE SOME
UNDERLYING REALITIES WHERE THAT
WOULD POSE A DIFFICULTY- I
THINK ULTIMATELY HOWEVER. TO BE
FAIR. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
SERIOUS- REASSESSMENT ON THE
DOCUMENTATION AND ATTESTATION-
TO MAKE THAT BETTER LIMIT A
LIMIT LET ME MOVE ON. THE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCIES
INCLUDES BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL ENTITIES SO THAT. IS THAT
CORRECT THAT WITH THIS HE
ACTUALLY I TRY TO LEAVE ALSO
WITH THE CHAIRS SPA SUGGESTION
WE TOOK OUT THE LOCAL
EMERGENCIES PIECE IN AT THIS
POINT SO WHAT. WE DID START
WITH THE DRAFT STATE AND LOCAL
I BELIEVE AT THIS POINT WE'VE
TAKEN OUT THE LOCAL THIS IS THE
CHALLENGE OF THEIR TRUNCATED TO
LEGISLATIVE ACCOUNT. OR HAVING
GOTTEN IT THIS MORNING. IN ON
THIS IS GONE THROUGH QUITE A
FEW AND THEN. THAT ARE THAT ARE
AND ALL ALL GO IN MOVE ON. FOR
THOSE FOR THOSE LOAN THAT HAVE
BEEN PACKAGED BEHIND THEM THIS
WERE HERE THE CORPORATE LARGER
ENTITIES- THE INVESTMENT TRUSTS
THIS IS WHERE I HEAR THEIR
ANGST ON THIS. IS THAT IF YOU
TAKE AWAY ON THE OBLIGATIONS OF
THE RENTERS IN CAN FOR THE
SMALL- MOM AND POP. A MULTI
FAMILY UNITS. THERE'S A MASSIVE
SEGMENT OF THE INDUSTRY THAT
INCLUDES THE CORPORATE ENTITIES
THE INVESTMENT TRUSTS VENTURE
CAPITALIST SO ON AND SO FORTH.
THESE INDIVIDUALS. ARE GOING TO
BE ON THE HOOK RIGHT SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS. IF THE DAY ARE
PUBLICLY TRADED FOR THAT. FIFTY
M. LOANS THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN
PACKAGE PORTFOLIO IN FLOATED ON
THE MARKET EITHER DOMESTICALLY
OVERSEAS. HOW DOES THIS PLAY
OUT DO WE KNOW. YES BUT AS OUR
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE CHAIRED
SUDAN'S. THE BILL IS FOCUSED ON
MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE FOR AN
UNDER UNITS SO IT REALLY
DEPENDS I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT A
CORPORATION THAT BIG WOULD ONLY
HAVE FOUR. UNITS AND THIS BILL
DOES NOT SOLVE FOR ANYONE WHO
HAD MORE THAN FOUR UNITS IN
TERMS OF FOR EXACTLY THAT. THIS
MIGHT IS THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
ENVISIONED. AS OUTLINED IN THE
LEGISLATION. AND I KIND OF GO
BACK TO THE CONTINUUM. OF
INTERESTED PARTIES WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY FINAL THOUGHTS ON WE'RE
LEAVING OUT LARGER ENTITIES
MEDIUM TO LARGER AND EVEN
INTERNATIONAL ENTITIES FROM
THIS- THE BILL ITSELF ON THE
MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE SIDE IT'S
FOCUSED ON. THE AREAS FOCUSED
ON SMALLER LANDLORDS- AS
OPPOSED TO THE CORPORATE ONES
OR BIGGER ONES- AND IT WAS
DESIGNED THAT WAY- IT BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT WHERE IS THE
GREATEST NEED I THINK THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE ENTIRE. PACKAGE
IN THE ENTIRE BILL IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAD IT FOR EVERYBODY
NOT EVERYONE BENEFITS FROM THIS
BILL BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS FOR THE GREATEST
FINANCIAL NEED CAN BE AND SO WE
FOCUSED ON THE SMALL. LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS ALL RIGHT SO HERE
AND I'LL FINISH UP WITH A LOT
OF LAST POINTS THAT HAVE CAUGHT
MY ATTENTION WE'VE DISCUSSED AT
LENGTH. WHAT THE MARKET IS. THE
HOUSING DIFFICULTIES THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE STATE
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PHILOSOPHIES SOME HAVE.
REFERENCE FOR RENT CONTROL SOME
HAVE FREE MARKET SO ON AND SO
FORTH. BUT SHOULD WE BE
CONCERNED THAT THIS FORBEARANCE
PROCESS ULTIMATELY WILL BE
BORNE BY THE CAPITAL MARKETS.
THE THIS WILL DIS INCENTIVIZE.
THE FLOW OF CAPITAL. ONE IT
WOULD DISINCENTIVE EYES THE
FLOW OF CAPITAL A NUMBER TWO
FOR THOSE ENTITIES WISHING TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
MULTI FAMILY UNITS AT A LARGER
SCALE. THE RATIO OF ELIGIBILITY.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS SEEKING A
LOAN THEY MIGHT BE CAPPED OUT
OF THE MARKET BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE LOOKING AT TWENTY FIVE
OR 50% DOWN ON THESE CAPITAL.
INVESTMENTS LENDING
INSTITUTIONS MIGHT ACTUALLY
YANKED OUT ALL THE WAY UP 275%
OR WHATEVER THAT THE MARKET
WILL BEAR ARE WE NOT CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE SOLVING A SHORT TERM
ISSUE POSSIBLY A MEDIUM BUT
CREATING SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM
HOUSING PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO ALL ANSWER THAT QUESTION IN
A IN A FEW WAYS SO- I THINK THE
PARENTS OR IS IT MAY HAVE SOME
IMPACT ON THOSE CREDIT MARKETS
BUT THE CHOICES WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US ARE STARK. THE
CHOICES ARE DO WE WANT TO SEE A
WAVE OF MASS EVICTIONS. WHICH
LEAD TO A WAVE OF MASS
FORECLOSURES. WHICH WOULD
DESTROY THE ECONOMY. OR DO WE
WANT. ASK FOR EVERYONE TO TAKE
A PAUSE FOR SAY SIX OR TWELVE
MONTHS. IN ORDER FOR RENTERS TO
GET ABOUT BACK ON THEIR FEET.
TO BE ABLE TO PAY BACK. THEIR
LANDLORDS WHO CAN THEN TURN
AROUND AND PAY BACK. THE
MORTGAGE HOLDER AND STABILIZE
THE MARKET. I WOULD SUBMIT.
THAT THE IDEA THAT WE ARE GOING
TO AFFECT. A GENERATION OF
RENTERS. AND THEN HAVE A WAVE
OF FORECLOSURES WOULD BE FAR
MORE CATASTROPHIC TO THE
ECONOMY THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
RIGHT NOW- BUT I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST- YOU KNOW LISTEN I
THINK. FOR ALL OF US THE IDEAL
SOLUTION WOULD BE IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. COULD
INVEST MONEY- AND HELP
STABILIZE THE ECONOMY THAT WE
CAN STOCKLEY THAT'S EXACTLY
WHERE I THINK. YOU NEED TO GO
IF WE'RE IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS. THE STATE HAS TO PLAY A
ROLE. AND I THINK WHAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED POLITICALLY IS THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY LIABILITIES
IN SO MANY UNCERTAINTIES RIGHT
NOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT THE ROLE
THAT CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CAN
PLAY THE TAXPAYERS CAN PLAY IN
CREATING A FUND. TO HELP THAT
CONTINUE IN THAT I KEEP ON
TALKING ABOUT. WOULD PROBABLY
BE POLITICALLY UNPALATABLE SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS THAT WERE
USING THE INSTRUMENTS OF THE
STATE. IN INTERFERING IN
PRIVATE CONTRACTUAL SITUATIONS
BASED ON A NEED. BUT WE HAVEN'T
EVEN HEARD OF THIS OF ANY REAL
SIGNIFICANT OP LOOK INVESTMENT
INTO A STATE LOAN FOR SOME SORT
OF ECONOMIC HOUSING FUND FROM
WHICH INDIVIDUALS COULD DRAW.
IN IN CREATE THAT BUT I MEAN
IT'S A HERE'S MY LAST BUT IF I
COULD JUST RESPONDED THAT WOULD
HELP OUT A LITTLE LET HIM
RESPOND I THINK THERE'S ONE
THING HE SAID ABOUT THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE BEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN HERE IS IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COULD ASSIST
US. STATE TO BUY THE TO GET WE
DON'T GET THE PRINT MONEY THAT
SPRINT PROPHECY WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T PRINT MONEY. AND WE JUST
SAW FOR FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT SO THE
IDEA THAT THERE ARE MANY
PENNIES UNDER THE COUCH THAT WE
CAN PUT TOGETHER THE PIECES
IT'S CHALLENGING- THE
WASHINGTON. NOT ACTED. WE HAVE
A TWO WEEK CLOCK TICK WE COULD
SEE. LITERALLY NO OF TENANTS
INTO WHO COULD FACE OF X.
NOTICES WE HAVE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM IF THERE'S A BETTER WAY
TO DO IT I AM ALL EARS BUT I
THINK UNTIL. ANYONE ELSE TELLS
US THAT THEY'RE GONNA COME TO
THE RESCUE WITH A HUGE AMOUNT
OF MONEY WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE
THIS FOR OURSELVES AND THIS IS
THE BEST IDEA WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO COME UP WITH RIGHT NOW AND I
CAN APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORT- MY FINAL CONCERN.
IS THAT. THIS WILL. ALMOST
CERTAINLY BRING ABOUT
LITIGATION. ARMY AND I'VE I
WOULD HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW CONSTITUTIONALITY. THE
FEDERAL PREEMPTION ISSUE
SOMEONE AND SO FORTH. THE
REASON I BRING UP THOSE LIKE
THOSE. LEGAL LIABILITIES IS
ONLY BECAUSE IT MAY STALL OUT.
THIS PROCESS SO WE HAVE TO ALSO
BE THINKING ABOUT A PLAN B. IN
THE EVENTUALITY THAT THIS IDEA
DOESN'T WORK BUT MY LAST
QUESTION IS CREDIT WORTHINESS
SO I BELIEVE IN THE
LEGISLATION. CREDIT RATING
AGENCIES CANNOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT- THIS PERIOD OF TIME
DURING FORBEARANCE. BUT RENTS
ARE STILL GOING TO BE DO NOW
LET'S BE REALISTIC SOMEONE AS A
WHOLE YEAR'S WORTH OF RENT THAT
IS DUE- CHANCES ARE. A LOT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO GET PAID
BACK WANTS COME DUE. OR THEY
ARE GOING TO FAIL TO
RENEGOTIATE UNDER NEW TERMS- AS
IT HAPPENS WILL THEN THE
CREDIT. RATING OF PROCESS KICK
IN AT THAT POINT WHEN THE YEARS
OF POP. THAT THEY CAN THEN.
BOTHERED THEIR CREDIT CAN BE
REEVALUATED IN TARNISHED FOR
LACK OF PAYMENT. EITHER FOR THE
AT THE RENTAL LEVEL OR AT THE
MORTGAGE LEVEL. I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND PROCESS QUESTION LET
ME JUST EXPLAIN WHAT THE BILL
IS ATTEMPTING TO DO WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IN THIS BILL IS SET FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME DURING THIS
CALL THAT EMERGED IN ORDER TO
DO THE QUESTIONS REALLY CLEARS.
WINDOWS THE CREDIT AGENCY
REVIEW. KICK BACK IN. BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T. YOU CAN'T ABSOLVE A
POPULATION LIKE THIS THAT
RELIES ON CREDIT. THROUGH THE
YOU KNOW THROUGH ALL THE
INSTRUMENTS OF COMMERCE HE HAS
TO KICK BACK IN AT SOME POINT
TO A CREDIT RATING REVIEW OF A
BORROWER OF LENDERS OR BORROWER
RENTER SILENCE OVER WIN WELL
THAT KICK BACK IN AGREED SO WE
SO WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING IS
THAT DURING THIS CALL THAT
EMERGE TYPE HEARD HOW IT
DEFINED LET'S SAY. FOR DEFINITE
OF THIS ITS THIRD MONTHS OF. BE
IT WAS NOT THE FOR. OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO HIM OR HER BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
PANDEMIC IN THE SHUTDOWN ORDER
IN THE JOBS IN MY OF LOSS IN
INCOME THEY MAY HAVE NOT SEEN
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO BE A
PERMANENT THING ON THE RECORD
THAT FOLLOWS HIM FOR THE NEXT
SEVEN YEARS THAT IMPACTS MANY
ASPETS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS CREDIT. ACCESS FUTURE
MORTGAGES ECCENTRICITY WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS FOR THIS PERIOD
OF TIME WE WANT TO NOT HAVE
THAT IMPACT THEIR CREDIT RATING
BUT SHORTLY THEREAFTER THE
REPORT AND AN EARLY THEREAFTER
IT CREDIT RATING REVIEW WILL BE
ACTIVATED YES. AND INTO YOUR
POINT I WOULD STILL BE NERVOUS
ABOUT THAT SITUATION BUT I
WOULD SUSPECT THAT YOU YOU KNOW
THE MAJORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
AT SOME POINT YOUR CREDIT HAS
TO BECOME YOUR CREDIT- ONCE WE
GET THROUGH THIS AND ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD OF COVER VERSIONS WE
SHOULD. BE POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE
CREDIT DINGS ARE NOT THEIR
FAULT THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
THAT THAT WAS. QUESTIONS THE
FOR BEAR. IN THIS BILL IS ONLY
OF. ON EGGS. LAW SO IT
SHOULDN'T FEW LOAN TO IS CLEAR
THAT THE IS THE- THERE'S ONE
OTHER THING I. WANTED TO ADD
YOU. THIS BILL IN MORE JUST ONE
FOUR. SO FROM ONE TO FOUR HOURS
YOU COULD RECEIVE UP TO TWELVE
MONTHS OF FORBEARANCE
COMPARABLE TO- TO COMPARABLE
TO- WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
FEDERAL CARES ACT. BUT FOR-
UNITS A FIVE OR MORE YOU WOULD
STILL BE AVAILABLE FOR UP TO
SIX MONTHS WHICH WAS ALSO
PARALLEL TO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AND THE
AND THE CREDIT JUST CAN'T BE
DOING BASED ON FAILURE TO
DURING. THE COVER PERIOD WHAT
WE AT HI GOOD. SO NEXT WE HAVE
US DO RUSSIA THANK YOU FOR THAT
DISCUSSION. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANNA THANK THE
BILL OF THE ALL OF THIS BILL
TOM THIS IS ALL HAVE SO AND
THERE'S SO MANYTHAT WERE
JUGGLING TO TRY TO ADDRESS TO
TRY TO FIX TO TRY TO PREVENT-
NO FOR FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE IMPACTED ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER WITH EITHER THE
HEALTH ISSUES OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES OR- THE FINANCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES SO I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO CALLED IN TO LEND THEIR
SUPPORT- IT TOOK SEVERAL HOURS
BUT- IT WAS WELL WORTH IT TO
HEAR ABOUT THIS- AND IT JUST
REINFORCES ALL WHAT IS GOING ON
IN MY OWN DISTRICT. WHICH IS A
WITHOUT A DOUBT- THE RENTAL AND
THE MORTGAGES- ARE THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT NUMBER
ONE NO DOUBT ABOUT IT. WE EVEN
THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF HURDLES
EVEN THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF
RESIDENTS IN MY DISTRICT- 77%
ARE RENTERS AND THAT'S THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF RENTERS
IN THE WHOLE STATE. BUT I DON'T
WANT THEM TO BE RENTERS FOREVER
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE RENTS
FOR OVER THEY WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BUY. AND BUILD WEALTH AND
BUILD BUILD EQUITY BUT SO MUCH
IS AT STAKE FOR THEM THAT RIGHT
NOW THE ONLY THING THAT THEY
ARE WORRIED ABOUT DRAMATICALLY
FREEDOM IS HOW TO STAY IN A
SAFE AND SAFE SHELTER- I JUST
READING THIS ARTICLE FIGHT. CAN
MANAGER- THE CAME OUT AND
CALMATTERS- AND WE ARE I THINK
WE WERE ALL WORKING UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE WAS SOME
LEVEL OF. OF A ANY FICTION
MORATORIUM FUNCTIONING OUT
THERE BUT IT SHOWS THAT N A
MATTER OF A FEW MONTHS
STATEWIDE. JUST WHAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO DOCUMENT WAS SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS WERE
EVICTED. SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS UNDER UNDER SOME
VERSION OF A NEED OF AN TO BE
FICTION MORATORIUM. AND THAT
DIDN'T COUNT FOURTEEN COUNTIES
IT DIDN'T REPLY TO THEIR
SURVEY. INCLUDING LA. SO UP
ALREADY EVEN UNDER AGAIN SOME
VERSION. OF PROTECTION FOR
TENANTS. YOU KNOW CLOSE TO TWO
THOUSAND FAMILIES HAVE BEEN
EVICTED. EACH ONE OF THOSE
FAMILIES THE TROM THAT IS
CAUSING ON THEM TO LOSE A SAFE
PLACE TO LIVE AND IS SOMETHING
THAT- I'M GLAD YOUR BILL
ADDRESSES. AND I'D LIKE TO
THINK THAT THERE WERE ALL KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WE COULD DO WITH
YOUR BILL TO MAKE IT. BIGGER
AND BETTER AND OF FOR ALL OF
THOSE WHO WERE IN FEAR BUT-
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED RIGHT NOW YOU DOING
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIANS
NEED. RIGHT NOW IT'S GOING TO
HELP HELP I DON'T KNOW HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS MAYBE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE. BUT IT'S BETTER TO GO
THROUGH SOMETHING RIGHT NOW
GIVE SOME SEMBLANCE OF ORDER.
ABSOLUTE CHAOS WHICH IS GOING
TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU SAID IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS SO I AM. I
REALLY THINK THAT THE EVEN
THOUGH. WE ARE GOING TO BE
FACING AND THOSE FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO BE FACING A SOMETHING
IN A YEAR OR SO. AS FAR AS-
RENTS OR MORTGAGES THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILT UP- AND THAT'S GONNA
BE ANOTHER CRISIS WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS. BUT
IN IN THE MEANWHILE WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE SOME OF A SENSE
OF ORDER SOME SENSE. PROTECTION
FOR BOTH. OF ALL. AS WELL AS
OUR RENTERS SO I WANNA. SHOW MY
ABSOLUTE SUPPORT AND I HOPE
THAT THEY'LL BE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE DO WHICH IS- EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WHICH IS. THESE
WRENCHES AND- HOMEOWNERS WILL
NOT HAVE TO COME UP WITH TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. IN
DEBT. AT THE END OF ONE YEAR OR
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A
SENATOR MORNING WHITE HOUSE KEY
STERN AND WILK. GONZALEZ AND-
LET SENATOR MELENDEZ TO THE
GROUP PART LET'S GO UP. TO
SENATOR MONNING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I TOO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS TOM. FOR ADVANCING
THIS SIN THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAIR FOR HELPING TO. FURTHER
AN EXPERT. THEM THOSE WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE COVERAGE
CONTEMPLATED HERE. AGAIN I
THINK THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THIS
IN HIS OPENING BUT THAT WAS
THIS MORNING FROM THE CONTEXT
OF THIS CRISIS IS UNPRECEDENTED
WE'VE HAD OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS DONE. OVER A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND.
AMERICANS HAVE DIED. THE SCOPE
OF THIS WE'VE BECOME ALMOST
NUMB TO THE REALITY- IF THIS
HAPPENED IN WAR THE NUMBERS
WOULD BE HUGE IF THIS HAPPENED
IN ANY OTHER FORM OF NATURAL
DISASTER THIS WOULD BE HUGE.
THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCE HAS
RESULTED IN. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOSING JOBS. AND
NOW THE E. D. D. SUPPORT THE
FEDERAL SUPPORT IS EXHAUSTED
AND HAS NOT BEEN RENEWED SO
PEOPLE WHO HAD SOME COMBINATION
OF EDT MONEY FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL CARES ACT MONEY AND
THE- UNEMPLOYMENT SUPPLEMENT
IT'S ALL GONE. SO THE NEXT STEP
IF YOU'RE HELD TO PAY YOUR RENT.
AS A FAMILY. AND YOU FACE
EVICTION. YOU FACE HOMELESSNESS.
SO THEN ARM AGENCY SERVICES
WILL HAVE TO CONSTRUCT TENT
CITIES. REFUGEE CENTERS.
TAKEOVER SCHOOL GYMS THE HOUSE.
THOSE THAT WERE UNABLE TO PAY
RENT. THIS BILL PROVIDES
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY RELIEF NOT
JUST FOR TENANTS BUT ALSO FOR
HOMEOWNERS FOR SMALL LANDLORDS-
AND I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO
TRY TO DEFINE AND EXPAND. AND I
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THERE
ARE SOME WHO WON'T ENJOY THE
PROTECTION LARGE CORPORATIONS
INVESTMENT FUNDS THEY ARE
PERHAPS A BETTER POSITION TO
GET SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WAS SHOWN IN THE
ONE AND ONLY CARES ACT WHERE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WENT TO
BANKING INSTITUTIONS. AND
CHECKS FOR ONE CHECK FOR TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. CAME TO POOR
WORKING PEOPLE SO THAT'S ALL BY
WAY OF KIND OF BACKGROUND OF
THE GRAVITY OF THE CRISIS SO MY
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR AUTHORS.
MOM IS. THE RELIEF THAT'S
PROVIDED IS TEMPORARY IT'S A
PERIOD OF MONTHS. IN WITH THE
EXPECTATION AND THE REQUIREMENT
THAT ANY RENT OWED. OR PAYMENTS
OWED WILL EVENTUALLY HAVE TO BE
PAID TO THE LANDLORD TO THE
BANKING INSTITUTION. IT SETRA.
HAVE YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO.
HOW PEOPLE THAT MAY BENEFIT
TEMPORARILY ARE SUPPOSED TO
COME UP WITH THAT KIND OF MONEY
IF THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY
EARNING. IF THEY'RE NOT
CURRENTLY. RECEIVING ANY
FEDERAL RELIEF. ARE WE JUST
POSTPONING WHAT'S GONNA BE. THE
NEXT CRISIS AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON HOW WE MITIGATE
THAT HIT SOME AFTER IF THIS
BILL BECOMES LAW AND RUNS ITS
COURSE. HOW DO WE PROTECT
PEOPLE AGAINST THAT CLIFF. SO
THE QUICK ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS I DO HAVE CONCERNS
AT THIS BILL MAY NOT BE ENOUGH
EVEN IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED IN
ITS FULL FORM WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS WE GIVE PEOPLE PERIOD OF
TIME- FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS TO NOT BE EVICTED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY PAY THE RENT AND
WE GIVE THEM ANOTHER PERIOD OF
TIME. TO HOPEFULLY EARN MONEY-
TO BE ABLE TO PAY BACK THE RENT
AND THEN AT SOME POINT SOON ALL
THAT THAT IS GOING TO COME OUT
AND LANDLORDS CAN GO AFTER
THOSE TENANTS FOR THE FULL
AMOUNT OF THE RENT I DO WANT TO
SAY I KNOW. THE ARE THANK THE
CALIFORNIA PART ASSOCIATION I
REFERRED TO THIS BILLS ARE.
STRIKE BILL AND COMMUNICATE TO
ITS MEMBERS AND I THINK THAT
CONFUSED A LOT OF MEMBERS. WHO
ARE COMMUNICATING TODAY BUT
THAT'S JUST SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
YOU CAN'T CAMP HERE TO STRIKE.
IF UNDER THIS BILL WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS THE TENNIS WILL
ALL THE RENT. ARE TO YOUR
POINT. OF THE WEEK IF THE
COVERT PANT. AND THE RISK.
DEEPENS WE COULD. QUITE
CHALLENGE BUT MY SUGGESTION
HERE IS WE'RE TRYING TO GET IT
DOWN THE MIDDLE. TO GIVE A
CHANCE FOR. AT LEAST THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS CERTAINLY WHEN
THIS LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN
SESSION UNTIL NEXT YEAR- FOR US
TO NOT SEE A WAVE OF ACTIONS
AND HOPE FOR THE BEST BUT- YOU
KNOW. WE HAVE TO BE CREATIVE
AND OTHER SOLUTIONS. I ALSO YOU
KNOW WANT TO IGNORE THE FACT
THAT UNDERSTAND THAT IN KNOW AS
WE LOOK. TO BEFORE. IF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T COME TO OUR
RESCUE WE MAY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT OTHER SOURCES OF RUNNING.
I KNOW THERE'S A SUGGESTION OF
POTENTIALLY TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE GOVERNMENT TAX
CREDITS. TO BENEFIT LANDLORDS-
THE WHICH IS A BILL THAT. THIS
BODY CONSIDERED AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT. I VOTED IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN TENS APPROACH. AS
POTENTIALLY COMPLEMENTARY TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING. BUT AGAIN
WITH A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
BUDGET DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT.
IT'S UNCERTAIN WHETHER WE AS A
STATE. WOULD BE ABLE TO.
WITHSTAND THAT FINANCIAL HIT.
SO AGAIN LOOKING FOR IDEAS- BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK YOUR POINT. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE MAY
BRING AND IF THE FUTURE
CONTINUES POORLY WE COULD
CONTINUE TO BE IN TROUBLE BUT
IF WE DON'T DO THIS. YOU KNOW
IN TWO WEEKS WILL. IN DEEP DEEP
CRISIS AND I. THAT IN. THE
GRAVITY OF THE EMERGENCY RIGHT
NOW REQUIRES. EMERGENCY ACTION
WHICH TO ME THIS BILL
REPRESENTS. A BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE. TO CONTINUE TO
POINT OUT THE NEED FOR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT. THE NEED
FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS. TO PURSUE
A SPIRIT OF COOPERATION MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING AND MUTUAL
SUPPORT- A SPECIFIC QUESTION IF
APPROVING A RENTER FAMILY.
CAN'T PAY THE FULL RENT. ARE
THE DOES THIS BILL STILL ALLOW
THEM TO NEGOTIATE A PHONE
LANDLORDS WILLING TO TAKE LESS
THAN FULL RENT FROM THIS BILL
WOULD NOT PROHIBIT THAT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN LANDLORD AND
TENANT. ABSOLUTELY NOT AND IN
FACT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL WAS
ACTUALLY A POLICY VALUE THAT
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE-
WANTED TO SEE HIM BETTER THAN
THIS BILL SO WE VERY MUCH
ENCOURAGE VOLUNTARY
RENEGOTIATIONS OF THE RENT
BETWEEN LANDLORDS AND TENANTS.
THANK YOU IN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I THINK I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE SOMETHING THAT. THE
CHAIR SAID TO MANY WHO CALLED
IN OPPOSITION I HOPE YOU DO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
THE BILL AS AMENDED. AND TO SEE
THE RELIEF OFFERED NOT JUST TO
TENANTS. BUT TO SMALL LANDLORDS
AND HOMEOWNERS. AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU
MIGHT FIT AS A BENEFICIARY. IN
THAT CONTINUUM OR SPECTRUM OF
SUPPORT THAT'S OFFERED BY THIS
BILL. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS IN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY CERTAINLY
BEFORE WE GET TO THE NEXT BAKER
I WAS POSED TO ME AND I'D LIKE
TO SHE GOT AN ANSWER. FROM YOU
ARE THE ONE TO FOUR UNITS IS AN
AGGREGATE SO IF SOMEONE HAS
THREE FOUR YEAR UNIT APARTMENT
STATE DO NOT QUALIFY FOR THIS
OR DO THAT. FOR THE MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE YES. IF YOU HAVE
ONE TO THREE. NO IF THEY HAVE
THREE FOUR UNIT PROPERTIES OR
THREE THREE UNIT PROPERTY
SYSTEM. BASIS IT'S ON A UNIT
BASIS AT THIS MOMENT SO THE
ANSWER IS NO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE OPEN A P. OR THE
AGGREGATE YOU MUST HAVE LESS
THAN FOUR UNITS IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR OR LESS. FOR THE
FORBEARANCE. FOR A YEAR FOR
TWELVE MONTHS. CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT SO IT'S A TOTAL IT'S
TOTAL SO IF SOMEONE HAS FIVE
UNITS. THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE.
FOR TWELVE MONTHS. THEY COULD
GET SIX MONTHS. THANKS THANK
YOU MY APOLOGIES FOR THAT FOR
TRYING TO. NO NO I CAN I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
BECAUSE IT WE HAVEN'T HAD A FEE
FOR THIS BILL HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY REFOCUSED. AN
EXPANDED TO TRY TO INCLUDE
EVERYBODY EVEN THE BANKS- TO
THE EXTENT THEY'RE WILLING TO
PLAY BALL. BUSTLED IT'S WORTH
THE DISCUSS AND PERHAPS A
CENTER MELINDA'S IF YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS YOU'D LIKE TO
ASK. WHERE DO WE GO TO YOU YOUR
EAGER TO PARTICIPATE IF YOU.
BUT IN THE IT WAS MY TURN YET
BUT I'M HAPPY TO WELL I WOULD I
WAS THINKING THAT WE JUST- IF
YOU'D RATHER DIFFERENT WEIGHT
IF YOU'D RATHER AIT TILL LATER
THAT'S FINE. YOU KNOW IT'S FINE
I JUST IN ONE JUMP AHEAD OF
ANYONE I DON'T KNOW THAT'S
RIGHT THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
GOING TO WAIT PATIENTLY BECAUSE
I'M STILL THE CHAIR. ALL RIGHTY
THEN. PUT THANK YOU MAY. CHAIR
SO. ASSEMBLY MEN'S. I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. I
GUESS I'M JUST NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW THIS IS GOING
TO WORK FOR- THE HOME OWNER
WHO'S RENTING OUT THEIR
PROPERTY. IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT
A HOMEOWNER. WHO WHO RENTS OUT
A PROPERTY CAN GET A
FORBEARANCE- SO THAT'S A
TEMPORARY RELIEF FROM PAYING
THE MORTGAGE GREAT EXCEPT THAT
WHEN THAT FORBEARANCE ENDS.
THAT PROPERTY OWNER DAN MUST
PAY IN FULL THE AMOUNT THAT IS
OWED SO IF YOU'RE GOING IF YOU
WERE. TENANTS ISN'T PAYING RENT
FOR A YEAR AND THE BANK GIVES
YOU FORBEARANCE FOR A YEAR. AT
THE END OF THE YEAR DO YOU
REALLY THINK IT'S REALISTIC TO
ASSUME THAT A RENTER IS GOING
TO COME UP WITH A YEAR'S WORTH
OF RENT. IF THEY COULDN'T PAY
IT. THAT WHOLE YEAR. WHY. WHY
WOULD WE THINK THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE MONEY AFTER YEAR TO
PAY IN FULL AGAIN THE STRUCTURE
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY SAYS WE
WANNA GIVE TENANTS A YEAR TO
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET TO
HOPEFULLY EARN THE MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO PAY BACK THE LANDLORD.
AND AT THAT POINT. HOPEFULLY
THE TEN AND IS ABLE TO PAY THE
LANDLORDS ARE THE LANDLORD CAN
PAY THE MORTGAGE. YOU RAISE A
GOOD POINT WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE AGAIN WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
THE END OF YOUR BUT WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU IS IF WE START
AFFECTING FOLKS. OVER IF WE
TELL THEM THAT ALL THE RENT IS
DUE. NEXT MONTH. WE KNOW WHAT
THE OUTCOME IS GOING TO BE. IT
WAS TENANTS THOSE TENANTS WILL
BE HOME OWNER IS GOING TO BE
TOLD. ALL THE MORTGAGE IS DUE
AT THE END OF TWELVE MONTHS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO COME
UP WITH THAT. WHERE ARE THEY
GOING TO GET IT. IN PLACE. BUT
THIS BUT THIS BILL IN A MINUTE
BUT SOME OF THE- THE PEOPLE WHO
CALLED IN REMEMBER THEY WERE
SAYING. I JUST OWN WE ARE ONE
RENTAL PROPERTY NINE DEPEND ON
THAT. FOR MY INCOME BECAUSE I'M
RETIRED OR YOU KNOW WHAT HAVE
YOU. WHAT DO THEY DO. A LET'S
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONLY KNOWN
ANSWER THAT BECAUSE IT DEALS
WITH THE FORBEARANCE PART
PERHAPS YOU HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
US. THANK YOU. SO THAT YOU KNOW
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE CAN'T TELL. A
BANK HOW TO STRUCTURE THEIR
PAYMENTS. HOWEVER UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW SO THIS IS A LINE
WITH CARES ACT. SERVICES CANNOT.
UP SOME PREPAYMENT. AND IN THIS.
WHAT IT ALSO DOES IT SAYS THAT
IF A LUMP SUM. YOUR TALKING
ABOUT ALL OF THE RENT FOR SIX
ALL OF THE TARGET. FOR SIX
MONTHS. AT THE VERY END. THAT
NEEDS TO BE DISCLOSED UP FOR.
BEFORE SOMEONE GOES INTO THE
FOR PRINCE PROCESS. STILL THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE ONE. IS
NOT ALLOWED IN THE CURES ACT
AND THIS BILL IS A LINE THAT.
SECOND THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT.
EXPLICITLY BE SET UP FRONT. TO
THE BACK COULD BE PART OF THE
DECISION MAKING FOR THE-
HOMEOWNER LANDLORD. BEFORE I GO
INTO FOR POPS. OKAY JUST
COMPETE ME BECAUSE YOU JUST
SAID. THEY'RE NOT A- TO SAY YOU
HAVE TO PAY EVERY ALL AT. A
FRONT. BUT THEY ALSO TO
DISCLOSE THAT. THE GOING TO DO
THAT. WE CAN'T TELL STATE
ACCOUNT. CANNOT TELL ABOUT HOW
STRUCK. PAYMENTS SO WE CAN'T
BUT STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS
FEDERAL. UNDER THE CARE ACT DID
AND SAID. IF YOU CAN'T DO LAW
SUM. WHICH IS WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT
SO WE CAN'T DO THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY SAID
THAT YOU CAN'T TO LUMP SUMS.
BUT IT DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WANTED TO DO SO THAT
THIS WASN'T A QUESTION IN TERMS
OF THE CONSUMER PROTECTION. WAS
MAKE SURE THAT THE BANK
INTERCOM. WOULD DISCLOSE THEIR
PAYMENT BECAUSE WE CAN'T THE
STATE CALIFORNIA CAN'T TELL
BANKS HOW TO RESTRUCTURE THOSE
PAYMENTS. BUT OKAY SO WE
UNDERSTAND THOUGH THAT THE
BANKS. ARE GOING TO WANT TO GET
THEIR MONEY BACK RIGHT SO.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY HOW THEY WOULD
STRUCTURE THAT SORT OF IF
STATEMENTS ARE A FEDERALLY
BACKED LOAN AT THE MOMENT THEY
CANNOT DO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE CARES ACT SPECIFIES
OKAY SO NOW IF THEY'RE NON
FEDERALLY. BACKED LOAN WHICH WE
HAD MAYBE THIRTY PLUS
PERCENTAGE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT
FEDERALLY BANK WHAT WE'RE
ASKING THEM TO DO IS TO
DISCLOSE IT UP FRONT. WE'RE
BASICALLY PARALLELING THE
CARERS ACT WITH THESE BANKS
FEDERALLY BACKED YES FOR
FEDERALLY BACKED UP FOR STATE
BACKED LOANS WE CAN DO BETTER.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE FEDERAL JURISDICTION AND
WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO JUST TO
BE BETTER IT'S REALLY CHEST
GIVE CONSUMERS THAT ADVANCE
NOTICE. THE GONNA HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AND WE AS A STATE
BECAUSE OF OUR CONCERN ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION WILL ALSO
GIVE THEM NOTICE WOULD LIKE THE
FEDS TO DO IT TOO BUT WE KNOW
WE CAN'T ORDER THEM. SO FOR
THAT FOR THIS FOR THE STATE
BACKED LOANS THE STATE CAN SAY-
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK FOR
ALL THE MONEY UP FRONT OR YOU
MUST ASK FOR IT ALL AT FOR A
DIMINISHING DO ANYTHING WE WANT
CORRECT FOR THE STATE BACKED
LOANS. NOT NECESSARILY THE
STATE I MEAN THIS IS IT THIS IS
AN ASPECT WHERE NO STATE- THESE
ARE PRIVATELY BANKS BANK
MONTHLY WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
STATE BACKED LOANS- AND SO WE
CAN'T TELL THEM. HOW MUCH TO
CHARGE AND WHAT MONTHS BUT WE
CAN PUT A CONSUMER PROTECTION
IN SAYING THAT IF A LOT OF SUN
IS WHAT THEY'RE OFFERING THAT
NEEDS TO BE EXPLICITLY
DISCLOSED. TO THAT PROPERTY
OWNER- AND THEN THAT WAY THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE A DECISION
IF THE FORBEARANCE IS GOING TO
WORK FOR THEM OR NOT. BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE AS MUCH AS
WE CAN- THE CARES ACT. I COULD
TRY TO EXPLAIN THIS. CENTER
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY WHICH IS.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW FEDS HAVE
SAID. IF YOU HAVE A FEDERALLY
BACKED LOAN YOU GET UP TO A
YEAR FOR PARENTS THE INDUSTRY
KNOWS THAT AS A STANDARD. WHAT
THE BANKING INDUSTRY WILL TELL
YOU FOR NON FEDERALLY BACKED
LOANS IN CALIFORNIA. IS BAY
BELIEVE THEY CAN ROUGHLY MIMIC
WHAT IS BEING REQUIRED FOR
FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS. TO
ANOTHER IS TO FOR POTENTIALLY A
TWO YEAR. WHAT WE'RE SAYING
WITH THIS BILL AS WE WANT TO
GIVE HOMEOWNERS AND PROPERTY
OWNERS UP TO A YEAR. AND THAT
GIVES SOME BREATHING ROOM FOR
THE TENANT TO HAVE UP TO YEAR
TO PAY WE'RE TRYING TO. WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE A WATERFALL
EFFECT SO IT WORKS. NOW IT MAY
NOT WORK ENTIRELY CORRECT
TWELVE MONTHS OF NOT PAYING
RENT IT MIGHT TAKE SOME TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT TWELVE MONTHS OF
MORTGAGE GETS PAID BUT I THINK
IT WORKS AN AWFUL LOT BETTER
THAN DOING NOTHING BECAUSE IF
WE DO NOTHING IN TWO WEEKS THAT
LANDLORDS GOING TO HAVE TO
BRING EXPENSIVE ADDICTION
ACTION TO KICK OUT THE TENANT
AND YOU CAN ASK LANDLORDS IF
YOU EXPECT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR UNPAID RENT FROM THAT
OF FICTION. EVICTION ACTIONS
ARE USED TO GET YOUR PROPERTY
BACK TO KICK PEOPLE UP IN ST
BUT THEY'RE VERY INEFFECTIVE
ACTUALLY GETTING YOUR UNPAID
RENT SO IF WE A LOT OF ACTIONS
TO HELP INSURE YOU'LL KICK OUT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
TENANTS ON TO THE STREETS AND
ALL THAT THAT HAS AN IMPACT BUT
THOSE LANDLORDS WILL LIKELY NOT
BE ABLE TO GET A PORTION OF
THAT ON THE FRONT SO THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR MORTGAGE
ANYWAY ALL WE'RE SAYING IS GET.
TENANTS SOMETIME LET'S GIVE
PROPERTY OWNERS HOMEOWNERS AND
LANDLORDS SOMETIME SO THAT WE
GET WE HOPEFULLY THE PANDEMIC
SLOWS DOWN THE RECESSION ENDS
WE GET EVERYBODY BACK ON THEIR
FEET AND EVERYBODY'S MADE WHOLE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE. FOR
EVERYONE TO BE MADE WHOLE.
MARTIN IF I MAY ADD. IS THE-
PRESS HAS NOT. PAYMENT AT THE
END OF THE MORTGAGE SO IF YOU
WERE A HUNDRED AND EIGHT MONTHS
AND NOT THEN SO IF IT'S NOT OF
A FEDERALLY BUT IF YOU'RE
SAYING NO THEN YOU CLEARLY HAVE
SOME EXAMPLES BUT THE OVERALL
PRACTICES BAND THAT THEY ARE
ADDING IT SO INSTEAD OF A
HUNDRED EIGHT MONTHS LEFT
YOU'RE NOW AT A HUNDRED. AND
YOU KNOW TWENTY MONTHS LEFT I
DON'T THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING BUT THANK YOU.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN WE CALLED OUR BANK TO
INQUIRE ABOUT THIS AND THEY
SAID WE ARE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU A FORBEARANCE OF RIGHT KIND
AND THAT THEY SAID THREE FOUR
MONTHS WHATEVER. BUT YOU ARE
EXPECTED TO PAY THAT BACK IN
FULL. AT THE END OF THAT TERM.
SO HOW DOES THAT HELP SOMEONE
YEAH YOU DON'T HAVE A FEDERALLY
BACKED. MORTGAGE THAT WHAT THAT
IS SAID PRIVATE MORTGAGE RIGHT.
OKAY I'M USING THIS AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHEN WE WERE
ENQUIRING TWO ONE OF OUR LOCAL
BANKS SO. I DON'T. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS WORKING THE WAY
YOU THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO
WORK BUT LET ME MOVE ON BECAUSE
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO IT YET
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE OTHERS WHO
WANT US MAKING THANK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. SO THERE'S- A
SEVERABILITY CLAUSE IN THIS
BILL. BECAUSE WE TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THIS BILL.
SO IF THIS BILL OF THE PORTIONS
OF THE BILL RELATING TO THE
FORBEARANCE GET STRICKEN.
STRICKEN DOWN IN COURT. WHAT IS
STILL STANDING IS THE PART THAT
SAYS YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY
RENT. DURING THIS PANDEMIC SO
THEN WHAT HAPPENS. TO THE
PEOPLE WHO. HAVE TO PAY THE
MORTGAGE. WELL AGAIN OUR
ASSUMPTION IS THAT IT IS BEST
FOR EVERYONE TO NOT SEE A HUGE
GENERATION OF RENTERS KICKED
OUT ON THE STREETS BECAUSE IF
THAT HAPPENS THOSE ONES ARE NOT
GONNA GET PAID ON THOSE
MORTGAGES WILL NEVER HAVE A
SHOT AT GETTING PAID OFF THEIR-
MORTGAGE IS PAID BY LANDLORDS
NO I UNDERSTAND BUT I'M I'M-ASKING YOU SERIOUSLY HAVE YOU.
CONTEMPLATED ALL THE DIFFERENT
WAYS THIS COULD TURN OUT IF
THIS DOESN'T STANDING
QUARTERBACK PORTION OF THE BILL
DOESN'T STAND IN COURT THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T PAYING RENT BECAUSE WE
PUT A LOT OF PLACES YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY RENT. BUT THE
PROPERTY OWNER STILL HAS TO PAY
THE MORTGAGE BUT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE RENT SO THEN THEY
GO INTO FORECLOSURE SO THEN THE
RENTER IS. OUT OF A PLACE TO
STAY ANYWAY RIGHT PART OF OUR
QUICK CAN'T PART OF IT A QUICK
ANSWER TO YOU IS WE OBVIOUSLY
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME WITH
WHICH COUNCIL TO AFTER AS.
PLEASE OUR AND WE FOR STRONGLY
THAT WE HAVE GOOD ARGUMENTS ON
TO THESE THESE PROVISIONS WOULD
BE CONSTITUTION WOULD STAND IN
CORPORATE DURING THE TIME OF
AND PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ATTEMPT
FORM OF RELIEF OKAY THANK YOU
S. THANK YOU A THE QUESTIONS
AGAIN- THAT WERE IN BOARD WE'RE
UNCHARTERED WATERS. AND WE'RE
DOING THE BEST WE CAN AND I
AGREE I THINK THAT THE LANGUAGE
OF AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS YOU SEE THAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO. MAKE IT CLEAR THE
CRITERIA UNDER WHICH THESE.
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEING
PROMULGATED WE ARE IN A-
PANDEMIC WE ARE IN A CRISIS WE
ARE IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION.
AGAIN HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THE
BANKS IN THOSE BIG LENDERS A TO
TRY TO WORK WITH US AND- OF
FROM THE TENANT ON UP TO THE
HOMEOWNER- IT'S INTEREST SO- I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A WILL.
I KNOW THERE IS NO PERFECT
SOLUTION BUT- YOU KNOW THIS IS
ONE OF THE- AVENUES FOR TRYING
TO PURSUE WITH THAT WILL GO TO
OUR BANKRUPTCY EXPERT. FROM
SENATOR Y. CASKEY READY TO JUMP
OUT OF MY TO DO SO. SICKENING
AT THE STATE MATTER CHAIR THE A
FUNDAMENTAL TO BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND NOW AND THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE IS IN THE
EQUITY CUSHION THAT HOMEOWNERS
HAVE YOU KNOW BACK IN
200-082-0007 PEOPLE WERE UPSIDE
DOWN THEY HAD BOUGHT HOUSES FOR
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND AND THEY
WERE WORTH THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND RING IN WHITE AFTER
THE SHOWER SO TODAY PEOPLE HAVE
CUSHION HAVE EQUITY IN THE
BANKRUPTCY WORLD WE CALL THAT
IN EQUITY CUSHION AND THERE'S
NOT A COURT IN THE LAND THAT
DOES NOT GIVE DEFERENCE TO ADD
TO A BORROWER OR DEBTOR THAT
HAS AN EXTRA EQUITY CUSHION YOU
WITH GOING TO COURT. AND IT IS
GOING TO SAY I OWE TWO HUNDRED
OF FULL AND I'M NOT MAKING MY
BUT THERE'S EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
EQUITY THIS PROPERTY THE LAW-
OF HOPE FOR CORPORATE AND
THAT'S ONE THE THINGS THAT'S
SORT OF ON THE- OF WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE SO WITH THAT SAID I
YOU KNOW THIS CUSHION EXISTS
PEN. I WANTED INTO THE
PREEMPTION PROBLEM SPEAK. I
THINK THE THIS. FOR SCIENTIST
SAYS HIS GUITAR ABOUT SEVERAL
IS YOU SEE AT YOU KNOW THERE'S
A THERE'S THE MAGIC DATE WE
WON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR UNIT. ON
FOR THIRTY SO UNTIL APRIL. TWO
TWO THOUSAND. TWENTY ONE AND
THEN WE WERE WON'T KNOW WHAT
THE DC UNIVERSE IS ON THE P.
WHO THE- ON EITHER THE- RENT.
AGREEMENTS FOR THEIR MORE
AGREEMENTS APRIL SO. TWO TWENTY
TWO SO AS- MS COUPLE EUROS BILL
GOES AND WE'RE TO LESS PEOPLE
IN THIS UNIVERSE OF THE FAULT
OF FOLKS SO ON ONE OF THE
PREEMPTION. BROUGHT UP BY THE
SENATE BANKING HE SAID. BAKER
SECTOR SETS DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY YOU
GUYS SAID. MARCH THIRTY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IN MY
WORLD I'M THINKING THAT THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S A NICE THAT OCCUR
BECAUSE YOU GOT A GOOD CHUNK OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU WOULD BE
DEALING WITH. CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN. RIGHT SO ON THE
OVERALL PREEMPTION SIDE- I THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ACTUALLY
THAT THE A JOB OF LAYING OUT
SOME OF THE CAN. BUT SOME OF
THE PAST FOUR. AND THE WORST
THE ADDRESSING SOME OF THE PAST
FOUR AND WE- TO BE IN A WHERE
THIS IS THIS STANDS ANY TEST IN
COURT AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT I THINK THE ANALYSIS DOES
A GOOD JOB OF DISCUSSING- YOU
KNOW THE BAR AT THE ENSURING
THAT THE BARS RECEIVE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION WHICH I
THINK WAS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
ABOUT THE TERMS OF THE
FORBEARANCE- WE RELY ON THE
FORECLOSURE PROCESS. AND
SLIGHTLY YOU KNOW THE
FORECLOSURE PROCESS- IS THERE
TO ADD TO SOME THE CONSUMER.
BUT IT ALSO. THAT THERE IS
FRONT OF PRE EMPTION ON THE
ISSUE I WANT TO SAY THAT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IN THE
DISPATCH. ON THAT THE YOU KNOW
A MENTION OC RULES BULLETIN.
AND IN THE EAL IN BOTH
BULLETIN MAY ACCURATELY
REFLECTED THE REACH OF
PREEMPTION AS IT'S REFLECTED IN
EXISTING FEDERAL LAW PASSED BY
CONGRESS. BUT THE OCC DOES HAVE
A HISTORY. OF GOING BEYOND
CONGRESS AND INTO AND SO THE
DISEASE WELL BE MAPS. A TO THE
NINE CIRCUIT. DO THIS BUT I
ALSO AT. AGAIN WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS A- THAT THERE
IS DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER
THIS IS PRINTED OR NOT
SPECIFICALLY THE EXAMPLE THAT'S
BEEN GIVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS THAT IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE HOMEOWNER. AND IT'S
OUT THAT IT'S BEEN PART BECAUSE
UNDER EMERGENCIES. THE AUTHOR
OF THE OF THE BILL MENTIONED-
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS AND STATE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE ISSUES
FORWARD SO TAKING WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY DONE IN
TWENTY TWELVE. LOOKING AT A
PATHWAY THAT COULD TO PERHAPS
CHANGE SOME OF THIS- IN TERMS
OF PRE AND PREEMPTION WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT PATH. AND YOU COUPLE
THAT WITH WE TALK ABOUT THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES OUR GUIDANCE
THAT THEY HAVE AND WHAT OF
COURSE NATURALLY YOU THINK OKAY
WHAT REGULATIONS SET AT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IMPLEMENTED BUT YOU
HAVE. THE LANGUAGE OF THE CARE
ACT THE INDICATION THAT WE WANT
TO HAVE A FORBEARANCE FOR A
YEAR AND GIVE. HER A CHANCE TO
WORK OUT OF A PLANNED SO THAT'S
INDICIA THAT THEY THAT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE FOR THE NON
FEDERALLY BACKED BANKS YOU
AGREE WITH THAT WITH THAT I
MEAN I'M I'M TRYING TO PERIL
WHAT WITH IF YOU COULD GOING TO
COURT. TO MAKE THE CITY THIS IS
A WILL THAT. THAT'S THE CASE X.
TO THIS YEAR FOR PERRANCE.
MIMICKING A FOR THE NON
FEDERALLY BACKED BY. IF YOU GO
INTO WORK WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
YOU CARE AS A LINK I MEAN THAT
YOU KNOW ACT I GUESS I CAN'T
SAY THAT I'M NOT THE THAT WOULD
DO THAT BUT RIGHT I THINK THAT
THE WHAT YOU AT YOU AT THE FACT
THAT THE FED. GOVERNMENT HAS US
GUIDELINE. AND SO THESE ARE DOT
ON EMERGENCY IS ON FINISHED THE
OTHER. INTERREG ANTHONY HAS. BY
MEMBERS IS THAT THE EIGHT HAS
POTENTIAL YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THE DIFFERENCE DATE BE CARE ACT
BEAT THIRD FIRST AND THIS BILL
BEING MARCH THIRTY FIRST AT.
THE DATA THE PEACE THEY KEEP.
IT'S SEPARATED MAKE THAT
SEVERAL BOLD DECISION ON THAT
NOT PAGE FOURTEEN MADAM CHAIR.
OF THE ANALYSIS WE TALK ABOUT
THE NOTICE OF DEFAULT AND
ACTUALLY GIVING. DIRECTING THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S TO PUT IN A
DECLARATION FROM LOAN SERVICER
THAT THEY HAVE SAID THAT THE
BORROWER HAS NOT SOUGHT. IS
WERE WE ON DEBT THIS PAGE
THIRTEEN YOU MEAN AND A PAGE
THIRTEEN RIGHT YEAH AND THE
THIRD PAGE THIRTEEN GOALS IN
THE FOURTH PHOTO SO LET ME JUST
SAY AT ONCE BEFORE ARE ASSEMBLY
BANKING COMMITTEE CHAIR BUT WE
ARE VERY MUCH LOOKING AT THAT
POTENTIAL SUGGESTION IF THAT IS
GOING TO BE ON FROM ILLEGAL
FOURTEEN SO- JUST KNOW THAT
THAT IS IN PROCESS BUT JUST FOR
OTHERS WHO MIGHT BE A LITTLE
CONFUSED WHERE THIS
CONVERSATION'S GOING HERE'S THE
CHALLENGE FOR TRYING TO STATE
WHICH IS THE GOVERNMENT EARLIER
THIS YEAR SAID. FEDERALLY
BACKED MORTGAGES YES YOU GET
PARENTS THROUGH THE END OF
DECEMBER. AND OUR THE DECISION
THAT THEY DID NOT MAKE A RULING
ON NON FEDERALLY BACKED
MORTGAGES SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS WE
WANT TO CREATE SOME. BETWEEN
FEDERAL NOT. AND WE WANT TO DO
THAT THROUGH FOR ANOTHER EXTRA
THREE MONTHS AND SO THERE'S
THIS ISSUE OF THE DATE. AND HOW
TO DRIVE THIS NOW WHAT WE SEE
IN THIS BILL. IS WHEN IT COMES
TO FEDERALLY BACKED MORTGAGES
THE FEDERAL. REGULATORY
STRUCTURE OUGHT TO APPLY THAT'S
THE SAFE HARBOR ISSUE. BUT
THERE'S THIS OPEN QUESTION OF
WHAT HAPPENS FROM NON FEDERALLY
BACKED. DURING THIS EXTRA TIME
PERIOD AND WE'VE- MADE OUR BEST
ASSESSMENT THAT. WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THIS IS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT MAKING SURE WE
HAVE. A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD BUT
THE REALITY IS RIGHT NOW. THERE
IS NOT A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
BECAUSE FEDERALLY BACKED
MORTGAGES HAVE. THE FULL FAITH-AND CREDIT OF THE FENCE BEHIND
THEM. BUT THESE OTHERS DON'T SO
WE'RE LITERALLY JUST TRYING TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AS BEST
WE CAN. BUT TO GET TO STAR
WHITE HOUSE KEYS POINT. IN YOU
KNOW SIX WERE REFERS TO THE
FACT THAT. IF YOU RESTRUCTURE
THIS IN A WAY THAT NESTS THE
DEFERRED PAYMENT PROGRAM
WITHIN. THE NON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURE PROCESS IN MY PM
STRONG LEGAL FOOTING WE ARE
VERY SERIOUSLY CONCERNED THAT
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS. WITH THE BANKING
INDUSTRY DIRECTLY ABOUT THESE
THESE POINTS SO. STATE I'M I
MIGHT ALSO SUGGEST. THAT OF
HOPEFULLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO EXTEND-
IF THEY CAN GET BACK TOGETHER
AND- COME TO AGREEMENT ON
ANYTHING- TO EXTEND THE CARERS
ACT. OR AT LEAST SOME
PROVISIONS OF IT. SO THAT. IT
THEN WE WILL BE IN SYNC- BUT
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO ANTICIPATE
TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO EXCEPT TO SAY. HEY LOOK
FOLKS THIS IS PROBABLY A GOOD
IDEA TO. EXTENDED OUT FURTHER
AND THE STATE THEN WILL BE- IN
PARALLELS. SINK SYNCHRONIZATION
WITH THEM. I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR SOME REALLY ON. MY
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM FRESNO WAS
TALKING ABOUT CREDIT WORTHINESS
REPORTING IT TO THE CREDIT
AGENCIES WHEN YOU'RE IN FOR
PARENTS. CAN YOU CONTINUE TO DO-THE DEAL WHATEVER THE DEAL WAS
YOU KNOW THEY YOU PAY YOUR
REGULAR MORTGAGE AND YOU PAY.
SIX HUNDRED BUCKS EXTERNAL THAT
THERE'S NO REPORTING AT THAT
TIME IT WOULDN'T BE UNTIL THERE
WOULD. I GUESS WE'D SAY THE
SECOND THE FULL RIGHT TO THE
SECOND YOU. BREAK THE PROMISE
THAT YOU MAKE UNDER THE
FORBEARANCE AND THAT WOULD BE
THE SAME IN THE RENTERS THERE
HAS TO BE A SECOND. THOUGHT
FORBEARANCE HAS ITS OWN
CLASSIFICATION AND THAT'S NOT
GOING TO CHANGE- AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THE CASE IF
THERE IS A FORMAL AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE SERVICE THE
SERVICER AND- THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT WILL NOT CHANGE IT HAS ITS
OWN FOR PARENTS PROCESS IT'S
NOT CONSIDERED- IN THE SAME AN
EQUAL WAY AS- THE CREDIT
REPORTING THAT WE MIGHT BE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF RENT.
IS MANAGED THANK WHERE. PEOPLE
SHOULD REMIND THEMSELVES IS
THAT THIS FORBEARANCES THAT THE
LENDER IS FOR BEARING ABOUT
GOING INTO NON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURE STATE THEY THEY
CAN'T DO A NON JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURE ON 80% OF THE- OF
THE BAY. OF DEBT RIGHT NOW SO I
GUESS. JANUARY FIRST OR JANUARY
SECOND WHENEVER THAT THAT
OCCURS. IT'S OPEN SEASON FOR
PEOPLE TO GO TO GO WIN PROVIDED
THAT YOU'VE DEFAULTED ON THE
FORBEARANCE AGREEMENT WHATEVER
THAT THAT MAY BE AND THAT. THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THE PEOPLE HAVE
IS THAT EVEN IF THE STARTED OF
THE NON JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE
YOU HAVE NINETY DAYS TO
OFFICIALLY. ENTER IN YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT THAT A
DECLARATION BY THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S IN THERE AND THEN
THERE'S A TWENTY DAY PERIOD
JUST TO SETTLE SO NOBODY'S
LOSING THEIR HOUSE. THAT ARE
FEDERALLY GUARANTEED LOAN.
BEFORE MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THE ON THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO AT LEAST MINE ALICE'S
AND I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THE
MATTER WHAT THE BIG BANKS SAY.
THEY CAN'T MOVE THAT FAST AND
THEY DON'T WANT TO MOVED AFTER
A SETTLEMENT THEY WANT HAVE
POST CHRISTMAS. DECORATIONS AT
THEIR JUST FOR CLOSING ON ON
EVERYBODY'S. I'M DONE I'M DONE
DONE I THINK IT'S- THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO SAY ME WELL. IS A
RESPONSE TO THE SAID I WOULD
JUST FROM EVERY THAT A FOR
CREDIT REPORTING IS NOT
DELINQUENT. IT THEIR SEPARATE
THINGS THESE ARE NOT DELINQUENT
AND SO THEY DON'T COUNT IN A IN
THAT TYPE OF WAY AND I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY ADS WERE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
ROLE OF FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS-
THIS BILL INDEPENDENT OF THIS
BILL. THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT PAY THEIR MORTGAGE OR
RENT SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS WE'RE TRYING TO HELP. THIS
BILL WHAT IF THIS BILL DOESN'T
EXIST THE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE STILL BEARING
UP BEARING A BURDEN BECAUSE
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT CANNOT
PAY THEIRMORTGAGE SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO GIVE
THEM MORE TIME. NO MAN MADAM
CHAIR IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WANT TO GIVE. THE BORROWER AS
MUCH TIME AS THEY HAVE I MEAN
IN THE WORLD OF BANKRUPTCY
SOMETIMES YOU FAR YOU FILE AND
YOU HE TRIED TO WORK OUT A PLAN
YOU TRY TO DO IT. AND YOU MAY
BE IN THEIR ONE YEAR EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND ALL THAT. AND THEN
IT FINALLY REALIZES I CAN'T
AFFORD THAT THIS HOUSE I HAVE
TO SELL THE HOUSE BUT YOU GET
SOME PROTECTION. FROM JUST
FLAT. WITH EVERYTHING AND AGAIN
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
BOILING POTS HERE AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT. THAT THINGS LOOK
REALLY BAD RIGHT NOW BUT MAYBE
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THEY'RE BACK ON THEIR FEET AND
WE REALLY WANT THEM TO BE IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY CAN.
NEGOTIATE THAT SO. I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S ATTENTION TO THE
DETAILS OF THIS BILL. WE
THOUGHT YOU WOULD ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WILL GO TO A SENATOR
STERN WHO IS PATIENTLY WAITING.
TO GIVE US HIS THOUGHTS IN
ASKING A QUESTION SO WE'VE GOT
TO THEIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
UP YOU ARE UP OKAY YOU CAN
SHARE IN THE- RESHAPED. THE
DEBATE- ESPECIALLY THE RANGERS
AS MONEY RECEIVED IT IT
UNDERSCORE IT. THAT GRAVITY
PRICES BECAUSE I'M IT WAS JUST
A BIT AGO THAT. THE BILL
DOESN'T DO IT. I KNOW IT'S
SHOCKING IS IT. EXTENDED TALK.
UNPRECEDENTED NATURE LET'S JUST
SAY OF PURSUING THIS KIND OF
REMEDY FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE NO
OTHER RECOURSE BUT HEY I THINK
THAT- IF I HAVE ANY CONCERN
HERE- IT IS IN OUR LIMITS OF
STATE LAW. AND THAT WE DO HAVE
TO TAKE A CHANCE AND DO WE HAVE
TO. SORT OF MAKE A BET HERE
THAT EVENTUALLY- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA STEP IN AND
REALLY FIND A WAY TO. MEET
TENANTS HOMEOWNERS LENDERS
LANDLORDS THE WHOLE RANGE OF
FOLKS AND MOVE THE KIND OF
CAPITAL WERE NEED WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO BELIEVE THE MARKETS I
THINK THE RESERVISTS BEEN DOING
THEIR PART BUT I THINK CONGRESS
HAS GOT ACT I JUST- I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO DO IN THE EVOLVING NATURE
THIS PROPOSAL. I DO HOPE THAT-
GIVEN A COMPRESSED TIMELINE ON
WHAT THIS NEGOTIATION HAS TO BE
IN ORDER TO GET THINGS DONE-
BEFORE OUR EVICTION DEADLINE
HITS THAT YOU WILL- CONTINUE TO
KEEP THIS COMMITTEE A PRIZE I
HAVE A LOT OF TRUST IN OUR
CHAIR AND- THE STAFF HERE BUT I
KNOW THAT- THIS IS GOING TO GO
FAST. SO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
WHAT THE SORT OF KEY MOVING
PIECES ARE GOING TO BE IN MY
SENSE IS THAT THE- D. THE
LENDING COMMUNITY AND- AND THE
LANDLORDS ARE BOTH- WILLING TO
COME TO THE TABLE I MEAN I'VE
HEARD. REPEATEDLY CALLS FOR TAX
CREDITS OR SOME KIND OF TAX
WRITE OFF OPTION- FOR THOSE WHO
ARE NOT ABLE TO FULFILL THE
TERMS OF THEIR MORTGAGE- AND BE
ABLE TO WRITE THAT OFF AS AN
EXPENSE OR FIND SOME OTHER
RECOURSE I THINK THAT'S A
REASONABLE OPTION TO HAVE ON
THE TABLE AND I HOPE THAT THAT-
IS THOUGHT OF IN IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE CONTEMPLATION OF THIS
TENET. RELIEF FRAMEWORK I THINK
THEY'RE BOTH NECESSARY. I WOULD
ALSO JUST ADD THOUGH THAT- NOT
OLD BANKS ARE CREATED THE SAME.
AND I EAT I DO WONDER IF YOU
ALL GIVEN THOUGHT TO- THE
COMMUNITY BANKS AND SOME OF OUR
LOCAL CREDIT UNIONS WHO. MAY
BE- WITHIN THEIR PORTFOLIO HAVE
A- A LARGER RANGE OF THE KIND
OF. LOANS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE THAT. THAT MACY GOOD
DAY KIND OF FORBEARANCE- THAT'S
ALLOWED BY THIS LEGISLATION
REALLY WHAT WE DO IN THOSE
THOSECASES- WE DON'T. WE KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
OPERATING MODEL AND CERTAINLY
DIFFERENT PROFIT MODELS- AND
ONE THAT'S MEMBER DRIVEN ON THE
STUDY SHAREHOLDER DRIVEN SO. WE
KNOW IT'S SORT OF A DIFFERENT
SET OF MOTIVES. CAN YOU CAN
EITHER I'M NOT SURE WHICH OF
THE AUTHORS ARE BETTER.
SITUATED AND- WHICHEVER GIVE IT
GIVE US SOME INSIGHT ON THAT
ISSUE BUT I WAS HOPING YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT. THAT UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENT. HELLO START ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION SO. AS WE WERE
CONTEMPLATING ADDING MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE PROVISIONS- ONE OF
THE FIRST. STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE
REACH OUT TO WHERE THE CREDIT
UNIONS ARE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AND WE'VE HAD. AS ON PAGE
SIXTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS-
DESCRIBES THE AUTHOR'S REPORT.
A HEALTHY BACK AND FORTH WITH
THE CREDIT UNIONS OVER A
POSSIBLE EXEMPTION FOR THE
BILL- AND IT LAYS OUT A COUPLE
THE OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
WRESTLER WITH. ONE OPTION WOULD
BE TO MIMIC THE CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS. BUT
THIS EXEMPTION MIGHT SWEEP TOO
BROADLY LEAVING MANY HOMEOWNERS
AND LANDLORDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
FORBEARANCE. ANOTHER OPTION
THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED IS. TO
POTENTIALLY- CONSIDER AN
EXEMPTION BASED ON INSTITUTIONS
SIZE SO. THIS LITERALLY LAYS
OUT- THAT WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT I WOULD
SAY S- I'M VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THIS. TO COMPLETELY IN
A GOOD PLACE TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS. I THINK SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF VERY MUCH RESPECT THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT. CREDIT
UNIONS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED NO. LENDER PROVIDE AND WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT. THAT
SO- SO VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION AND
I. AM HOPEFUL THAT BY THE TIME
THIS GETS THE SENATE FLOOR-
HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE ARRIVED
AT AT AT AT AT A BETTER SPOT IN
THAT. AND I CAN'T KISS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEóN. AND I WILL ADD IT
YOU KNOW THAT I CONCUR WITH THE
AUTHOR I THINK IT'S ALSO ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE'RE STILL
HAVING THE DISCUSSION ABOUT
CREDIT UNIONS ON AND CERTAINLY
THERE'S A LIST OF. FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT. ARE ASKING
TO BE LOOKED AT DIFFERENTLY- IS
ALSO BECAUSE THE MOST RECENT
REPORTS FROM THE PARK
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. SHOW THAT CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNIONS HAVE VERY
ADEQUATE CAPITAL LEVELS. AND
EVEN AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR THE
EXPECTED LOSSES RECORDED BY THE
CREDIT UNIONS IN THE SECOND
QUARTER. THE AVERAGE CAPITAL
LEVEL FOR CRACK CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNIONS REMAINS ABOVE 11%
WHICH- EXCEEDS. THE 7%
THRESHOLD FOR REGULATORS TO
DEEM. I CREDIT UNIONS AS WELL
THE LIGHT. SO I THINK WE ARE TO
IGNORE. THAT THERE'S STILL A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS-
BECAUSE THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATION- IS SUCH THAT THESE
THAT THEY OUT THEY STILL HAVE
BARS. AND WE WANT TO KNOW HOW
WE CAN HELP THE BARS THAT HAVE.
AT A CREDIT UNION- LOAN
MORTGAGE AND SO WE ARE
COMMITTED TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BEST. SOLVE THIS- AND
ALSO THERE'S DEFINITELY A LOT
OF INTEREST I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THERE'S LEGISLATORS
CARE. A LOT ABOUT THE WORLD OF
CREDIT UNIONS AND COMMUNITY
BANKS- BUT WE ALSO WANT TO LOOK
AT THE DATA AND FACTS TO. HELP
INFORM US ON HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT DO HAVE. AGES UNDER THOSE
AT FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. I
THINK THAT'S VERY WISE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID. YOU TRY TO
BE EVIDENCE DRIVEN AND ENGAGE
D. B. O. FRANKLY AS MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN IN THIS PROCESS
AND- WHAT THE DATA FOR. DRIVE
YOU ON THE STATE OF BOTH
CAPITAL MARKETS IS OF OUR OUR-
AT THE CAN BE MADE. ASSEMBLY
THIS COULD PASS QUITE YEAH
DEVIN SORT OF THE- THAT'S THE
BIG RED LINE BUT THAT'S
ENLIGHTENING THOSE NUMBERS-
OKAY. WELL YOU KNOW LISTEN IT.
WE'RE IN A SPOT HERE I THINK.
WE GOT A PERSON THIS OPTION
RIGHT NOW. I WISH WE WERE IN
THIS. AND WE ACTUALLY HAD TO
SAY ADEQUATE CAPITAL GOING TO
THOSE FOR PANDEMIC RELIEF AND
HAVE A STEADY FLOW SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO.
PURSUE THESE OTHER REMEDY BUT
GIVEN THE ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCE
THE PEOPLE ARE AND I DON'T
THINK WE CAN. AFFORD TO BREAK
FAMILIES AND BREAK THIS WHOLE
ECONOMIES ALL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY AND- REALLY THANK
YOU GUYS FOR. JUST BEING
GENERATED WITH US AND REALLY
DETAIL ORIENTED THIS IS A VERY
VERY TOUGH. CLAIM TO LAND IN A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME WITH A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRECISION
SO- COUNT ON ALL OF US TO BE
HELPING YOU OUT AND- TRY TO
FIGURE OUT SOME SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU TO BOTH AUTHORS AND OTHERS
HAS BEEN A VERY- GREAT LONG
DISCUSSION BUT IT'S THIS IS A
REALLY AWESOME AND MEASURED
ASAL I BELIEVE- THAT PROVIDES
OPTIONS ALL AROUND THE ECONOMIC
CYCLE I KNOW WE'VE OFTEN
HISTORICALLY TALKED ABOUT
TENANTS BUT INCORPORATING OUR
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS IN THE
MIX I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
GOOD PLACE TO BE- ALL OF MY
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED
BUT I WILL SAY NO. ACCESS TO
CAPITAL SIMILAR TO IT CENTER
MINING SAID DOESN'T AFFECT SOME
OF US. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WE'VE SEEN HAS
PROPROVIDED THAT CAPITAL TO
MANY OF OUR LARGE BANKS MANY OF
OUR LARGER COMPANIES ESPECIALLY
IN THE SMALL BUSINESS FROM THE
PPP LOANS. THEY'VE HAD ACCESS
AND THAT'S STILL FLOWING- WHAT
I DO- SIMILAR TO WHAT HE'D
MENTION AS WELL THOUGH AS I DO-
ALSO HAVE A CONCERN EVERY
PAYMENT AFTERWARDS BUT I SAID I
KNOW THAT-THIS WILL BE AN
EVOLVING DISCUSSION AND THIS IS
NOT GONNA STOP EVEN AFTER. THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATE. AND SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH
AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT ALL
OF OUR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE SOME REPRIEVE DURING THIS
TIME. VERY DIFFICULT TIME SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND A CENTER-
BURKE I BELIEVE YOU HAD SOME
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CHU IN THE MONTH OF FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS AS I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A SOMETHING
YOU'RE CONTINUE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS POINT. RIGHT EVERY
MINUTE OF EVERY HOUR OF EVERY
DAY FOR MANY MANY DAYS AND THIS
BILL. HAS BEEN AMENDED I THINK
AT LEAST SEVEN TIMES ALREADY-
CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARD I THINK
THE CONSENSUS SET THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR BUT TO. IN FACT
THAT AS SOON AS WE FINISH HERE
THE TWO OF US ARE GOING TO GET
INTO ANOTHER ROUND OF
YOU- I APPRECIATE DIRECTOR
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE BEEN.
HURT IN THIS PANDEMIC HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
COMPLETELY INNOCENT I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT TO WORK
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF THE LAW.
BUT PRACTICALITY IT AND
POLITICAL REALITIES HERE TO BE
ABLE TO SPREAD THE RISK- SADLY
THE RISK CAN'T BE SPREAD AS FAR
AS IT SHOULD BE SPREAD. OF THAT
YEAR. APPORTIONING THAT RISKS
TO CERTAIN INSTITUTIONS THAT
YOU BELIEVE CAN BEAR THE RISK
BETTER THAN OTHERS AT LEAST
THAT'S HOW I VIEW WHAT WHAT
YOUR OBJECT IS. I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FACT YOU'RE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE IT
MORE EQUITABLE- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE FINAL
PRODUCT HERE BELIEVES CAN MOVE
OUT OF COMMITTEE ELSE LOOK FOR
TO SEE THE FINAL PRODUCT THANK
YOU. THE BILL. YES OUR CENTER
MELENDEZ AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE
IT UP SO THAT WE CAN GET ON TO
OUR NEXT ITEM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST CAN YOU EXPLAIN
WHAT'S THE RECOURSE FOR- THE
PROPERTY OWNER IF- YOU IF THE
TENANT. DID DOESN'T PAY THE
RENT LIKE I SAY AT THE END OF
THE- OF THE DAY DISCLOSE TIME
PERIOD OKAY NOW I NEED START
AND THE RUNNER JUST SAYS I'M
NOT PAYING IT OR THEY MOVE OUT
AND GO SOMEWHERE ELSE. WHAT IS
THE RECOURSE FOR THE PROPERTY
ON THE RECOURSE WOULD BE
TYPICAL CIVIL ACTION. SO YOU
COULD GO AFTER THE TENNESSEE
WOULD FOR ANY CONSUMER DEBT. AS
LONG OKAY AS LONG AS IT'S
BEYOND TO THE- AS LONG AS
BEYOND THE DATES THAT WE HAVE
SET IN THIS WHICH BY THE WAY
TO- CENTER ON BREAKS POINT ARE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE UNDER
DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS O WHAT ARE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAMES FOR
WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING. OKAY
THANK YOU. GREAT WHITE WE HAVE
A MOTION- THE MOTION IS. IT IS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. OF WERE
WE GOING WITH THIS TO PASS THE
SENATE RULES- SENATE RULES THAT
IT IS THE MOTION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TOO AND RIGHTLY AND THEN
LIKE I THINK I'M PROBABLY IN A
MUCH BETTER PLACE THAN YOU ARE
LIN'AN. I IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. CAN WE TRY TO KEEP THIS
DISCUSSION SORT OF FOCUS NOW ON
THE CLOTHES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRED THANK YOU SENATORS
FOR THE VERY ENGAGING
CONVERSATION TODAY THIS IS
CLEARLY NOT AN EASY ISSUE AND
THAT STATES DON'T HAVE ALL OF
THE TOOLS THAT ARE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE. TO INJECT
FUNDING INTO THE HOUSING MARKET
THAT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT I TALKED ABOUT THAT
WE WOULD ALL LOVE TO BE THERE-
AND ALL OF TO CONSIDER THAT
PROPOSAL BUT THAT'S NOT A
REALITY THAT'S IT'S NOT A
REALISTIC PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF
US BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
DISPLACING PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HOMES IS NOT ONLY DISRUPTING.
TO THOSE SPECIFIC FAMILIES BUT
IT'S ALSO COSTLY AND DISRUPTIVE
TO ALL OF OUR SOCIETY
PARTICULARLY IN THE TIME OF THE
HEALTH PANDEMIC I HOPE THAT WE
CAN BASS THIS BILL TODAY AND WE
ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO TRY TO
TAILOR THE SOLUTION TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED OUR HELP WHETHER THIS BILL
EXIST OR NOT BIG ISSUE REMAINS.
AND I THINK IT IS UP TO US TO
TRY TO IDENTIFY HOW TO BEST
HELP MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND THAT INCLUDES TENANTS
LANDLORDS HOMEOWNERS THE BILL
DOESN'T SOLVE EVERY SINGLE
ISSUE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS OR THAT TENANT
LANDLORDS AND HOMEOWNERS HAVE
BUT IT DOES GIVE. OUR
CALIFORNIANS AT LEAST AN OPTION
THAT THEY COULD PURSUE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
ABOUT THE- THANK YOU IN ASSURE
MEMBER CHIU SAID ALL GIVES UP
AS YOUR CLOTHES HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW COME IF I
CAN JUST A FEW PRINCELY FIRST
TO START BY THANKING. THE
COMMITTEE I AND ALSO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- THIS- IN MY SIX
YEAR THIS IS THE LONGEST HERE
AND I'VE HAD ON A BILL. AND IT
IS REFLECTIVE OF WHAT IS AT
STAKE AND I JUST APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND
PARTICIPATION. AND TO THE
PUBLIC- KNOW THAT EVERY MEMBER
OF THIS LEGISLATURE APPRECIATES
AND FEELS INCREDIBLE. PERSONAL
AND HUMAN CHALLENGES THAT
EVERYONE IS FACING A LONG THIS
CONVERSATION FROM TENANTS. TO
LANDLORDS TO PROPERTY OWNERS TO
THE FINANCING. UP AS- FOR THE
ONGOING COVER BUT IT'S A
CONVERSATION WE NEED TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD. AND I WOULD ASK
YOUR SUPPORT KNOWING THAT THERE
WILL. VERY LIKELY BE CONTINUE
CHANGES AS WE MOVE TO THE
FLOOR- BUT- THIS CRISIS
DISCOVERED CRISIS IS GOING TO
BE A DEFINING MOMENT. IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY IN OUR
LIFETIMES. AND WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN AN INCREDIBLE LOSS OF
HUMAN LIFE AND ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION. WE HAVE ONLY TWO
WEEKS TO ENACT POLICIES TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS WHETHER. THIS
EMERGENCY AS WAS ALLUDED TO
BEFORE DOING NOTHING IS NOT AN
OPTION. IF WE DO NOTHING WE
LEAVE MIL OF CALIFORNIANS. AT
THE MERCY OF FORCES BEYOND
THEIR CONTROL. AND THERE IS NO
REDO ON THIS IF WE DON'T ACT IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS THERE WILL
BE. POTENTIALLY CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES AND THIS IS
FRANKLY OUR LAST CHANCE. TO
TAKE ACTION TO STOP A MASSIVE
WAVE OF THE AND FOR AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY I YOUR BOTH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS AND IF AT THIS POINT WE
COULD ASK. MADAM CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE RULES. SENATORS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON
THE MOTION THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU. THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. JACKSON
ACTION AYE JACKSON AYE BORJAS.
THE RUSSELL I DID US SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ.
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE STERN.
THIRTY NINE STERN I BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI BY BYE CASKEY I
THAT. FIVE SIX ZERO SIX THE SIX
ZERO WITH THREE ABSTENTIONS OF
THE MEASURE PASSES TO SENATE
RULES THANK YOU SENATORS
ALREADY AND NOW WE ARE. IT WAS
AT FIVE AND A HALF SIX HOURS I
HOPE THIS ONE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI DOESN'T GO
QUITE THAT LONG. I UPPER ONE
IT'S ITEM NUMBER ONE ON OUR
CALENDAR. CHAU THERE. YOU KNOW
I'M TOLD THAT IT'S THE CHAIR
WHO HAS TO TAKE CARE DINNER SO.
WILLOW WILL ORDER A PIZZA IS IN
A FEW HOURS- ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK. ALL RIGHT THERE
YOU GO YOU HEARD IT YOU HEARD
IT FROM THE AUTHOR. OKAY. SO
ALL RIGHT. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO LET'S TAKE A
FIVE MINUTES TO STRETCH YOUR
LEGS WILL COME BACK AND TO GET
STARTED ON FILE ITEM ONE.
TO
WORK. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
THE JUDICIARY IS NOW BACK IN
SESSION OR I SHOULD SAY WE WILL
BEGIN IN SIXTY SECONDS SO THAT
WE CAN GET EVERYBODY LINED UP-
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF WHERE WE
ARE. WE ARE NOW AT FILE ITEM
ONE. AND WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
THE BILLS NOW IN ORDER SO WE
WILL BE HEARING FILE ITEM ONE
FILE ITEM THREE AND THEN ENDING
WITH FILE ITEM EIGHT I THINK WE
WILL BE HERE FOR A WHILE THESE
ARE ALL VERY INTERESTING. AND
SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED BILLS
ALTHOUGH I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THIS ONE IS NOT AS
COMPLICATED AS THE LAST ONE BUT
AN INTERESTING ONE NONE THE
LESS SO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WILL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECONDS SO THAT WE CAN GET. THE
PUBLIC BACK IN THE QUEUE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MORE RESEARCH. AND IF YOU WOULD.
GIVE US I THINK PROBABLY
ANOTHER TEN SECONDS WE WILL GET
STARTED AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I'M NOT SURE
ANY OF US EXPECTED THAT THAT
LAST BILL WOULD GO QUITE AS
LONG AS HE DID- BUT- IT WAS AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING ANOTHER
INTERESTING IMPORTANT BILL TO
US AS WELL. SINCE WERE. DOING A
LITTLE OPTION HERE FOR TIMING
I'M GOING TO REMIND PEOPLE OF
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
964-844-2916 THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX THREE
TWO EIGHT SIX EIGHT SIX ACCESS
CODE. SIX THREE TWO EIGHT SIX
EIGHT SIX AND WITH THAT I
THINK- WE'RE ALL SET TO GO
AHEAD ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS FILE ITEM ONE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I BELIEVE THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT BE AS
CONTROVERSIAL AS A YEAR MORNING
BILL- THIS IS AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX WHICH IS A BILL ABOUT
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES ALSO
KNOWN AS THE E. SCOOTERS AND E.
BIKES. THE GOALS OF THIS BILL
ARE LIKE SAFETY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. THIS BILL IS CO
SPONSORED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA PROP AND SUPPORTED
BY A WIDE RANGE OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE A.
R. P. DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND. IN
RECENT YEARS MANY CITIES IN OUR
STATE HAVE SEEN A BONE AN E.
SCOOTER AND E. BIKE USE ON OUR
STREETS AND SIDEWALKS SOMETIMES
APPEARING OVERNIGHT. WITHOUT
ANY PRIOR NOTICE TO LOCAL
AUTHORITIES. PISI SCOOTERS AND
E. BIKES CAN BE FUN AFFORDABLE
AND ECO FRIENDLY WAYS TO GET
AROUND. BUT WITH ANY NEW
INNOVATIVE PRODUCT OR SERVICE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
SAFE FOR BOTH THE USERS AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. WITH BASIC
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR YOU.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE FOR
THINGS NUMBER ONE. SHARED
MOBILITY SERVICE PROVIDERS LIKE
BURDEN LINE MUST ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH OR OBTAIN A
PERMIT FROM THE CITY BEFORE
THEY OPERATE IN A CITY. NUMBER
TWO THE PROVIDERS MUST PROVIDE
MINIMUM LEVELS OF LIABILITY
INSURANCE. NUMBER THREE
PROVIDERS WOULD BE PROHIBITED
FROM USING BOILERPLATE WAIVER
OF LIABILITY LANGUAGE AND THEIR
USER AGREEMENTS. AND FOR CITIES
MUST ADOPT LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
RULES ON THE OPERATION PARKING
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE DEVICES
BEFORE ENTERING INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH OR ISSUING A
PERMIT TO A SHARED MOBILITY
PROVIDER. WITH ME HERE TODAY
SUPPORT THAT HERE WITH ME IN
THE ROOM BUT- I AM VIRTUALLY IS
CHRIS DOLAN. SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND DEREK DOLPHY-
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
THANK YOU AND A REMINDER WE
WILL PROVIDE WITNESSES- THE
JUDGE IS A MAIN WITNESSES WILL
HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES TO
BE DIVIDED UP AS THEY CHOOSE-
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE AFTER- BUT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO START I BELIEVE
YOU INDICATED- CHRIS NOLAN AND
ERIC DOLPHY- NEITHER OF WHOM
ARE. APPEAR TO BE HERE. ARE
THEY THEY'RE ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD AND LET'S START
WITH. ALL RIGHT LET'S START
WITH CRYSTALLINE CRESCENDO FOR
MINUTES TOTAL AND- GO AHEAD THE
CLOCK IS RUNNING. THANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE ON THIS
COMMITTEE. THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE AS WE SAW
WITH. UBER LIFT IN TNCS THEY
WERE DROPPED ON OUR CITIES
WITHOUT ANY THOUGHT PLANNING OR
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS. THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IS FULLY
BEHIND THE IDEA OF REDUCING.
CARBON EMISSIONS CONGESTION AND
PROVIDING MORE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS INCLUDING THE LAST MILE
OPTIONS. WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOWEVER IS MAKING SURE
THAT IT IS SAFE FOR THE
CONSUMERS TABLE IN OTHERS IT.
WILL I WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE REPORTS INCLUDING FROM THE
JOURNAL OF AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. AND FROM OTHER
EMERGENCY ROOM GROUPS AND THIS
THING CALLED THE CDC THERE
INDICATING THAT THE SEVERITY OF
THE INJURIES WITH THESE
PARTICULAR MOBILITY DEVICES.
ARE EXTREME WITH OVER HALF OF
THEM RESULTING IN SIGNIFICANT
BRAIN TRAUMA SO WHAT WHAT THIS
BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO IS TO
ALLOW ENTRY AND REMOTE ENTRY
FOR SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES BY
REQUIRING THE CITIES TO DEVELOP
PLANS AND PROGRAMS. SO THAT
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THIS THE BILL ALSO HOWEVER
REQUIRES FIFTY PROVIDERS AS WE
DID WITH UBER AND LEFT WITH.
ANITA BACK IN TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE AND TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TAKE KERRY INSURANCE THESE ARE
NOT SUPPORTING- VEHICLES THIS
IS NOT A SPORT IT'S
TRANSPORTATION LIKE THE RENTAL
CAR. IN THESE ARE ITEMS THAT
ARE BEING BACKED BY UBER AND
LEFT IN SOME OF THE LARGEST
COMPANIES OUT THERE SO THEY
NEED TO MAINTAIN INSURANCE SO
IF THEIR DEVICE NOT IF THE
WRITER DOES SOMETHING WRONG.
BUT IF THEIR DEVICE FAILS THEN
THERE IS- COVERAGE TO PROVIDE
FOR THE INJURED PERSON SO THEY
DON'T WIND UP DESTITUTE AND ARE
ON THE. THE CITY'S DAHLE. SO DO
YOU DIVIDE ARE ARE FAIR. IN
SUCH WAY BREAK STATE. WITH THE
HANDLEBAR COMING OFF IT PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING FROM SEVERE
INJURY. EVERYTHING I'M GONNA
FACTORING THESE DEVICES AS WELL
AND THEY HAVE THESE ONEROUS
RELEASING WAIVERS THAT RELEASED
HIM FROM ALL LIABILITY
INCLUDING LIABILITY FOR THE
VEHICLE THAT THEY MAIN THEY
THEMSELVES MAY CONSTRUCT OR
SOMEONE ELSE MANUFACTURES
CHRISTIAN REDUCE TANGLING WITH
YOU NO RECOURSE CHRIS YOU'VE
TAKEN TWO AND A HALF MINUTES
LEAVING. A DIRECT ALL FEET A
MINUTE AND A HALF AT YOUR CALL
BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
ARMY THEY'RE NOT I WILL
CONCLUDE. I WILL CONCLUDE BY
REQUESTING THAT YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER DOLPHY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR JACKSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEECH YOU
TODAY ON AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX.
I'M AT SOME WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI HAS INDICATED
UNIVERSITIES EXPERIENCE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES PRACTICALLY
OVERNIGHT WITHOUT PRIOR
CONSULTATION. THIS IS FORCE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO RUSH TO
ESTABLISH THEIR OWN REGULATIONS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS REGARDING
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT AN ACTUAL
DISTRIBUTION SERVICES AND
PUBLIC RESOURCES. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX TAKES AN IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE DEVICE
PROVIDERS CHAPEL PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FROM CITIES-
WHERE THEY WISH TO OPERATE
BEFORE DEPLOYING THEIR DEVICES.
IT'S INCLUDES REQUIRING SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE PROVIDERS TO
COMPLY WITH ALL LOCAL OPERATION
PARKING MAINTENANCE AND SAFETY
RULES. TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT PREEMPT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I'M OR RESTRICT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM DECIDING
FOR THEMSELVES IF AND HOW THESE
DEVICES SHOULD OPERATE IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX ALSO INCLUDE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL
GIVEN THE PREVAILING TO BE
DEVICES ON CALIFORNIA'S
SIDEWALKS AND STREETS. DELETED
CALIFORNIA CITIES CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE SAFE RESPONSIBLE
DEPLOYMENT OF YOUR MOBILE
DEVICE PROVIDERS- AND THEIR
DEVICES THAT ENCOURAGE
ALTERNATIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. BUT WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC SERVICE
WE BELIEVE THIS. BILL DOES.
BACK THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I LIKE TO RE.
PLEASE TRY WOULD. TO STAY ON
THE MUTE. ELEMENT UNLESS YOU
ARE SPEAKING. SO WITH THAT.
LET'S GO TO GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT WILL. BE
LIMITED TO PEOPLE INDICATING
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
AT THIS POINT IN TIME WE ARE
SEEKING ONLY SUPPORT IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WAIT. DO NOT
KEEP DIALING JUST ONE TIME ONE.
ZERO AND WAIT AND WITH THAT
LET'S CHECK AND SEE DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
COULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THIS BILL. SHE NOBODY LETS
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. THERE IS
NOBODY INROOM ONE TWELVE. A SO
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
PHONES. OUR MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO HI WE GO TO WIND.
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN THAT'S TWO
ZERO SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. ONE
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN. YES
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN I WANTED TO- BOTTLE OR
EXPRESS MY- SOLIDARITY WITH A
DIFFERENT BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALL RIGHT NEXT TO A-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU INDICATE
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
QUEUE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
MUSIC TO OUR EARS OKAY WE HAVE
A COUPLE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT PERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON. NO I NUMBER TWO
ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT'S TWO ZERO
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GO TO TWENTY SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES
ON THE LINE WISHING TO INDICATE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. AND
WE HAVE NO MORE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S WAIT
ONE MORE MINUTE FOR ANYONE ELSE
WHO MIGHT BE IN THE QUEUE TO
GIVE THEIR SUPPORT. ON AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES. MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. WE HAVE NO WAY OF
SECURITIES TIME THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- I BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE TWO WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THEY ARE
ED FEW FROM BIRD AND JUSTIN
HIGHER FROM THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP- IS THAT
CORRECT MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
THESE TWO PEOPLE LINED UP TO BE
THE MAIN WITNESSES. YES WE DO
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT WITNESSES
THEN IN OPPOSITION WILL START
WITH MR. IS IT PRONOUNCED FEW
MISTER FEW FROM BIRD.
REMEMBERING FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
THIS. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR MY NAME IS- AT WORK FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I
AM SENT SENIOR COUNSEL FOR BIRD
BUT TODAY I'M ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SHARED MICHAEL
ABILITY INDUSTRY MORE BROADLY
IN OUR THREE YEARS IN EXISTENCE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A PLACE TENS
OF MILLIONS OF CAR TRIPS WITH
TRIPS ON OUR BIKES AND SCOOTERS
YOU KNOW TWO YEARS WE HAVE
WORKED HARD WITH HIS
LEGISLATURE ENTITIES TO PLACE
EVEN MORE AND TO DO SO SAFELY
ASSEMBLY AND EQUITABLY. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX SHORT
CIRCUITS ALL OF THAT STATE AND
LOCAL WORK AND WOOD WIDEOUT
MICHAEL BILITY IN CALIFORNIA
ALL TOGETHER IT DOES SO BY
STRIPPING LEGAL PROTECTIONS
FROM SHARED BIKES AND SCOOTERS
THE SAME LEGAL PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED TO EVERY OTHER
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IMPOSING
THE STANDARD ONLY ON THE
JAMYCHAL ABILITY INDUSTRY AND
NO ONE ELSE IS DEVASTATING TO
THE BY CONSIDERED THAT MAKE.
OUR AIR CLEANER AND OUR ROADS
SAFER. THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROTECT. LISTING CAL LAW
ALREADY RIGHT AT THE DO EVERY
THAN YOU CAN'T WAIT YOUR RIGHT
TO SUE IF YOU'RE INJURED BY A
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT NO MATTER
WHAT THAT PRODUCT IS THAT WE
COMPLY WITH THE SAME PRODUCT.
LIABILITY LAW APPLICABLE TO
EVERYONE ELSE THAT MEANS
INSURANCE BECAUSE EVERY FOR
WHICH WE ARE LIABLE BUT NOT FOR
INCIDENTS THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
OUR CONTROL. THIS BILL CHANGES
THAT. EXPOSING BOTH US AND THE
CITY THAT WORK WITH A-
LIABILITY OUTSIDE OF OUR
CONTROL. THE REAL QUESTION
TODAY IS WHETHER BIKES AND
SCOOTERS SHOULD BE SINGLED OUT
FOR A NEW AND MORE BURDENSOME
LIABILITY STANDARD. THAN ANY
OTHER CONSUMER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. KNOW WHETHER THIS
IS THE RIGHT TIME TO BE TAKING
SOCIALLY DISTANT RURAL MISSION
AND PEOPLE BILLY OPTIONS AWAY
FROM CALIFORNIA. IT'S BEEN.
NEED MORE SOCIALLY DIFFERENT
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS OR
FEWER. DURING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS SHOULD WE ADD TENS OF
MILLIONS OF CHARACTERS BACK ON
GEORGE STREET ANNUALLY. DURING
THESE PAST THREE YEARS CITIES
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE FOUND
THAT THE MORE TRIPS TAKEN BY BY
COMPUTERS AND THE PEOPLE BY
CAR. THE STATE FOR OUR STREETS
CAN BE FOR EVERYONE. TOGETHER
WITH OUR CITIES AND OUR WRITERS
WE HAVE SPENT YEARS WORKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIA'S REPLACEMENT PARTS
OF THE BY COMPUTER CHIPS. IN A
STATE OF ANIMAL AN EQUITABLE
WAY. EXCEPT FLOUTED THAT
COLLABORATED PROP. ONE QUICK
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS ARE
NEEDED THE MOST. HE TOLD ME
DISTRICTS WOULD ELIMINATE THEM.
BY DENYING THEM THE SAME LEGAL
PROTECTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
GRANTS EVERY. OTHER INDUSTRY.
WE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK. MISTER
HIGHER. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUSTIN HIGHER AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
AT THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX BECAUSE IT UNFAIRLY
TARGETS SHARED MICHAEL ABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA AND THREATENED
EXISTENCE BY DENYING AT THE
SAME LEGAL PROTECTIONS AFFORDED
TO EVERY OTHER INDUSTRY WE WANT
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND DOES NOT DO. THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROTECT RIDERS
FROM DEFECTIVE BIKES R
SCOOTERS BEGIN EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY SEES TO
THAT INSTEAD IT SINGLES OUT ONE
INDUSTRY AND ESTABLISHES A
NOVEL LEGAL STANDARD ONLY
APPLICABLE TO THE SHARED BY THE
MOBILITY SECTOR FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN YOU GO SKIING YOU
VOLUNTARILY AGREE TO ASSUME
CERTAIN RISKS YOU AGREE THAT
YOU WANT TO JUST BECAUSE YOU
FELL DOWN OR CRASHED INTO
SOMEONE ELSE OF COURSE BECAUSE
WE DON'T WAIT RIGHT TO SUE
THANK YOU COLLAPSES WHAT YOU'RE
RENTING HE'D BREAK. BECAUSE
BECKY THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY SPEAK TO WHAT THOSE
WAIVERS PROVISIONS CAN AND
CAN'T SAY AND SKI RESORTS RELY
ON THAT ESTABLISHED LAW TO
SCOPE THE RISK AND PROTECT
AGAINST LIABILITY OUTSIDE OF
THEIR CONTROL IF YOU ARE THE
RESORT OR RENT OUT CARS OR
ENGAGE IN ANY OTHER CONSUMER
FACING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN. EITHER STOP SLOP TO
LIMIT AND CONTROL WHY BY STATE
EXCEPT I CAN THEY ALONE UNDER
THE BELT. IN OUR INDUSTRY TO.
TURNING DECADES SALAS LAWSUIT
ALONE BE OF A- TO A- AB TWELVE
EIGHTY. HOWEVER WE PARTICULAR
CONCERNED IT HELPS ALREADY PAY
NUMEROUS EITHER OTHER ALSO.
THAT PER THEM FOR WRITING BIKES
SCOOTERS. FURTHER IF I'M WHY
ENSURING HIKE ON A INDUSTRY
THAT IS EVEN OP. AT FULL
CAPACITY THAT WITH THE FUTURE
THAT'S QUITE UNCERTAIN EVEN
BEING CONSIDERED DURING THIS
CRISIS. AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
WOULD BE THE FINAL STRAW ALL
THAT DURING THE CALIFORNIANS
GET BACK INTO THEIR CARS
INSTEAD. MORE ZERO EMISSION
SOCIALLY ENTRANCE. OPTIONS NOT
FEWER AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO MICHAEL
ABILITY NOT CREATE NEW ONES.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THIS
POINT NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONES. ARE AND IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE'RE
HAPPY TO HEAR FROM YOU YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND
INDICATING THAT YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL. IS IT BEFORE WE DO THAT
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM COULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO NOW WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES. OF OTHER ANY. ON
THE PHONE RIGHT NOW MODERATOR
WHO ARE LINING UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AND IF YOU WOULD
INDICATE HOW MANY. YES WE HAVE
FOUR SO FAR LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO. GO TO LINE OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT'S ONE
NINE EIGHT TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON STEVE WALKER
CARTOMIZERS HAPPY CAL POLY
BICYCLE COALITION IN
OPPOSITION. THANKS THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THE NEXT
LINE IS NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
THAT'S ONE NINE ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS GOES OUT MEN AND THE
PROPERTY OWNER I ASKED THE
NUMBER OF LAND NETWORK
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF OTHER
LANDMARKS AS WELL- WE STRONGLY
OPPOSITE. EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN AB
FOR SIX WE ARE STRUGGLING TO
SELL THANK YOU YOUR YOUR HERE
AT A LATER DATE ALL ARE SHORT
ON THAT WE'VE WE'VE MOVED OFF
THAT BILL BUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE YOUR OPPOSITION-
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO EMAIL IT GO
TO THE PORTAL OR TO THE-
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SITE. IN
ORDER TO EXPRESS ROB POSITION
ON THAT BILL WE ARE ON-
DIFFERENT BILL AT THE MOMENT-
BUT APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
AGAIN ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IT IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX. ON SURE
MOBILITY DEVICES I'M PLEASE
SERVICE DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO.
EIGHT RIGHT A MODERATOR TO
ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE. YES
WE HAVE TWO MORE LINES. GO
AHEAD. BLIND FLIGHT NUMBER TWO
ZERO EIGHT ONE THAT'S TWENTY
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE NATION WITH
PACMAN I TAKE THEM AS OPPOSED
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND THEN
NEXT ONE WE HAVE IS ONE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SIX TWO
ZERO EIGHT SIX CLEVELAND. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBER TIMOTHY BURR
ON BEHALF OF LIPS AT RISK
OPPOSE TO A TWELVE EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHERS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. SIX ALL
RIGHT THEN LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I JUST GOT A
COUPLE COMMENTS. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE- COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THERE IS NO
NEW LIABILITY STANDARD. THIS
BILL SIMPLY RESTRICTS THESE
COMPANIES FROM HAVING USERS
WAIVE THEIR RIGHTS. THEY THEY
INDICATE THERE ARE CERTAIN
THINGS A CAMPY WAY THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT BUT THAT NONE
THE LESS THEY STILL IN THERE
BECAUSE- TO RECALL. THAT WAIVER
EVEN THOUGH ARGUABLY IT IS
INVALID BUT FOR MANY PEOPLE
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE ASSUME
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY RIGHT.
OR RECOURSE. I WANTED TO MAKE A
POINT CLEAR. AND OF COURSE
GIVEN THE DRAMATIC RISE IN
PREVALENCE IN THESE DEVICES IT
IS EXPECTED THAT LOCAL AND
STATE REGULATION IS RACING TO
CATCH UP. THIS BILL REQUIRES
PROVIDERS INTO AGREEMENTS
OBTAIN PERMITS OR THEY CAN OPT.
OKAY GOVERNMENTS TO. BASE RULES
OF HOW THESE. CAN OPERATE WE DO
THAT WITH LOTS OF DIFFERENT
THINGS- AND AS I MENTIONED THE
WAIVER PROVISION. IN THIS BILL
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE OTHER
PROVIDER TO WAIVE ANY LEGAL
RIGHTS OR DEFENSES THEY HAVE A
CHOICE SIMPLY RESTRICTS THESE
COMPANIES FROM REQUIRING. THAT
THE USER IS A CONDITION OF USE
OF THIS OF THESE- ARE. OF THE
VEHICLES THE RIVER WHICH THE
USER TO WAVERLY'S OR OTHERWISE
LIMIT THEIR RIGHTS. THE BILL
SAYS YOU CAN'T. SO I. YOU KNOW
IT'S EXCITING SOMETHING AS
THINGS SAY THEY ARE OF AN OF
VEHICLE THERE THEY THEY SERVE
AN ACTUAL PURPOSE- BUT OF THIS
CONCERNS THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
THERE IS AN ATTEMPT TO AVOID.
ALITY IN THE ABSOLUTE AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE IS
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL SO- AT
ANY RATE. I WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT AND TO. OPEN UP FOR
DISCUSSION WE'VE GOT A MISTER
WE GET CENTER- BERG WHITE HOUSE
KIAN AND ABORTIONS IF ASKED TO
SPEAK AT A SORRY YES MISTER I
JUST CAUGHT YOU SO WE'LL PUT
YOU. AFTER SAID. BOARD ZIP.
THAT'S A PATIENT WAIT VERY GOOD
ARE RIGHT CENTER RUMBA I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LET ME DIRECT
COUPLE QUESTIONS AS OPPONENTS
OF MR FOOD IF YOU'RE STILL ON
THE LINE. LOOK LOOK BETTER ALL
RIGHT BUT LET ME UNDERSTAND SO
IT IF I UNDERSTOOD YOUR
TESTIMONY CORRECTLY I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE WAIVER
DOES AND ITS IMPACT AND HOW IT
PROTECTS- THAT'S- SO IF A
SCOOTER IN THE BRAKES FAIL THEN
THE PERSON WHO WAS THE WRITER
THAT PERSONS INJURED DOES THE
WAIVER IN ANY WAY TAX BIRD FROM
ABILITY. SENATOR IT DOES NOT IN
WHEN THERE ISN'T THAT IS OUR
LIABILITY- THE BECAUSE OF THE
PROTECT THE PRODUCT OR TO OTHER
WEEK THESE WAIVERS DON'T LIMIT
ELIMINATE THAT RECOURSE IN
ARGUE THESE WAIVERS. FROM WE
CONSIDER OURSELVES SUBJECT TO
THE SAME PRODUCT LIABILITY. OR
WHAT'S THE GOING GUIDING OKAY
LET LET ME WHAT CAUSE OF ACTION
OR WHAT LIMITED WITH DOES THE
WAIVER PER FOR YOU. ANOTHER
WORD WHAT BECAUSE TAX ARE WOULD
BE VICE. IF SIGNED THE WAIVER.
FOR MARKETS BECAUSE ACTION ARE
NOT LIABLE ARE THE THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO BAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH OUR LIABILITY SPECIFICALLY
BOOKS AS PART THE CONDITIONS OF
THESE OF THESE WAY. AS WE ARE
THE TRUTH FOR ALL. CALIFORNIA
USERS USE CAN CAN'T CAN'T HOLD
CANNOT RECALL IN EUREKA ARE NOT
THE RESULT OF OUR LIVES. DATE
CANNOT RECOVER FOR INJURIES MAY
RESULT OUR THEIR OWN THAT OR
THEIR OWN. WE'VE END AFTER
THAT'S THE THRUST ABOUT LIKE
THAT WE THAT THAT WE THAT WE TO
FOCUS ON TODAY WHICH IS YOU
KNOW THE OTHER PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL RELATING. IF THE
INJURY WAS OUTSIDE OF YOUR
CONTROL- THIS BILL DOESN'T
ELIMINATE NAY DEFENSES RIGHT.
ERIC SCRIPT. SENATOR DO YOU
BEAT WHAT IS STILL DOES IS IT
IS IT THE ELIMINATES THE
FORECLOSURE OF THE LAWSUIT THAT
NOTHING TO DO WITH OUR HAVE
NOTHING TO WITH OUR LIVE THAT
IS TO SAY AT PART OF THE OF AND
OUR OF THE AGREEMENT THAT YOU
SIGNED WHEN YOU EVER YOU WANT
OUR BIKE OR OF OUR YOU AGREE
CANNOT. THANK YOU BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT. HELLO FOR THE- PART OF
THE WORK THAT ARE NOT THAT ARE
NOT OUR LIABILITY. THATDOES.
THAT REPRESENT IN OF YOUR LEGAL
RIGHT TO RUN THE THAT WE THAT
THE ACTORS BY QUALITY. THE
LANGUAGE BROAD LANGUAGE WITHIN
THE BILL THAT TO LET THE WHOLE
HOLD ON FOR AND PROVISION OF
ANY. THAT A USER'S TO RUN THAT
ANYWAY. INTERESSE WHY SHOULD TO
THE PROSECUTION WITNESS ALL
RIGHT OF CENTER Y. CAO SKI.
BENCHER THANK YOU I CAN I THIS
SEEMS PRETTY THE MINIMUM.
INSURANCE YOU MAY LIKE IT AND
PROHIBITION OF WAY FOR RIGHTS
THOSE ARE SORT OF ON MOVED
MICHAEL MOBILITY CLEAN WILL.
LAST MILE MOBILITY PEOPLE BUT
THE PERMITTING AND THE LOCAL
OPERATIONAL OR MAINTENANCE OR
PUBLIC SAFETY RECALLS ARE ON
THE CITIES AND- I MAY BE
SKEPTICAL BUT I FELT SOME OF
THE CITY SAID I DON'T THINK
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY. YOU SEE
ASK ABOUT ALLOWS MILE IN THE
CLEAN MALL SO I'M WONDERING AND
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE BILL
YOU DON'T HAVE A BIG. THAT
WOULD SAY IF. THIS SAYS. THREE
YEARS OR TWO TO THE DAY ARE AT
THE TOP TO PERMIT PROCESS FOR
THEIR- OPERATIONAL MEET. OR
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THESE LAST
VIA BECAUSE THERE COULD BE SOME
CITY SOME CITIES OF JAPAN THEM
THAT WILL DO NOT. AND THOSE
RESIDENTS WERE NEVER THAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THIS CLEAN. UP.
MOTOR TREND SO. WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS YEAR BECAUSE TO SEN. IF
THE CITY THIS SIZE NOT TO
APPROVE. THE SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICE TO BE PROVIDED IN THERE
ARE SO WHAT RECALL WE CAN HAVE
RIGHT BUT SEE BUT SEE THE ONE
OF THESE. LEFT STATE THEY REDO
THE CONTRACTS THEY HAVE THE
THEY HAVE THEIR. INSURANCE
THESE WE WANT TO WE WANT TO
PROVIDE THESE THINGS THEY GOING
THE CITY THE CITY. WE HAVE NO
PER FOR. BUT WE WERE NOT GOING
TO PASS A MAIDEN LAW ON THESE
WOULD OCCUR YOU ANY IT'S SORT
OF A GIVE TRADE IF YOU YOU DO.
WHAT HAPPENS HELLO CAN SEE SO
WANT TO SOME TIME. BUT I'M
CONCERNED THERE BE SOME HAVE
TRYING TO REALLY PROVIDE THESE
CLEAN MODE. AS LONG AS WE CARE
OF THE CONSUMER. THERE MAY SOME
ENACT. FROM SOME RE. CAL OUT
THE THAT JUST SAYS NO WAY NOT
GOING TO DO WITH THIS CURRENTLY
I MEAN I THINK A- AND WE ARE. A
CITIES THAT. TOO BAD AND SOME
OF THESE REMOTE DEVICES FOR
THESE LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERN OVER THE WAY THEY WERE
THESE THE SERVICES ARE THE
DEVICE WERE OUT. IN COMMUNITY
AGAIN BOB OVERNIGHT UP ON ON
THIS AND SAW I THINK THE
ULTIMATE RECORD FOR MEMBERS.
THAT ARE ENDING IS. IS IT. IS.
STILL THERE THERE EITHER ON
THEIR LOCAL COUNCILS. STREETS
ARE ON THE SIDEWALKS AT ALL I
THINK THAT- IS UP TO EACH CITY
BUT YOU KNOW I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE A MAN AS AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST I WANT TO SEE
THIS MICROBE BILITY INDUSTRY
THRIVE AND YOU KNOW- I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT THAT SHOULD PREVENT.
THE THIS INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE
TO THRIVE- BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR
CONCERNS I THINK IT YOU KNOW WE
ARE LIVING UP TO CITIES TO MAKE
THAT DESERVE DETECT DISINTEREST
THERE'S A TRADE OFF FOR MADAM
CHAIR AND I CAN I GET THE FACT
THAT WE WANT TO HAVE SOME
CONTROL IN SOME ORDINANCES I'M
JUST IT'S JUST ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I PICKED UP THAT
THAT IF. A CITY SAYS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO PASS AN ORDINANCE THEN
THESE BUSINESSES WOULD BE
PRECLUDED FROM DOING THAT IF
THEY AS LONG AS THEY DO THE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL THAT. OUR HARD DRIVE. THE
TRAIN SO. OKAY I SAID STATE
LAURIE THANK YOU CENTER
BORCHERS THANK YOU. WE HAD A
VERY SPIRITED THE DISCUSSION ON
ONE OF YOUR OTHER BILLS LAST
WEEK I SEE YOU AGAIN IT IS
HERE- IN FORGIVE ME I HAVE TO
POSE THE QUESTION AS I DID LAST
WEEK ON HOW THIS IS CODED
RELATED. BUT THANK YOU WELL
FIRST OF ALL THIS BILL- IS A
TWO YEAR BILL AND SO- IT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED- LAST
YEAR UNDER. A VERY DIFFERENT
TIME AS AS WE ALL KNOW. BY YOU
KNOW I WOULD SUBMIT THAT- THIS
BILL IS CALLED RELATED AND
THAT- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TO. THAT AS- YOU KNOW THE
SERVICES CONTINUE TO BE
PROVIDED IN COMMUNITIES THAT.
THAT THERE ARE- YOU KNOW THE-
YOU KNOW THE CERTAIN DEVICES
AND SERVERS SERVICES ARE ARE
PROVIDED IN A WAY THAT THAT IS
SAFE FOR CONSUMERS- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY IF- IF YOU WILL. HAD
CALLED IT AND YOU NEED TO GET
AROUND IT YOU DON'T HAVE A CAR
OR BUS AND FOR YOU HAVE A E.
SCOOTER YOU KNOW HAND IN FRONT
OF YOUR HOME THEN YOU CN
LEARN. ALL OF THE OLD ALMOST
ALL STOP AT LINE INQUIRY I
THINK WE SHOULD TURN THIS INTO
A DRINKING GAME EVERY TIME WE
ASK IF IT'S COVERED RELATED.
THE VERBAL ACROBATS ARE
EXTRAORDINARY. DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION I DO I DO ACTUALLY DO.
SO MOVING ONTO TO THE MERITS OF
IT- SOME OF THIS ACTUALLY SEEMS
LIKE IT MAKES SENSE TO ME-
HAVING THE POLICIES. THE
INSURANCE- LIABILITY. POLICIES
IN PLACE. AND. THE OTHER THING
IS THAT MAKES THAT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE WHAT CAUSES ME ANGST
IS THE WAIVER. AND I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. EXISTS I THOUGHT
I UNDERSTOOD EARLIER BUT THEN I
THINK WE HAD TO SOME TELEPHONE
ENQUIRIES- IN AND MAYBE TO LOOK
AT MORE CONFUSING. I RENT. A
SCOOTER RIDE I GET ON THE
SCOOTER AND I HIT SOMEONE. THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS THE RIGHT THAT
THIRD PARTY IS THAT THIRD PARTY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO SUE. THE
SCOOTER COMPANY. THEY MAY HAVE-
DISINVITE AND THE CAUSE OF
ACTION TO SUE THE COMPANY IT
WOULD DEPEND ON THE FACTS OF
THE CASE I THINK AS THE MATH
MADAM CHAIR INDICATED THIS THIS.
CHANGE TORT LAW IN IN ANY WAY
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
MAY BE- A DUTY ON BEHALF OF THE
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICE
PROVIDER- TO THE THIRD PARTY-
YOU KNOW IF IT WAS A CASE OF
SAY WITHOUT COULD FACE THAT WAS
NOT MAINTAINED. ARE YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT PART SO IT HAVE
THAT LET'S MOVE TO THE PRIMARY
USER I'M ON THE SCOOTER. EIGHT
FORGET THE MECHANIC FAILURE
THAT SEEMS CLEAR THAT. IN THAT
EVENT THERE WOULD BE- LIABILITY
EXPOSURE. I DIDN'T TIE MY
SHOELACES I FALL OFF BREAK MY
LEG. CAN I. THEN WITHOUT THIS
WAIVER ODD WHAT I'D BE ABLE TO
SUE THE SCOOTER COMPANY FOR
THAT. AGAIN THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
THE EXISTING TORT LAW- IF THEY
HAVE A BECAUSE IT OUT OF
ACTION. BUT I MEAN IF THE- IF
THE PROVIDERS. YOU KNOW DID NOT
BREACH ANY DUTY OF CARE TO THE
USER YOU KNOW EXACTLY EXACTLY
GETTING TO CENTER ON BURKE'S
POINT- WHICH I THOUGHT WAS IT
WAS INTERESTING IS. WHAT
EXACTLY DOES A WAIVER OF
LIABILITY OFFER IF TORT LAW IS
NOT BEING SUBSTANTIALLY
MODIFIED. AND THERE IS A REASON
WHY PEOPLE PURSUE IT. THEY
PURSUE IT BECAUSE ONE IT'S A
GET OUT OF LITIGATION CARTON IT
CUT SHORT. WHAT OTHERWISE COULD
BE A PROLONGED EXPERIENCE IN
THE COURTS ORDERED LENGTHY
NEGOTIATIONS ON AND SO FORTH
THAT MAKES IT A LOT CLEANER SO
I CAN SEE WHY THE ENTITIES.
WANT TO PURSUE THAT. AND THEN I
GO BACK TO THE EXAMPLE OF IF I
WERE TO RENT A BICYCLE. OR
SWIMMING EQUIPMENT ALMOST ALL
OF THEM ARE GOING TO HAVE. UP A
LIABILITY WAIVERS. SO HOW IS
THAT DIFFERENT ARE THE HOWEVER
THOSE CIRCA. DIFFERENT IN AND
IT SHOULD BE APPLIED HERE. I
THINK THE BILLING ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION. ELEVEN LET ME ASK YOU
A CRYSTAL AND WITH IT THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS TO RUSH TO
RESPOND AND I CAN FOLLOW SURE
GO AHEAD IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
LETTING HIM THAT THAT'S A VERY.
VERY GOOD QUESTION FIRST OF ALL
THIS IS NOT A SPORT IT'S MORE
IF YOU WERE TO THINK ABOUT A
RENTAL CAR. IN A PARKING
TRANSPORTATION UNTIL CAR WHEN
THEY ASK YOU TO WAIT THERE
YOU'RE RIGHT STIFF THE TIRES
FELL OFF BECAUSE THEY HAD NOT.
TIGHTEN BECAUSE- ON FIRE. IF
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
WITH NOT AGREE WITH THAT THAT
IS WHAT THEY'RE SEEKING TO DO.
AFTER LEASES IN FRONT. WAIT
WHAT WAS SAID BY BIRD WHEN I
READ BIRDS PAPANASAM. RIGHT IT.
WILL BE BOTH THE MALFUNCTION
THE ARMY PAIN AND I'M OUT ON
MAY CALL INJURY. RIDERSHIP
THANK YOU FOR AND YOU WHAT
WE'RE HAVING ON IT IS OR
ANYTHING WE CAN OUR T. PAY WE
CAN'T HEAR THAT ANSWER IT'S
MODELED. IT IS HIS PHONE YEAH
FIVE. ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
CHANCE AND- CAN YOU CAN EITHER
GET THE YOUR PHONE IS NOT
TRANSMITTING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
IS THIS ANY BETTER I'M SORRY IS
BETTER THANK YOU HAVE MOVED.
WOULD YOU GO AHEAD AND AN OLD
FIVE I APOLOGIZE. ALL RIGHT.
YES WHEN I WAS READING BIRDS
RELEASING WHERE THEY ACTUALLY-
I HAVE THE USER SIGN A DOCUMENT
SAYING THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE RELEASING THEIR RIGHTS
OVER INJURY CAUSED BY THE
MACHINERY ITSELF. SAYING THEY
UNDERSTAND EVEN THAT MACHINERY
IT IS WELL MAINTAINED AND HAIL
IN IT THERE FOR THEY THEY
ACCEPT FULL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ANY INJURIES BECAUSE SO. BIRD
IN LEFT SEEK TO EXEMPT
THEMSELVES FROM THEIR OWN
DANGEROUS PRODUCTS PRODUCTS IN
WRITING IN THEIR RELEASE
AGREEMENTS IN STATE THAT THEY
GIVE NO WARRANTY AS TO THE
FITNESS OF THE PRODUCT. OR ITS
INTENDED USE SO THEY'RE WRITTEN
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE
TO SEE COMPENSATION IF THE
DEVICE BREAKS CLOSE UP THE
WHEELS FALL OFF. THAT'S WHY
THEY HAVE IT IN THERE WELL I'M
CONFUSED BECAUSE I HEARD THE
PROPONENTS ARGUE THAT. YOU
CAN'T THROUGH THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION ON DO TORT LAW. AND
LIABILITY FOR MECHANICAL
FAILURES EXIST NO MATTER WHAT.
HOWEVER RELATION IN WORDING. IS
IN A WAIVER. WELL THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY TRUE YEAH THEY PUT
IT IN THERE. THEY'RE SEEKING TO
DRAFT IN SUCH A WAY THAT ARE
THE RISK OF THE PRODUCT FAILING
TO BE PROPERLY MAINTAIN THEIR
INSPECTED. THESE PARTICULAR
DEVICES I PICKED UP AT NIGHT BY
WHAT THEY CALL BIRD CATCHERS OR
BLIND USERS WHO ARE JUST PEOPLE
WHO BRING THEM HOME. THE MAN
AND PUT THEM BACK ON THE STREET
THE NEXT DAY THERE'S NO
INSPECTION OF THAN THE TO BEING
CONDUCTED. IN THEIR WAIVERS
WRITTEN SUCH THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO ESCAPE LIABILITY FOR
FAILURE TO MAINTAIN AND INSPECT
THEIR OWN PRODUCTS. SO THEY MAY
BE TELLING YOU THERE'S NO WAY
THAT THERE IS THEIR WAIVERS.
BOB AND THEN YOU HAVE TO THE
QUESTION THEN WHY THEY GOTTEN
THEM THERE. BUT THEY SEE THE IN
TO TRY TO KEEP. FROM BEING HELL.
TO BE ABLE TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE
WHEN THEY'RE INJURED BY THEIR
PRODUCTS OKAY AND THEN. CLOSE
OF THANK. IS THERE A
SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF LITIGATION
THAT THESE ENTITIES HAVE
PREVAILED OVER INDIVIDUALS THAT
WEREN'T ABLE TO EXERCISE
TRADITIONAL TOWARD- RIGHTS. I
AM NOT AWARE OF. OKAY GO AHEAD
MISTER DON THERE'S THAT OVER
YET THEIR SON THEY'RE WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE COURTS
BECAUSE THESE ARE RELATIVELY
NEW BUT THEY'RE THEY HAVE
ASSERTED THEIR WAIVERS IN IN
LITIGATION. HE THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE WHY THEY SEEK TO
PRESERVE IT OKAY AND- DO THESE
SCOOTERS TO THE DRIVERS HAVE TO
ADHERE TO THE RULES OF THE ROAD
LIKE THEY WERE A MOTORCYCLE OR
A CAR. THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
RULES OF THE ROAD DETECTABLE TO
THESE DEVICES AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE LOCAL
CITIES DO WHEN THEY PASSED
THEIR PERMITTING REGULATIONS.
IS THEY CAN CREATE ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
ON THE SIDE WALK OFF OF THE
SIDEWALK BUT THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO CONFORM TO THE RULES OF THE
VEHICLE CODE. AND RULES IMPOSED
BY THE STATE OKAY WELL I GOTTA
TELL YOU KNOW I'VE IT THEY ARE
REALLY CONVENE THERE THEY CAN
BE VERY HELPFUL IN CONGESTED
AREAS- I HAVE ALSO SEEN SOME
TRULY RECKLESS BEHAVIOR BY SOME
OF THE FOLKS. THAT THE YOUTH
THAT USE THESE. EITHER WAY IT
IS SO ALL I I'LL MY COLUMN HERE.
THE IT DOESN'T IT IT'S ALMOST
AS IF WE ARE. SEARCHING FOR.
PREEMPTIVE LEGISLATION THE
ISSUE DOES NOT SEEM TO BE RIGHT
ON THIS PARTICULAR POINT
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE LIABILITY
INSURANCE POLICY I THINK IS
APPROPRIATE NON PROVISIONAL
ONE- BUT I THINK THE WAIVER
ISSUE- IS IT JUST NOT RIGHT AND
IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT COVERED
RELATED I WOULD RECOMMEND THIS
COME BACK IN JANUARY BUT THAT'S
JUST MY PERSONAL RESPECTFUL
OPINION DO YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I WOULD LIKE. TO K. AGAIN.
AT THE SOUNDS LIKE. THE COME
ONE IS SOME OF THE RISK AND SO
THIS WAY SOME OF SPORT. BANTOCK
KEEP THINKING WHEN YOU GO TO A
BASEBALL GAME THEY TELL YOU TO
GET HIT BY BASEBALL HE WAS SOON
THE RISK I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
PREVAILS OR NOT. BUT HEAR WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IS ON THESE
VEHICLES THEY'RE TRYING TO.
ATTACK HOUSE BY TALKING ABOUT
THEM IS A SPORTS VEHICLE. AND
WHAT THEY REALLY ARE AND I
THINK WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO
DO IS CLARIFY WHAT THEY REALLY
ARE. THERE ARE MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION- AND SO- IT
WOULD IT'S NOT CHANGING
LIABILITY STANDARDS- AND
CREATING NEW LAW WHAT IT SAYS
YOU CANNOT. APPLY ASSUMPTION OF
THE RISK TO THESE VEHICLES AS
IF THEY WERE LIKE YOU'RE GOING
SKIING OR WHAT HAVE YOU THESE
ARE MODE OF TRANSPORTATION. AND
THEY HAVE TO BE MAINTAINED
APPROPRIATE. HAVE TO A- SICK
YOU KNOW COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SOMEONE WHO'S
PUTTING THESE. VEHICLES IF YOU
WILL ON THE ROAD AND ACTS OF
THE ANALOGY I DON'T THINK CAR
MANUFACTURER COULD GET AWAY
WITH THAT- AND WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS NEITHER SHOULD THE-
THE SHOULD THESE VEHICLES. ARE
IN THEIR NEW PRODUCT I MEAN
THEY- THESE MOBILITY DEVICES
ARE POPPING UP AND I THINK OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND WITH
THIS BILL TRIES TO DO IS.
IDENTIFY CLEARLY WHAT THE
PUBLIC'S EXPECTATIONS ARE WHAT
OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE ALL OF THE
WAY THEY ARE. HANDLED IN THE
WAY. THEY ARE PRESENTED TO THE
PUBLIC THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
PICKED UP AT NIGHT. THE BROUGHT
TO SOMEBODY SHOT HOMER WHATEVER
IT IS TO A WAREHOUSE AND
THEY'RE NOT. THEY'RE NOT
MAINTAINED WHICH IS GET PUT
BACK OUT IN THE STREET AND
THERE THEY ARE AND IF SOMEONE
GETS INJURED. REDDIT WAIT A IN
THE COMPANY. TOUGH TOUGH LUCK
AND I THINK WITH THIS TRIES TO
DO IS PUT SOME CLARITY ON IT.
I'M NOT SURE I MAKE THE CODE
CONNECTION. DIRECTLY MYSELF BUT
I DO THINK THAT GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE'RE SEEING THESE
VEHICLES THESE DEVICES MORE AND
MORE IN OUR STREETS THEY DO
NEED TO BE IDENTIFIED AND- THEN
CATEGORIZE DIDN'T- PLACED
WITHIN. YOU KNOW THE PARAMETERS
OF WHAT THE PUBLIC'S
EXPECTATIONS CAN AND SHOULD BE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT I'M WE
HAVE ENDED OUR STERN. HE HOW
YOU DOING. OKAY THANK YOU CAN I.
BECAUSE I WANT TO PIGGY BACK ON
THE POINT YOU WERE JUST MAKING
MADAM CHAIR AND JUST GET SOME
CLARIFICATION OUT OF HE WAS THE
GENERAL COUNSEL. OUR STATE TO
BIRD MISTER SAID FU. I WAS
HOPING TO GET SOME CLARITY ON
THAT ASSUMPTION OF RISK
QUESTION AND ALSO SOME.
SOMETHING THAT. CENTER BORDERS
AND I'M BURKE WE'RE GETTING AT
IN TERMS OF. WHAT GOOD WHAT NEW
CAUSES OF ACTION AT IT CAUSE OF
ACTION QUESTION BUT IS HE ON
THE LINE STILL COMING JUST
CHECK THAT. LANTANA THREE SO
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF ITS IF IT
IF IT'S ALL RIGHT. MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL IS THE-
YOU YOU WOULD BE DENIED THE
ABILITY TO PROACTIVELY WAVES-
CERTAIN LIABILITIES BUT THAT
YOU WOULD STILL BE PRESERVED
THE ABILITY TO RAISE ASSUMPTION
OF RISK AS A LEGAL DEFENSE. IS
THAT IS THAT ARE YOU READ THIS
THIS LEGISLATION AS WELL.
SUTTER MADAM CHAIR THAT'S NOT
QUITE HOW WE NEED IT. AT THAT
RURAL CORRECTLY IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY FROM MY LAW WHAT THE
FUNCTION OF IT IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE BOTH EXPRESS AND
IMPLIED AND IN N. B. EXPRESS.
IS A LEGAL DEFENSE AVAILABLE TO
ANY OTHER CONSUMER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WOULDN'T BE
AVAILABLE TO US- TO USE THE
BASEBALL GAME ANALOGY BEFORE
YOU KNOW IT IT IT IS COMMON
THAT WHEN YOU GO TO A BASEBALL
GAME YOU ASSUME THE RISK. OF A
OF A BASEBALL STRIKE YOU. BUT
BUT BUT WHAT WHAT THERE ISN'T
IS A RULE THAT THAT THAT THE
DODGERS ALONE CAN'T HAVE THEIR
USED HAVE HAD THEIR CUSTOMERS
SIGN SUCH A WAIVER BUT TO DO IT
BUT THE GIANTS BUT IF THERE WAS
IF THERE WAS A TIME TO MAKE.
CHANGES TO SOME SERVICE DR
PROMOTE THE TRANSPORT I THINK
ARGUED THAT IT SHOULD APPLY
EQUALLY TO IT TO ALMOST
TRANSPORT BECAUSE I TRIED TO
GET EVERYONE AGREES THAT THE
STATE CHANGE A LOT ABOUT ON THE
BOARDWALK BUT WHAT IT DOES
CHANGES THE SCOPE OF WHAT. WHAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE INCLUDED IN
IT IN A USER AGREEMENT- AND I
BELIEVE MISTER DILLON AT LITTLE
BIT EARLIER WHAT VALUE THERE
WEREN'T ACTUALLY WERE FROM THE
REGION AND I THINK OF THAT AND
I THINK THE ANSWER IS THAT THE
FINANCIAL REALITIES OPERATE ANY.
BUSINESS YEAH. WILL BE A RISK
AND AVOID AT ALL. TROLL ON THE
WAIVER FOR ARE ONE OF THE KEY
TOOL FOR CONSUMER EIGHT AND TO
ENSURE THAT IN THAT WHY THEY
ARE BUT I EVERY CONCERT
INDUSTRY GALA. AND I IN I AND
OUR OBJECT TO THE BILL THEM
FROM FACT THAT WE WOULD BE ONLY
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA DENIED THAT
LEGAL PROTECTION. SO DO DO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO KEEP EXERCISING THAT
WAIVER AS YOU CAN UNDER CURRENT
LAW. D. PERTAIN TO THOSE. WHEN
THIRD PARTIES THAT. I FORGET
WHAT THAT MEANS THE AUTHOR OR
MISTER DOLAN REFERRED TO THEM
AS BUT THAT DOES YOU SORT OF.
PICK UP THE DEVICE. STORE
OVERNIGHT CHU SUM UP. IS THAT
HAVE YOU HAVE YOU APPLIED THE
WAIVER IN CIRCUMSTANCES WORST
MAYBE DAVE ACTED NEGLIGENTLY.
IS THAT THE SORT OF PRIMARY
CONCERN WHEN YOU SAY OUT OF
YOUR CONTROL IS THAT REALLY
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO. YEP
YEP CENTER THAT'S RIGHT THAT WE
WILL ALL RIGHT NOW- LET
LITIGATION THAT ARISES OUT OF
THOSE. CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
INSTANCE A RECKLESS RIDERS OR
ANOTHER CAR ON THE STREET OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. ARE IS THE
FACT THAT WE IT IS THE FACT
THAT WE ARE CLOSED BY A WEIGHT
BYE BYE BYE THE WAIVER
PROVISIONS IN THE AGREEMENT.
THE SAME WAY THAT THE WAIVER
PROVISIONS AND OTHER- INDUSTRY
FOR CLOSE THOSE. FOUR FOUR
CLOSE LITIGATE. WITH AB
PROBABLY. ARE CONCERNED THAT
THOSE THOSE CASES BECOME FAR.
NO REQUIRE A LOT MORE
LITIGATION IN ORDER TO RESULT
IN WALL THE ULTIMATE JUDGMENT
MIGHT AND YOU NOT BE A
RADICALLY ULTIMATELY END UP IN
THE SAME PLACE THE REALITY IS
THAT BETWEEN. DIFFERENCE DEAL
WITH A LITTLE GRAYSON AND NOT
IS REPRESENTS NEXT THREE NOT
ONLY ARE INDUSTRY TWENTY
INDUSTRY THAT WOULD HAVE TO-
ABOUT THAT WE HAVE THE CHILDREN
THAT KIND OF RISK FOR WORKING
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL
UNDERSTOOD MAYBE CHEROKEE MAYBE
YOU OR THE AUTHOR IN HIS
CLOTHES COULD JUST CLARIFY SOME
SUPER CLEAR ABOUT WHAT I'M
VOTING ON HERE BUT I THINK I
HEARD FROM- MISTER FU IS THAT.
YEAH STILL DO. PRESERVE THAT
DEFENSE ASSUMPTION OF RISK. BUT
THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE UNABLE TO
IMPOSE THIS WAIVER. SOME
ADDITIONAL SORT OF LITIGATION
RISK THAT. THE NOT QUITE I MEAN
IT'S HE DIED HE GAVE THEM
EXAMPLES OF RECKLESSNESS I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THESE THIRD PARTY
PRACTICES AT THE JUICERS OR
WHOEVER YOU WANT TO CALL THEM I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE STILL
UTILIZING THOSE SERVICES BUT- I
THINK THE THING THAT SENATOR IS
THAT THIS DOESN'T CREATE ANY
GREATER LIABILITY. AND IT
DOESN'T DENY THEM THE RIGHT TO
DEFEND- FOR STANDARD TORT LAW
SO IF THERE'S NEGLIGENCE BY THE
USER THAT'S A DEFENSE. SO
BASICALLY ALL IT DOES IS SAY
YOU CAN'T HIDE BEHIND THIS
WAIVER. AND SAY THINGS THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN YOUR LIABILITY
OR RESPONSIBILITY ORANGE
BECAUSE OF THIS WAIVER. I MEAN
THAT'S THE THAT'S AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL THAT THE
WAIVERS- ARE. IT SORT OF. NOT
ALLOWED THERE IF THEY'RE
ESSENTIALLY- UNCONSCIONABLE
POTENTIALLY OR AT LEAST PARTS
OF THEM SO RATHER THAN LET THEM
DO IT AND HAVE THEM BE FOUND
UNCONSCIONABLE THIS BILL SAYS
HE CAN'T HIDE BEHIND WHAT IS AN
UNCONSCIONABLE WAVE YOU CAN
ASSERT WHATEVER CLAIMS YOU HAVE
INFORMAL TOWARD LAW. THOSE
SERVICE THE ARE STILL FOR YOU.
THAT ESSENTIALLY IS I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE BILL DOES
AND PERHAPS IN YOUR CLOTHES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU CAN CLARIFY
FIVE MISUNDERSTOOD IT. BUT IS
THAT HELP AT ALL SENATOR YES.
SIR STERN WE GET. YES IT DOES
THANK OKAY GREAT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR THE RAZA. THANK
YOU YOU GUYS ARE ALSO SMART YOU
TOOK MY QUESTIONS BUT- I JUST
WHAT SORT OF LEAD YOU TO A
CURIOUS AS TO WHAT LED YOU TO
WANNA PROPOSE LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS AND- I KNOW I'VE BEEN IN
SOME CITIES WHERE IT'S VERY
POPULAR AND THEY'RE JUST.
THROWN ALL OVER THE SIDEWALKS
YOU JUST HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
WHERE YOU WALK SO- THAT'S BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE ALTHOUGH I AGREE
WITH YOU I THINK IT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT IT SEEMS THAT. THESE
NEW IDEAS. ARE IN ARE DONE
FIRST AND THEN WE'RE SORT OF
REACTING AND RESPONDING LATER
TO WHAT WITH WHERE THE RULES
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
AND THEN YOU INTRODUCE IT WITH
A LOT MORE RESPONSIBILITY BUT-
MY QUESTION IS. WHAT WAS IF YOU
CAN GIVE EXAMPLES OF WHAT WAS
THE EXPERIENCE. THAT EITHER
CITIES OR COUNTIES HAD. THAT
LED YOU TO WANNA. INTRODUCE
THIS LEGISLATION- YEAH THAT'S
IT BASICALLY THANK YOU SENATOR
SO. THE INTRODUCTION OF THESE
DEVICES OVERNIGHT HAPPENED IN
MY DISTRICT- IN CITIES LIKE
REDONDO BEACH AND MANHATTAN
BEACH- SUDDENLY. THESE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICES APPEARED ON
THE SIDEWALKSAND- THEY LEAD TO
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COMPLAINTS- FROM RESIDENTS.
ECKLEY SENIORS CENTER BARGES-
IT TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
DANGEROUS THAT COULD BE IF
THEY'RE LEFT ON THE SIDEWALKS
IT RESTRICTS ACCESS FOR SENIORS
WHICH IS WHY THE A. R. P.
SUPPORTS THIS BILL. YOU KNOW
MAY RESTRICT ACCESS TO THE TO
THE TO THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
WHICH IS WHY THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTS THIS BILL- I THINK IT
IT JUST MAKES SENSE LIKE YOU.
SAID CENTER THAT TO YOU KNOW
RATHER THAN WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CATCH UP TO
THIS INDUSTRY THAT DECIDED THAT
THEY JUST WANT TO ROLL OUT-
WITHOUT- ANY- PUBLIC SAFETY
REGULATIONS- IN PLACE AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO CATCH UP. TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WHEN THE
ESSENTIAL NEEDS TO GET TO THE
HOSPITAL TO TAKE CARE OF A
COVERT. YOU KNOW THEY THEY
WOULD. TO SERVE A BILL DEVICE
OF THEY NEED TO. YOU KNOW PUT
THE IT IS THE- IN. WELL MY GOOD
ALL RIGHT. THAT WAS GOOD ALL
RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS. THE CENTER
I'M BURKE NO ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT A SINISTER IS YOUR HAND
STILL UP. NO OKAY ALL RIGHT I
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE- B. THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL- AND
AGAIN- AS MADAM CHAIR AS YOU.
BOB POINTED OUT ON SEVERAL.
CATIONS THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE TORT LAW THE SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE PROVIDERS THEY
STILL HAVE THE SAME DEFENSES
WHETHER IT'S ASSUMPTION OF
RISK- OR ANY OTHER. LEGAL
DEFENSES- IN AND THEY CAN THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO ASSERT THEM
I'M- FRANKLY DISAPPOINTED WITH
SOME OF THE RHETORIC USE BY THE
REPRESENTED FROM BIRD I MEAN
THIS SHOULD NOT AND IS NOT
INTENDED TO. TO BE AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
MICROBIAL OF THE INDUSTRY.
AGAIN WE HAVE MANY REASONS TO
SUPPORT. THIS INDUSTRY TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE. YOU KNOW
THERE BUT THERE'S NOT THERE
SHOULD BE A QUESTION LIKE IT.
OUR USER OF A E. SCOOTER IS.
AND THE- YOU KNOW THEY THEY- HI
I TRY TO USE- PER DEVICE IN A
NEGLIGENT MANNER I MEAN BIRD
CAN SUE THE RIDER- IT AGAIN IT
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING IN
TERMS OF EXISTING TORT LAW AND
EGGS IN TERMS OF EXISTING
DEFENSES- I. WANT TO MAKE THAT
EMPHASIS LAST BUT NOT LEAST YOU
KNOW MAKING SURE THAT WE TREAT
THIS AS FOR WHAT IT IS AS A-
IMPORTANT MODE OF TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION THAT MAY BECOME
INCREASINGLY POPULAR- THIS
SHOULD BECOME INCREASINGLY MORE
POPULAR IF THEY CAN CUT DOWN ON
CAR TRIPS. ON ON EMISSIONS- AND
AFFORDABLE WAY- WE WANT TO
PROMOTE THAT BUT IN IN A SAFE
WAY THAT PROVIDES FOR BASIC
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I ASKED FOR I
GOT. TO HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATOR DORADO
SENATOR ALSO MOVES. BY MADAME A
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL A SENATORS PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON THIS
IS FILE ITEM LINE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX MARTUCCI. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
JACKSON JACKSON- APEX IN BY
BURGESS BURGESS NARROW TO DEATH
CAN YOU TURN YOUR MAKER IS A
MICROPHONE ON. OKAY BURGESS
THANK YOU KNOW PORTIS NOW DON'T
KNOW THE RUSSELL I THE RUSSELL
BY GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
MELENDEZ. NO MELENDEZ NO
MORNING I MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN NINE STERN I- BURKE- BERG
I WAKE CAL SKI HI MY CASKEY I
THAT SEVEN TWO TWO SEVEN TWO
TWO- THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI THAT
WAS MUCH SHORTER THAN THE FIRST
ITEM AND NOW WE'LL GO TO FILE
ITEM THREE AND SEE IF WE CAN.
CONTINUE OUR- THE MOMENTUM HERE.
GIVE ME JUST A SECOND TO.
ENOUGH REUSING AGREES TO
DELIVER. MONDAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR HOPEFULLY THIS IS
QUICK BECAUSE IT IS A SIMPLE
BILL M. IN VERY COVERT RELATED.
DISCUSSION THERE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THIS IS COVERED
RELATED ADS WE KNOW PEOPLE
BECOME INCREASINGLY DEPENDENT
ON ON FOOD DELIVERY SERVICES
BOTH RESTAURANTS AND
INDIVIDUALS AT HOME DURING THIS
PERIOD HOWEVER WE'VE ALSO NOW
FOUND OUT- THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT THERE ARE
RESTAURANTS WHO HAVE NOT AGREED
TO BE PART OF THIS DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND HAVE HAD NEGATIVE
EFFECTS ON THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
AS A RESULT- FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A HAVING
SOMETHING ORDERED FROM YOUR
RESTAURANT YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S BEING ORDERED FROM A
DELIVERY SERVICE. SOMETIMES
THAT DELIVERY SERVICE CAN POSIT
BE DELIVERED LATE WRONG IT
COULD BE THE WRONG ORDER IT.
YOU CALPERS MORALS GO DOWN BE
THE CUT THINK THAT YOU ARE IN
OUR THIS DELIVERY SERVICE. SO
ALL THIS SAYS IS SIMPLY THAT
THERE HAS TO BE AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE FOOD DELIVERY
COMPANY AND THE FOOD FACILITY.
IN ORDER FOR A FOOD DELIVERY
COMPANY TO. PARTAKE IN
DELIVERING THOSE SERVICES- WE
DID A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS TO SEE HOW WE COULD
DO THIS BILL I KNOW THAT. THERE
IS GREAT. NOW SAYS ABOUT THINGS
PROBABLY NEED TO COME BACK AND
STRENGTHEN IT UP WITH BUT THIS
IS WHAT. TODAY IN A RESERVE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ONE OF. THAT
IS THE BALLPARK. ONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND YOU DON'T GET
THAT OFTEN. IT IS TRUE SO FUNDS
CLEAR. CHINGLISH TO THIS FILE
UP I'M THREE AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY CONSULT ON
FOOT. PLAQUE AT. CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ON THE
LINE YOU'RE RIGHT THIS IS A AN
INTERESTING COLLABORATION BUT-
IF MISTER SUTTON YOU ARE ON THE
LINE AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
WITNESSES YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THE METS THAT MOVIE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION JUST
WANT TO VERIFY YOU CAN HEAR ME
APOLOGIES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU DO AT THE
MOMENT IN DOLLARS FOR ALL THREE
OF THE TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE
AND SHE CLEARLY SAID THIS IS
ABOUT RECEIVING PERMISSION FROM
A RESTAURANT PRIOR TO
DELIVERING THE FOOD. ON OUR
BEHALF. BUT ME THANK YOU TO
COMMONSENSE PRINCIPLE JUST GOOD
BUSINESS PRACTICE WE AGREE
HOWEVER THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND SO MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS. THIS PROBLEM WAS A
PROBLEM BEFORE COVERED NINETEEN
AND IT WILL BE A PROBLEM AFTER
COCONUT GENE AND NOT SAY BE
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE- MOVES
FORWARD TO FIX ISSUE. THE
RESTAURANT'S. MENUS OTHER ITEMS
WITHOUT PERMISSION THE REST.
AND DELIVERING THAT TO DISCUSS.
ALSO WITHOUT. IN UNKNOWN TO OUR
MEMBERS THIS TYPE BAY TRACK.
PROBABLY HELPS TO APPS DRIVE.
TO PLOT. BUT FOR RESTAURANTS IT
CREATES CONFUSION DINNERTIME
BRAND INDUSTRY OUT. SOME CASES
THIRTY HOW A DELIVERY SYSTEM OF
THEIR OWN. IN TURN. THE MENU
LIST ON ANOTHER. GOOD BYE.
INTEGRATES MESSAGING FROM THE
REST AND DELIVERY. SHOWS UP.
THE CUSTOMER AND DRIVER REST
AND LIVES THE IF THE CUSTOMER.
DOES NOT GET THEIR FOOD
SOMETIMES. DON'T GET. AND THE
RESTAURANT REPEAT DAN. ANOTHER
IN ITS FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM
MIGHT POST. A LOGO NOW DATA
MENU AND CHANCES ARE. IF WE
DON'T KNOW THAT. WE CAN'T
ENSURE ACCURATE SERVICE TO THAT
GUEST. WE CAN'T PROTECT THE
RESTAURANT REPUTATION WHEN
THIRD PARTIES ARE DELIVERING
OUR PRODUCT THE FOOD. BUT THAT
ARE NOT YOU CAN. NINE THREE
BEEN AMENDED TO THE APPROACH TO
FIX THE THIS PROBLEM IN SAYS.
YOU GOTTA HAVE TO IF YOU'RE
GONNA DO FOR FROM A RESTAURANT
VIA A THIRD PARTY FOR. WHAT TO
DO PLATFORM I ON THE OF THE
REST EMPLOYEE. THAT PARTNERSHIP
THE TWO AND- NOT ALL TO DELIVER
PRACTICE. ARE TAKING SUCH.
IMPRESSED TACKED TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESS. JUNK FOOD PROCTOR ARE
ACTS TRUE PART WITH RESTAURANTS.
WE WILL ALL FOOD DELIVERY
SHOULD COMMIT PARTNERSHIP THAT
ARE HUGE BENEFIT. IT'LL RESTORE
THAT ACT BACK INTO THE RELAY. I
THINK AB TWENTY ONE FORTY IS
FACT THAT HELP TO SKILLED
EQUITY TOWARD THE LOCAL
RESTAURANTS WHICH I YOUR END
VALUE TO THE STATE'S OVER REST
YOU. THAT IS PROUD TO BOAST THE
THANK YOU FOR OF HELP REST ARE
OWNED PEOPLE OF COLOR THE REST
COMMUNITY AT LEAST PRIOR TO.
THEY'RE INTENTIONAL
UNAUTHORIZED DELIVERY OF OUR
PRODUCTS FOOD HELPS DRIVE
INCREMENTAL SALES FOR
RESTAURANTS AND THEREFORE WE
SHOULD BE GRATEFUL. I RESPOND
IS THERE A TIME THAT YOU
CRIMINAL STALE VALUE IS
COMPLETELY OUTWEIGHED BY THE
REPUTATIONAL DAMAGE CAUSED BY
THE UNAUTHORIZED HANDLING AND
DELIVERY OF OUR FOOD. AND THE
CONSUMER IS UNDERSTANDABLY
INCORRECTLY ABSENT WITH THE
RESTAURANT FOR THE CORE
PERFORMANCE OF THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY KITTY. YOU LIKE HERE
THAT THEY WILL THREATEN TO PULL
THEIR FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE OUT
OF EXISTING SERVICE TERRITORY.
SPOTS WOULD BE THE TRUE
DELIVERY PLATFORMS AND BEEN
VERY PUBLIC THAT- DELIVERY SIDE
OF THINGS IS THE BEST HOPE FOR
THESE PLATFORMS TO BECOME
PROFITABLE IN TODAY'S
ENVIRONMENT. SO IT'S I THEIR
SELF INTEREST TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE. THAT THEY CURRENTLY DO
IN CALIFORNIA. FINALLY THE
STAFF ANALYSIS HIGHLIGHTS THE
OPPONENTS CLAIM AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE IS BAD FOR
RESTAURANTS. THE MUSING
FERNANDO INCREDIBLY IRRITATING
FOR MUCH LONGER PLEASE
REFERENCE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PRESS. THANK YOU. IN THE VOICE
RESTAURANTS IN THE STATE AND IN
THIS BUILDING FOR DECADES WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE BOARD
COMPROMISED SMALL LARGE
OPERATORS THANK YOU BACK PLEASE
SUBMIT THAT WE KNOW BETTER. WE
KNOW BETTER WHAT RESTAURANTS
LIKE USED MUCH AS FUNNY TO HEAR
ABOUT IT FOUR MINUTES ALMOST
FOUR MINUTES THIRTY SECONDS SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT WE WE'VE
ALREADY IN ALICE'S WILSON WITH
THAT. SEE IF ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO LIKE TO. GIVE US THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE SERVE ANYONE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NO
ONE LETS GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE IS NO ONE THERE NOW WILL
GO TO ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. A MODERATE COULD YOU
PLEASE BOB THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THE TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE AND
WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. JUST MOMENTS FOR
THE FIRST.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM ONE OF TWO ZERO SEVEN
EIGHT TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MODERATOR WOULD YOU TELL US HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE.
WE HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALREADY VERY GOOD
PLEASE SIR. GO AHEAD
INTENSIFIED NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE. MY
NAME IS LOUIS SOVEREIGNS. AND I
HAVE THREE RESTAURANTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO AN
ORANGE COUNTY SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY AND ONE IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY EVERYTHING THAT THE
STATE ASSEMBLY JUST MENTIONED
ARE MY BIGGEST NIGHTMARES
THANK- I'VE HAD MY OWN BUSINESS
FOR NINETEEN YEARS. AND I'VE
HAD NOTHING BUT THEY ARE IN SO
AND ALSO PARTS THANK YOU THAT'S
BECAUSE OF ALL ALL OF THE
ONLINE- THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
CAN GET WE GET IT I THINK
YOU'RE- THE CHAOS AN IDEA
SHOULD ASK WERE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SO I CAN. CALL
YOUR RESTAURANT AND COME PICK
UP MY OWN FOOD AT SOME POINT
TIME. BUT THAT BEING SAID- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OF. AB.
TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE. AND
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SIR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE. I
DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE YOU
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WE DO IN FACT HAVE. DYLAN
HOFFMAN IN CAMERON DIMITRI ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION. A
MODERATOR IS THAT CORRECT. YES
THAT'S CORRECT ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GIVE YOU FOLKS FOUR
MINUTES AND TEN SECONDS TWO
MINUTES EACH. TWO MINUTES TEN
SECONDS EACH I THINK THAT MAKES
IT ALL BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
USE IT ALL BUT IT'S AVAILABLE
TO YOU SO LET'S GO AHEAD OF MR
HOFFMAN WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD
AND START. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR STONE HUSBAND
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR INTERNET
APPLICATIONS- I A THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
FORTY OF. THE WORLD'S LEADING
INTERNET COMPANIES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE. BUT WHILE THE
BILL SURELY WELL INTENTIONED WE
BELIEVE IT WOULD HAVE DIRECT
CONSEQUENCES FOR RESTAURANTS
ARE FOR DELIVERY PLATFORMS AND
CONSUMERS ALIKE. ARE COMING
UNNECESSARY HARM DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL. THAT'S
RESTAURANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CLOSE THE DOORS TO DINE IN
CUSTOMERS MANY TURN TO OUR FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS TO OFFER
DELIVERY SERVICE ENGINE OPTIONS
AND IT WILL. DELIVERED GLAD
RESTROOM OFFERDELIVERY WITH
HAVING HIGH AND DRY OR- THEIR
OWN DELIVER SUCH. AND MANY
RESTAURANTS TALIBAN BUT THEY
FOR ALL DELIVERY THROUGH OUR
CLASS WITHOUT A FORMAL. WHICH
ALLOWS THEM PLAY TROUT. AND
MANY ON BLOCK ON PLATFORMS OR
TO BETWEEN CLASS PARTIES.
HOWEVER IT YOU TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE AND A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH REQUIRING ONE TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
RESTAURANTS AND POP UPS. THE
MEDIA IMPACT OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS. WE CAN POPULOUS
RANDOLPH FROM DELIVERY- UNTIL
FORMAL AGREEMENT CAN BE MADE-
BUT WE THINK THAT'S CREATES
UNNECESSARY DISARRAY FURNITURE
THAT'S STILL REELING FROM THE
PANDEMIC. I'M ALWAYS OF THE
PROFIT MARGINS ARE YOU TIRED OF
CARMEL LAST COULD BE DISASTROUS
FOR RESTAURANTS. TRYING TO KEEP
IT OPEN. PRESSURE TO COME.
COMPETITORS FOLLOW FUTURE GET
NEGOTIATED ARE PLATFORMS WILL
DO THEIR BEST FOR. OUT OF THESE
AGREEMENTS CORPORATE. BY IT'S
LIKELY TO CRITICAL A REQUIRED
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE START OF
PANDEMIC OUR PROBLEM RECEIVED
QUESTION. OF RESTAURANTS TRY
AND BUY. FOR OUR DELIVERY
SERVICE. THANKS I COULD NOT
HAVE A BUYING A DIFFICULT SAY
HOW LONG THE PROCESS TO.
DISAGREEMENTS WITH BUT I ANY
DELAYS WILL CAUSE RESTAURANTS
WEBER I FINALLY WE BELIEVE. THE
BILL DEFINITION OF COULD
FACILITY IS A BROAD TO ADDRESS
THE ASSURING WE RESPECT COMPANY
NARROW TO ACQUIRE A WINDOW.
ONTO NATIONAL. BOASTED AND-
THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT- RIVER.
PARK. AB TWENTY. NINE I STILL
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL CREATE
DETRIMENTAL CONSEQUENCES TO
RESTAURANTS ARE PLATFORMS THE
CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON THEM.
IT'S NO SECRET CODE NINETEEN IS
IMPACTED EVERY INDUSTRY BUT AS
NOTED BY THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
BUT HAD A- DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON RESTAURANTS PARTICULARLY FOR
FAMILY OWNED RESTAURANT. STAY
HOME ORDERS CREATED A GREAT
NEED FOR RESTAURANTS TO REACH
CUSTOMERS WHO NO LONGER WALK
THROUGH THEIR DOORS. THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY PLATFORMS HAVE
BEEN THERE TO HELP BRIDGE
CUSTOMERS TO RESTAURANTS
STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN. AS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION THE
ABILITY TO PARTNER EITHER
FORMALLY INFORMED ME WHAT THE
DELIVERY PLATFORM EXPANDED.
STRUNG OUT. BY THE AMERICAN
AFTER. AND I. DELIVERY OPTION
WITHOUT THE- INTENSIVE BURDEN
ASSOCIATED WITH FLEET
ACQUISITION. WITHOUT A FORMAL
AGREEMENT WHICH SOME
RESTAURANTS PREFERRED
RESTAURANTS CAN SEAMLESSLY TAKE
ORDERS FROM ONE PLATFORM TO
ANOTHER EFFORTLESSLY WITHOUT
ANY CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION OR
LIMITATION. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE WOULD PUT THIS PREFERENCE
IN JEOPARDY IN APPLY UNIFORMED
APPROACH THAT MAY GO AGAINST
YOUR RESTAURANTS PREFERENCE.
THE AFFIRMATIVE EXPRESS CONSENT
CONNECT THEM OUTLINED IN THE
BILL COULD CREATE A DEVASTATING
LINE BETWEEN WHAT RESTAURANTS
ARE DROPPED FROM PLATFORM SO
WHEN THEY CAN BE ADDED BACK
ONTO THE PLATFORM. WHICH COULD
BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
RESTAURANTS STAYING OPEN OR
CLOSING THEIR DOORS FOREVER.
PLATFORMS WOULD LIKE. TO TRY TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THESE CHALLENGES
BUT AN EDITION OF EVERY
RESTAURANT IN THE STATE SEEKING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION CONTENT WILL BE
UNDOUBTEDLY CREATE DELAYS IN
RESPONSE NEXT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITHOUT- LET'S GO TO
WITNESSES. WHO ARE GOING TO
JUST SIMPLY IDENTIFY THEMSELVES
AND THEIR AFFILIATION. WHETHER
ANY OF THOSE WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE. ALL RIGHT SEEING.
NO ONE. LET'S GO THEN TO- ROOM
ONE TWELVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO LET'S. BRING
IT TO THE PHONES AGAIN- WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO GIVE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY NINE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
MIN ZERO. DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE MODERATOR. BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME- LET'S WAIT ANOTHER
THIRTY SECONDS AND THEN WE'LL
GO AHEAD I'VE GOT A FEW
COMMENTS. AND THEN WE'LL OPEN
IT UP IF ANYONE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT WELL FIRST
OF ALL THE RECENT AMENDMENTS SO
THAT WE'RE CLEAR- THE IDEA OF
THIS BILL IS TO REQUIRE A
RESTAURANTS CONSENT. FOR FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICE CAN ARRANGE
FOR THE DELIVERY OF THE
RESTAURANTS FOOD. THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS BILL
ACCOMPLISHED IT BY FORBIDDING
THE POSTING OF MANY TRADEMARK
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THE
RESTAURANT. BY THE SERVER
DELIVERY SERVICE WITHOUT THE
RESTAURANTS. THIS KIND OF CAR
DID IN IT WAS BY THE OPPOSITION
COULD BE SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT TO.
WORK THROUGH- IS RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TRADEMARK AND
COPYRIGHT LAW SO S. AMENDED A
FEW DAYS AGO AND THANK YOU TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO
RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETIMES
SIMPLE. SIMPLE IS BETTER- THE
BILL SIMPLY PROHIBITS PRO
PROHIBITS ARRANGING FOR THE
DELIVERY OF A RESTAURANTS FOOD
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT. SIMPLE
IT'S A DIRECTED I THINK GOOD
OLD FASHION REGULATION OF A AN
ABUSIVE BUSINESS PRACTICES. ARE
TICKETS INTERESTED OUT OF THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTERS AND THE TECH
INDUSTRY SIZZLE RESTAURANTS ARE
GOING TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
THE SOMETHING IS A LITTLE OFF
AND IF STRESS THEY WERE GONNA
GET THE BUSINESS I SUSPECTED MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IS THEY'RE VERY VOCAL
AND WOULD BE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. BUT IN FACT PORT
SO- WELL THIS BILL I FOR SEEK A
REST CONCERTS BEFORE YOU PROF
OFF THEIR PRODUCT AND WHY- IS
IN THIS BEING DONE ALREADY- THE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE COMPLICATED. I THINK IS- IS
CHESTER. INACCURATE THE BILL
THE FOOD FACILITY EXPRESSLY
AUTHORIZING THE FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORM TO TAKE OR IN DELIVER
MEALS PREPARED BY THE FACILITY.
THE TECH JUST SINCE IN WRITING
THAT'S UP TO SAY. AND THEN
EMAIL ACTUALLY COULD COULD
SATISFY THIS REQUIREMENT
THERE'S NO FORMALITIES
REQUIRED- THE POINT IS THIS IS
NOT AN ONEROUS REQUIREMENT- AND
THE LAPSES SERVICE ARGUMENT AS
I INDICATED IF THERE WAS REALLY
GOING TO BE A LAPSE OF SERVICE
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY WOULD
BE IN STRONG OPPOSITION. JUST
SIMPLY OF THESE PLATFORMS FROM
WHAT I HAVE GATHERED A MOVEMENT
WHICH I'VE HEARD IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY IS THAT WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT MOST OF THE PROFIT GOES
TO THE A PLATFORM TO THE
DELIVERY OF THE PRODUCT AND
REST. COOLEY THEIR PROFIT WHICH
IS- ANYWAY IS REDUCED EVEN MORE
DRAMATIC. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE TO. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT UNLESS THE
RESTAURANT KNOWS THAT THERE'S
SOMEONE ACTUALLY DOING THIS ON
THEIR PLATFORM THEY HAVE NOBODY
TO NEGOTIATE WITH. SO IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT. THIS IS
SOMETHING PARTICULARLY ARE
SMALLER BUSINESSES. LARGE
CHAINS MIGHT HAVE BARGAINING
POWER AND LEVERAGE BUT- SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE REALLY AT THE
MERCY OF THESE COMPANIES AND-
THIS BILL ELIMINATES
CONDUCTANCE OF BENEFIT BETTER
AFTER SEN. I JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT A LOT OF THIS WERE
TREADING NEW GROUND BECAUSE
THESE PLATFORMS IN THE WHOLE.
IDEA OF THE INTERNET AND IN
PLATFORM. CONDUCTING CUSTOMERS
IS NEW. THE TECH INDUSTRY TESTS
INTO BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT OF
THIS IDEA THEY BE ABLE TO. IT
AND- BUT- THESE ARE NOT IN THE
SUPPOSED TO BE PREDATORY
INDUSTRIES AND PREDATORY A
COMPANIES- THERE ARE CERTAIN
THAT KIND OF RULES OF FAIRNESS
AND CONTRACT IN IN WHAT HAVE
YOU THAT STILL NEED TO BE
ABIDED BY EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE
THESE NEW KINDS OF CONCEPTS AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL.
INDICATES IT IS RESTORE SOME
EQUITY IN BARGAINING POWER AND
THINGS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL I
WOULD SUBMIT TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE FOR THIS
MARVELOUS FREE MARKET KEEP
PUSHING FOR THIS IS HOW A
FUNCTIONING FREE MARKET CANS
FIVE BY ALLOWING RESTAURANTS.
TO OPT INTO THE PROGRAM.
BELONGS AND THAT'S WITH THE
ENTITY THAT'S PRODUCING ALL OF
THE VALUE IN THIS RELATIONSHIP
AND- AS SOMEONE WHO. EATS OUT
FREQUENTLY AND TAKES OUT
FREQUENTLY- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WONDERFUL LOCAL
RESTAURANTS STAY IN BUSINESS
AND ARE ABLE TO THRIVE COVERT.
OR NO COVERED. AND THERE'S A
CONNECTION ERROR SEVEN. ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT- THE BILL ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CASKEY SENATOR BORJAS
HAS A QUESTION. THANK YOU
SOMEONE I'D I WAS CURIOUS ON
HOW THIS WAS GOING TO PLAY OUT
AND I'VE I'VE LEARNED QUITE A
FEW THINGS THAT I DIDN'T KNOW
BEFORE ABOUT THIS. OP FOR
EXAMPLE THE STAFF REPORT
INDICATED THAT- THE ONLINE
PLATFORMS WHICH I BELIEVE
PROVIDE A FANTASTIC SERVICE AND
REMARKABLY THERE IS A COOKIE
CONNECTION HERE BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE USING ONLINE FOOD
PURCHASING- PUTS MORE THAN THEY
DID BEFORE BUT I DID NOT KNOW
THEY COULD MODIFY THE PRICES.
WAS KIND OF NEW TO. I DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT. MAY THAT WAS
REFLECTED IN THE PRICE OF THE
FOOD AND- THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
THEIR OWN DELIVERY- PERSON
THERE- I CAN SEE HOW THIS WOULD
CREATE HAVOC HAVING WORKED IN
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY FOR
MANY MANY YEARS I CAN EASILY
SEE HOW THIS THING GETS A
LITTLE WEIRD- SO JUST TWO
QUESTIONS. THE AGREEMENT THAT
YOU TALK ABOUT. IT THAT IS UP
TO THE PARTIES TO CREATE IS
THAT CORRECT EXACTLY ANNA AS
THE ANALYSIS SUGGESTED COULD BE
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS AN
AFFIRMATIVE OPT IN BY THE
RESTAURANT IN AN EMAIL OKAY
THAT IS HELPFUL THE OTHER. FOOD
FACILITY IS DEFINED IN STATUTE.
I BELIEVE SUPERMARKET IS AS
WELL THIS ONLY PERTAINS TO
RESTAURANTS AT THE STATE THIS
PERTAINS TO FOOD FACILITIES SO
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE THE LINES ARE BLURRED
HONOR IF YOU GO TO MY LOCAL
SUPERMARKET YOU SEE THAT THEY
ALSO SERVE HALF INCH SECTION.
FOR HOT FOOD HOT FOOD
DELIVERIES I THINK IT WOULD
THAT BE CONFUSING FOR US TO
START PICKING CHOOSING WHAT
FOODS FACILITY IS AN OBVIOUS
BONDS AS- IN A THEIR DEFINITION
RIGHT NOW. SO SIMP IT YOU KNOW
THE SERVICES YOU YOU HAVE THE
SAME PROBLEM BY THE WAY WITH
WITH THAT SUPERMARKETS WHO ALSO
HAVE DELIVERY ASPECTS IN IT IS
DEALING WITH THE SITUATION AS
WELL SAM. JUST REQUIRES AN OPT
IN I MEAN IT'S NOT A- IT'S NOT
ONEROUS- SITUATION AND MOST.
BIG COMPANIES. RT HAVE CAUGHT
PLACE. THE IS COLLECTION IS A
FOOD FACILITY IS TO FIND. BUT
ELSEWHERE IN THE CODE
SUPERMARKETS ARE DEFINED
ELSEWHERE. IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING I DON'T THINK WE
SAID WE- NOT THEY'RE TAUGHT IN
YOUR BILL L. WOULD HAVE TO GO
BACK AND CHECK TO BE HONEST BUT
I DIDN'T HAVE AN INTENTION OF.
DEFINING ARE SEPARATING THE BUT
I CAN GO BACK AND I'LL CHECK ON
THAT I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE A
DEFINITION FOR ME I THINK THAT
WAS THAT WAS MY ONLY CONCERN IS
THAT. IT BROAD WITH THIS GOING.
BY THE RESTAURANTS I'M ALL IN
ABSOLUTELY ALL AND I'M LOOKING
TURN ABOUT SUPERMARKET ANGLE- I
THINK THE OPTING IN. IS NOT A
BAD THING I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
THAT IS A SMART THING TO DO AND
IT ALLOWS FOLKS JUST TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING THEMSELVES
INTO AND- CREATES THAT
RELATIONSHIP. BUT I GUESS- I DO.
M.'S REALLY GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY BUT- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT. YOU ADD
CLARIFICATION WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BACK DOOR. THAT
SUPERMARKETS ARE NOT INCLUDED
UNDER THE DEFINITION OF FOOD
FACILITY. I WILL I WILL CHECK
ON THAT THANK YOU I WAS NOT
ATTEMPTING TO DEFINE FOOD
FACILITY SO. THIS. THANK YOU IS
RUNNING FOR ANYTHING ELSE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION WAS OUR MOTION
MADE BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY. I
THINK. IF YOU GO TO PAGE SEVEN
OF THE ANALYSIS THERE IS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE FOOD
FACILITY ISN'T GOING FORWARD
SUGGESTING TO THE AUTHOR THAT
SHE MAKE SURE THIS DEFINITION.
IS CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
EXPECTATIONS. HI FORGET OKAY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD THINK
ILL- OBVIOUSLY COVERED RELATED
I WILL GET AN ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND THEN WE MAY LIKE
THE OUTCOME OF WILL DEFINITELY
GET UNANSWERED. IN ALL HONESTY
I DO. END BECAUSE I'VE NOW FELT.
SO IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IF I CAN
EVEN SAY THAT MY LIFE SO I WANT
TO END WITH THIS WEEK YES
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION SHOULD
SPEAK FOR ASTRONAUTS JUST LIKE
UNIONS AND WORKER ADVOCATES
SHOULD SPEAK FOR WORKERS. IN
TECH MAKES IT SPEAKS FOR THE
PLATFORM COMPANIES THAT THEY'RE
SPEAKING FOR AND IF WE JUST
ABIDED BY THOSE RIPPLES IN ALL
OF OUR DISCUSSIONS I THINK WE
GET A LOT MORE DONE AND HAVE A
LOT FOR YOUR- WITH THAT. I AM
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR AN. THE
ROUTE IS THE WAY TO GO AND SO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK YOUR STATS HARD WORK ON
THIS. THANK YOU IN WITH THAT.
MOTION TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
MADAM. THE CONSULTANT WOULD YOU
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL-
SENATORS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON THIS IS FILE
ITEM. THREE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SEN HI
JACKSON HI BURGESS HI BRIDGES I
DID ALSO HI GET US SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
MELINDA'S. MORNING STERN
CAROLINE STERN I AM BURKE HI
BERG I WAKE CAL SKI BY. I SEVEN
TWO ZERO AND TWO ARE MISSING SO
WORLD YES WILL WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AND NOW FOR OUR GRAND
FINALE. THIS IS OUR LAST
BUILDING ANOTHER HUMDINGER. OF
THIS CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHT THIS IS AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE- AND- THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE ON PAGES
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE COMMON
SEVEN ARETHOSE GOING TO BE
TAKEN NOW OR- DOES IT I AM
HAPPY TO THE MOMENTS GREAT VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT SALUTE STONE
PLEASE FEEL FREE. THANK YOU
SENATORS I HOPE MEASURE ONE
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR AN
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS. THE BILL IS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY SIMPLE BUT THE
CONCEPTS ARE NOT AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT STRICT LIABILITY. IN
THE PRODUCT DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS
SITUATION BLOG GOES BACK A
NUMBER OF YEARS GOES BACK
DECADES AND HAS REALLY BEEN
FAIRLY CLEAR AND SETS UP
STANDARDS THAT COMPANIES HAVE
OPERATED BY AND THRIVE BY. FOR
THOSE DECADES INSTRUCTABLE E.
WAS USED AND THE NOTION IS TO
ENSURE. THAT WHEN A PRODUCT IS
SOLD IN THE CALIFORNIA AND
SOMEONE IS INJURED. BUT THERE
IS A REMEDY. BUT IN THE CURRENT
SITUATION WITH ONLINE RETAILERS
THESE MARKET PLACES THAT GET
CREATED THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO BLUR THOSE LINES. SO THAT
THEY ARE NOT ACCEPTING THE SAME
LEVEL OF LIABILITY THAT BRICK
AND MORTAR. COMPANIES TO COME
INTO OUR EXISTING. WHO HAVE OR-
HAVE A SIDE CUSTOMERS GO TO
THEM AND EXPECT TO BE PROTECTED
FROM DANGEROUS PRODUCTS. SOTHE
IN THE SITUATION OF THESE
ONLINE MARKETPLACES BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH THAT LIABILITY
AND IN FACT. HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE AGAINST
THE BRICK AND MORTAR THE LOCAL
STORES IN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEY THEN OR OR EGGS EXERCISING
THAT ADVANTAGE IN IN REALLY
LEAVING CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. IN THE LURCH SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST
TO CREATE. ONLINE MARKETPLACES.
TO RETAILERS AND RETAILERS WHO
CARRY THAT LIABILITY AS
RETAILERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COURTS HAVE
BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT WOULD THAT
THAT STRICT LIABILITY IS A PRE
HERE TO ENSURE THAT IT INJURED
HAS AN APPROPRIATE REMEDY. AND
THAT RETAILER THEN ALSO HAS
RECOURSE KIND OF UP THAT CHAIN
OF DISTRIBUTION. SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO CREATE THE SAME
SITUATION AND ENSURE THAT WE
THEN HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY SO
THAT AS NEW BUSINESS MODELS
COME OUT. THIS IS STANDARD
STILL CAN BE ADOPTED IN SEEN BY
THE COURTS AND APPLIED BY THE
COURTS. IN CASES OF INJURIES.
THAT'S WHAT IT DOES IS IT
CREATES THESE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO BRICK AND
MORTAR RETAILERS RETAILERS AS
FAR CALLS THEM. AND WE ALSO
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE SAME.
DEFENSES AS THE BRICK AND
MORTAR RETAILERS WOULD AS WELL
THERE'S A RECENT CASE ON POINT
AND THAT IS BOLGER VERSUS
AMAZON AND ONE THIS IS TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY. WITH THE
PLAINTIFF IN THAT CASE AND IN
ORDER TO REDRESS HER INJURIES
HAD TO TAKE IT TO COURT. AND WE
ENDED UP WITH A- AN EXCELLENT
APPELLATE COURT DECISION JUST
LAST WEEK. WHERE SHE WANTS AND
SHE'S GONNA BE ONE OF THE
WITNESSES TODAY SO HER PAIN HER.
HAVING TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS BECOMES INSTRUCTIVE TO
US BUT NOW THE COURTS HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS ON SORT OF
CASE BY CASE BASIS AS THEY DO
SO IT IS TIME FOR. IT TO ACT.
AS THE TRANSLATOR CREATE STATUS
STATUE WE DO. TO BE SURE THAT
WITH THAT ANYONE WHO WAS
INJURED IN CALIFORNIA. HAS THE
ABILITY TO GO AFTER THE PARTIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR BRINGING THAT
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT INTO
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IT'S IN IN ITS
LANGUAGE FAIRLY SIMPLE BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND. THAT CONCEPT AND
THIS THIS WORRY ABOUT STRICT
LIABILITY CAN. CAN BE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO GET OUR HEADS
AROUND. BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE TODAY HE
WITNESSES I HAVE EARLY IN
TRENTON FROM THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEN AS I MENTIONED ANGELA
BOULDER WHO'S GRACIOUSLY AGREED
TO BE WITH US TODAY TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. POURTANT THIS
GROUP. FOR US CALIFORNIA TODAY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
PRIVATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- TWO WITNESSES A TOTAL OF
FOUR MINUTES SO- LET YOU FOLKS
DECIDE HOW YOU WANT TO DIVIDE
THAT UP. IN TRENTON AND ANGELA
BOLGER WHO'D LIKE TO GO FIRST
AND LET'S JUST TO CONFIRM THAT
THEY ARE ON THE LINE. DO WE
HAVE AMONG THE WITH THAT
AFTERNOON. VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT
AFTERNOON MEDICARE NUMBER HI I
ENTRAPMENT FOR CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA A PROUD
COACH MONSTER OF AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY TWO A LOT OF THE UFCW AND
THE TEAMSTERS. SB THIRTY TO
SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLY SAYS THAT IF
YOUR CALORIES THAT COULD BE
MADE AT HER COAT RATHER THAN
BRICK AND MORTAR ALL THE SAME
PRODUCT LIABILITY RULES THAT
APPLY TO TRADITIONALLY DOLLARS.
FIFTY OR THE FIVE G. AN ONLINE
RETAIL. THE BILL THE FACT OF IN
CAN SIMPLY BY SELLING ON LEGAL
PROTECTION ONLY BY FOR A- PLAY
FINE EXACTLY. NOTHING RENDON
CHARRED LIKE FEED MY TIME TO
ALL OF JR HELLO SHERIFF OUR OWN
THE DAY TO THAT THEY AND I'M
RIGHT AND ON THE ON MY RETAIL
MARC I THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK
YOU OF GO AHEAD. THROUGH THE
DURATION THREE MINUTES. BUT
AFTER CEMEX LEVEL GERMAN
LICENSE DMG AND FUTURE
TECHNICIAN AT UNIVERSITY OF
COLORADO HEALTH IN APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. EARLY IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE RESEARCH
SUGGESTING THAT MAYBE MEDICAL
CENTER AT NEW MEDICAL CENTER
SAN DIEGO. WHAT THE AMAZON CARD
AND BOB DOT COM MARKETPLACE
LOOKING FOR REPLACEMENT BATTERY
FOR MY HP LAPTOP AT HOME. I
FINAL GREAT REVIEWS SO I BOUGHT
IT. A FEW MONTHS LATER WAS JUST
BEFORE THANKSGIVING I WOULD
TELL ME TO MY LAPTOP AND
STARTED A CAREER DOWN RIGHT BUT
THAT ARE WORKING HERE. EUROPE
WORK COMING FROM AND- PUT IT
BACK OVER MY WHAT. IF SUDDENLY
EXPLODED LIKE A- BOMB. PLANING
MILL BATTERIES WENT EVERYWHERE
I. BET ON FIRE. FIRE LOOK WHAT
WAS KNOWN I GOT BED HELLO THIS
THIS IT WAS SO WHICH I EVEN
REALIZE I WAS BURNED. I THINK
WE MEMBERS UNIT RIGHT. IN
SEPTEMBER SURGERY MY IN MY WHEN
HE HAS BEEN WORKS HARD WAS THE-
YOUR- UNDERLYING MY HOSPITAL
BED AND- RUNNER TRAINING YOU
CAN WALK AGAIN. I VERY FIRST
TELL HER TO. ALL THE TIME. SUCH
A HORRIBLE. BUT NOW I. TO HELP
OTHER BORN BACK THROUGH
RECOVERY PROCESS. ONE I GOT
HOME FROM THE HOSPITAL I DEPEND
ON WALKER CRUTCHES TO GET
AROUND MY- I RETURN TO WORK IN
REPLY AND I'M FAMILY AND
FRIENDS ONE. PERCENT MY CHANGES
GROCERY ONE THREE TWO. EVERY.
AMAZON GIFT HYDROPONIC THEY
SELL. THREE DOT. I WANTED
SEVERAL AFTER MY EXPLOSION
AMAZON EMAIL ME FOR THE PRODUCT
YOU MAKE PREVENTIVE FOR HOW THE
OR NOT. EXPECTED REFUNDED ME
THAT SHOULDER THIRTY CAN ARE
ABOUT. WHICH KIND ABOUT NOT
YOURS IF YOU BOUGHT THEM WITH
WE'RE NOT. COMMITTED A STATE.
TO ACCEPT ANY RESPONSE INSTEAD
THEY TOLD ME TO GO OUT TO THE
CHINESE COMPANY THAT WAS THE-
BUT NOT EVEN AMAZON TO FIND
THAT TWENTY COMPANY AND GET
THEM TO RESPOND. CONSUMERS LIKE.
WE TRY LEAD PRODUCT BUYING FROM
E. COMMERCE GROCERY AND WHETHER
OR NOT. THESE COMPANIES AMAZON
WILL TAKE THE- FOR AND THAT HOW
TO US. ONE EXAMPLE TO COME LIKE
IT ALLOWED TO BE DEBATING THE
RESPONSE. FOR ALL I BILL.
PERFECT RUNS LIKE WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE. GOING TO HEAR
ABOUT THEM IN. WHEN YOU HOME
TODAY AND YOUR CHILD IN SCHOOL
WORKING OR LAPTOP. OR YOUR
IMPOSING EMAIL. TAKE A MOMENT
WELL I'M NOT THAT BATTERY
SUDDENLY EXPLODED. HOWEVER
THEIR Y. IN YOURS AND THEN ASK
YOURSELF YOU KNOW WHAT YOU JUST
FOR. WELL IT'S TOO LATE FOR ME
IT'S NOT TOO LATE YOU TO FIX
WALKED THIS NUMBER HAPPENED
ANYONE EVER AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR- ARE THERE. ARE OTHER BY
WILL HOLD LET'S GO AND OTHER
ANY OTHER WITH PEOPLE IN FORTY
OR THREE. WHO ARE HERE TO. ON
ON SOME OF THIS MISSION. BUT
SEEING ANY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
CHINO WHEN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
PHONES AND A MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO WE WILL BEGIN. HENLEY'S
ENJOYMENT PORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. WE
WILL FIRST START WITH NUMBER
TWENTY ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBER SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH SIX
WITNESS. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MEMBERS AT
THE GROUND UFCW LECTERN STATE
COUNCIL PRONTO THUNDER THAT THE
MEASURE AND STRONGLY SUPPORTING
HOPING THE STORY NEVER HAPPENED
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL AGAIN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH BEFORE FORGET TO
THANK MISS BOLGER FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO TESTIFY AND TO
RELIVE A VERY HORRIFIC
SITUATION WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIFYING.
WITH THAT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE NEXT TO BE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M JUST HELPING HIM OUT THERE
ARE THE CHILDREN THAT BECAUSE
THE INSTITUTE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF STANDING UNCLE OF LONG IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FELT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER TWENTY
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORE MONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
A NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SUSAN LITTLE WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I KNOW
GOOD TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE TO
JUST BE A MOMENT. I WILL NEXT
GO TO NUMBER TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE. AT THIS TIME OF NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR VERY GOOD-
WILL GO TO THE OPPOSITION MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE OPPOSITION
WILL BE REPRESENTED BY A
CHRISTMAS KELLY AND JOHN.
CAPITEC. I WAS TOLD TO BOTH
ONLINE BUT I DO SEE HERE AT
LEAST- I SEE BOTH OF YOU HERE
ALL RIGHT SO WHY DON'T YOU GO
AHEAD UP TO THE MICROPHONE YOU
HAVE FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN YOU.
OF NICE TO SEE WITNESSES IN
PERSON SO- FEEL FREE TO GO
AHEAD AND- YOU CAN SPLIT THE
FOUR MINUTES ANYWAY YOU CHOOSE
WITH THAT GO AHEAD KELLY TO
CAESAR. NICE TO SEE YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND IF I MAY BEFORE YOU
START YOUR- JOINT YOUR
COLLEAGUES NOW EIGHT A HALF
HOUR AGO TO SAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I HAVEN'T THE OFTEN
PERSUADED YOU TO SEE MY CLIENTS
POINT OF VIEW OVER THE YEARS
BUT YOU HAVE CERTAINLY HAD. AN
OPEN DOOR- AND I'VE ALWAYS
ENJOYED THE ENGAGEMENT THAT
WE'VE HAD ON ISSUES. SUCH AS
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO OVER YOUR
TERMS AND BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND I'VE
BEEN PRETTY OPPORTUNITY AS
WELL. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WE ARE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONES BILL. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A LARGE
EXPANSION OF PRODUCT LIABILITY
LAW IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EXTENDING WELL BEYOND. THE
FRACTURED AND RETAILERS. IN
CAPTURING ONLINE MARKET PLACES.
WHICH IS A SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE
IN OUR PRODUCT LIABILITY LAWS.
I OBVIOUSLY AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO WOULD ADD A SIGNIFICANT
CODE SECTION TO OUR CALIFORNIA
CIVIL CODE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
THIS IS THIS WOULD BE A FIRST
IN THE NATION BILL I WOULD NOTE
FOR YOU THAT SEVERAL OTHER
STATE LEGISLATURES AROUND THE
COUNTRY HAVE CONSIDERED SIMILAR
BILLS ALL OF WHICH THEY HAVE
BEEN REJECTED SO FAR. A LOT OF
STATEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT- CONSUMERS CAN.
HAVE ANY FORM OF RECOURSE- I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SOME
ADDITIONAL FACT PATTERNS BEYOND
THE ONE THAT WE HEARD FROM THE
WITNESS IN THE BOLGER CASE. AND
I MEAN THAT THE BILL ITSELF
EVEN IN THE FINDINGS TALKS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A
POTENTIAL. OF FOR- PURSUING THE
COULD BE ACHIEVING. BAND THAT
LANGUAGE YOU KNOW DOESN'T GIVE
US CERTAINTY AS TO WHAT SORT OF
FACT PATTERNS WERE ACTUALLY
LOOKING TO ADDRESS. NOW ANOTHER
COMMON HAS BEEN MADE YOUR MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ABOUT
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD. WE
DON'T SEE THIS IS LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD WE THINK IN FACT
IT CREATES A DIFFERENT FIELD OF
PLAY. BECAUSE BY THIS EXAMPLE
UNDER EXISTING PRODUCT
LIABILITY LAW IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE CIVIL CODE- IT DOES PROVIDE
STRICTLY ABILITY FOR THE BRICK
AND MORTAR SHOPPING MALL.
HOWEVER THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE
STRICKLAND BILITY ON THE ONLINE
SHOPPING MALL WHICH DOESN'T
OCCUR EXCUSE ME I MISSPOKE IT
PROVIDES STRICT LIABILITY UNDER
EXISTING LAW FOR THE BRICK AND
MORTAR. MANUFACTURER RETAILER
BUT NOT THE BRICK AND MORTAR
SHOPPING MALL BUT UNDER AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO. THE ONLINE
MARKET PLACE THE ONLINE
SHOPPING MALL WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO IT. AND WHAT IS THE ULTIMATE
RESULT THE ULTIMATE RESULT IS.
THESE PRODUCT PROVIDERS THESE
WEBSITES THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
ARE ALL GOING TO BE SUBJECT-
SUBJECT TO STRICT LIABILITY AND
SUBSTANTIAL COSTS THERE'S GOING
TO BE A DIMINUTION IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSUMERS TO
PURCHASE PRODUCTS AND THOSE
THAT THEY DO AT A HIGHER PRICE.
LET ME CONCLUDE ON THIS POINT-
AND- IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE WHAT
HAPPENED. TO MISS BOLGER IN
THAT PARTICULAR CASE.
DISCRETION THAT THE JUDGES THE
COURTS HAVE TODAY DEMONSTRATES
THAT THERE IS RECOURSE UNDER
EXISTING LAW IN THIS CASE. AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS CASE IS LIKELY TO BE
APPEALED A PENNSYLVANIA STATE
COURT ACTUALLY MADE A SIMILAR
DECISION TO BOLGER IT WAS
REVERSED ON APPEAL AND YOU KNOW
MADAM CHAIR THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS OVER THE YEARS
REGARDLESS OF SUBJECT MATTER
BEEN VERY RELUCTANT TO STEP
INTO PENDING LITIGATION. BUT
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO DOES TAKE A
SIDE IN THIS TYPE OF LITIGATION
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL
HELD LET'S SEE HOW THIS
LITIGATION PLAYS OUT- FURTHER
ALONG THE LINES AND THEN
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN DECIDE
WHETHER IT THE CIVIL CODE NEEDS
TO BE AMENDED IN ANYWAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY YOU STEP THREE
MINUTES AND FORTY SECONDS. IF
YOU WILL IT WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE EXTRA BECAUSE THIS IS
PROBABLY THE LAST TIME YOU'RE
GOING TO BE A TESTIFYING IN ONE
OF MY COMMITTEE SO I WILL USE
MY- CHAIR PRIVILEGE GO AHEAD MR
CAPITEC GIVE HIM. IT IT. IS
GOING TO OKAY THANK YOU MANAGER.
MY NAME'S JOHN CABOT ON THE
CALL STATE. THE NOW FOR THE OF
THE BUSINESS THE STATE'S
LEADING SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION HERE- TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED EIGHTY
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO. THE BILL
WILL HAVE A SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES ON SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AS YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE NUMBER ONE
JOB CREATORS THEY ARE VERY
FRAGILE. MORE FRAGILE THAN EVER
BEFORE. OUR RECENT SURVEYS HAVE
SHOWN THAT IF THINGS DON'T
IMPROVE SOON UPWARDS OF 50% OF
SMALL BUSINESSES MAY BE FORCED
TO CLOSE. FOR MANY DEVASTATED
EMPLOYERS ONLINE COMMERCE HAS
BEEN THEIR ONLY LIFELINE IS
VITAL IS MORE MORE BRICK AND
MORTAR BUSINESSES HAVE TURNED
TO ONLINE VENUES TO SELL THEIR
GOODS AND SERVICES. IN A SAFE
WAY. SMALL BUSINESSES RIGHT NOW
DON'T HAVE THE CAPITAL TO
CREATE THEIR OWN WEBSITES. AND
YOUR COLLEAGUE SENATOR COMING
YEAR LISTED AT AN UPDATE TO THE
ACCOUNT. MATTERS HAVING ACCESS
TO ALL. COULD BE. CAN HAVE TO
CLOSE YOUR SHOP. EIGHTY THREE
TO SIXTY TWO CUT OFF THAT LIE.
CREE HUGE BATTERIES A ENTRY.
FOR THOSE ALL STRUGGLE SMALL
DOES. THE WILL BE A REAL PAID
PRICE. SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
WANT TO CONTINUE TO SELL ONLINE
WILL BE FORCED TO INVEST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. TO COME
THROUGH- EACH YEAR TO ON ON
COMPLEX NEW PLATFORMS THANK YOU
AND IT INCREASES LIABILITY ON
ALL MARKET PLACE THEY CAN
MISTER CRADDICK WE DO IT YOU'RE
A- COP. I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
THANKSGIVING WITH YOU AND YOUR
BROTHER. ARE INTERESTING
CONVERSATION. SINCE THE TWO OF
YOU ARE PROBABLY DIAMETRICALLY
OPPOSED ON THESE ISSUES BUT-
ALWAYS NICE TO HAVE YOU HERE
GOOD TO SEE YOU SIR. USUALLY IT
IS HOUSE THERE'S LOTS OF VODKA.
I AGREE TO MAKE. WE WISH YOU
WELL THANK. ALL RIGHT. WHEN A
LITTLE OVERBOARD THERE- WILL
GIVE A- CHANCE TO. RESPOND
PERHAPS I WOULD ASK MS TRACK
AND STAY ON THE LINE IN CASE OF
ANY QUESTIONS- FOR HER AS WELL.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE PHONE LINES A MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO. TESTIFY
NAME ASSOCIATION- OR
AFFILIATION AND THERE ARE OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO WILL GIVE
YOU MOMENT- DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE LINE MODERATOR. PLEASE
JOIN HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ONE ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT NOW WE ABOUT
TEN IN Q. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
LET'S GO AHEAD- NAME
AFFILIATION IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AMY MINOR ON BEHALF
OF EBAY WE ARE OPPOSED TO LET
THE MEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT WITNESS. YEAH YOU
HAVE AN EXTRA TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GAIL BELL HANNAH WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WILL
NOW GO TO NUMBER TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS CAN TO MAKE SURE THE
TECH THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DRESSES ARE
WITH UNTIL CANNELLA LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
WITH A TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARKET COLLAPSING ABOUT
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND THEN LET YOU KNOW
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THAT SOUNDS FAMILIAR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT TO A NUMBER TWENTY NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELP WITH
THE CIVIL GENTRIFICATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING ABOUT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. UNEXPLODED
TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT WOULD TEACHER
GARCIA WITH A CALIFORNIA GROUP
ASSOCIATION OFTEN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE NEXUS
NUMBER TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T OFTEN
WITH THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT WE ARE THE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GOOD. CARL ZERO VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
BE A CHOICE ALSO ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR AT GEORGE MASON LAW
SCHOOL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT IS TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS FOR
A MOMENT WITH TH CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE YOU
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT WE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE BURR ON BEHALF OF THE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WELL ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MANAGER. ALL
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT A COUPLE. COUPLE THOUGHTS.
TO BE CLEAR THIS THIS BILL
PLACES ONLINE MARKET PLACES ON
EQUAL FOOTING WITH THEIR BRICK
AND MORTAR COUNTERPARTS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF THIRD
PARTY SALES THAT'S WHAT IT DOES
WE HAVE THIS HOME THE MARKET
PLACE BASICALLY UNREGULATED-
AND THIS IS A BILL THAT JUST
SIMPLY SAYS WE ARE GOING TO
COMPARE YOU WE'RE GOING TO WIN
AN ANALOGY WHICH YOU TO A
MARKET PLACE- AND- THE NOTION
THAT. THIS IS NOT THE SAME AS A
SHOPPING MALL THE COURT IN THE
BOLGER CASE WHICH JUST CAME OUT
ABOUT A WEEK AGO. REJECTED THE
COMPARISON TO A SHOPPING MALL
IT'S NOT. IT SHOULD RATHER
INACCURATE OF COMPARISON HE'S
OUR ONLINE ONLINE MARKETPLACES
AND THEY ARE- IF THIS BILL
PROCEEDS JUST SIMPLY GOING TO
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE SAME
GUIDELINES AND PROVIDE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS- THE BRICK AND
MORTAR COMPANIES NOT NO MORE NO
LESS AS I UNDERSTAND IT SO. THE
BILL ALSO EXEMPTS THINGS LIKE
USED AUCTIONED ARE HANDMADE
GOODS UNLESS THE PRINCIPLES OF
STRICT LIABILITY WOULD
OTHERWISE APPLY IT EXEMPTS
PRODUCTS THAT WERE NOT SOLD ON
COMMISSION SUCH AS
ADVERTISEMENTS AGAIN IT IS.
DESIGNED TO WORK GOLD PARALLEL
TO BE A PARALLEL SET OF
PROVISIONS FOR ON THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE AS WE HAVE IN THE
BRICK AND MORTAR MARKET PLACE
SO. IT DOESN'T APPLY WHEN THE
COMPENSATION IS JUST AN
ADVERTISING FEE WHICH IT
DOESN'T TO IN THE NORMAL COURSE
OF COMMERCE. I CRAIGSLIST
CRAIGSLIST INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
I JUST LEARNED ACTUALLY-
CHARGES AN ADVERTISING FEE AND
YOU SELL YOUR PRODUCT THERE AND
THEY MAKE NO REPRESENTATIONS
THEY DON'T PRETEND THAT THEY
KNOW WHAT THE PRODUCT IS AND
THEY DON'T BENEFIT FROM THE
SALE. THEY BENEFIT FROM THE
ADVERTISING THAT WOULD APPLY
HERE AS WELL. AND IT TO THE
BOTTOM LINE IT IT JUST ENSURES
THAT THE BILL'S APPLICATION
REMAINS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRINCIPLES UNDERLYING STRICT
LIABILITY CAN WHY DO WE HAVE
STRICT LIABILITY BECAUSE WE
WANT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC IN
THE CONSUMER- TO ENHANCE SAFETY
AND PROTECT THE INJURED PARTY
THE STORE THAT THAT WOMAN A
SHARED WITH US- IT REQUIRED
LAWSUIT BECAUSE AMAZON SO WE'RE
NOT RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE THE
COMPANY THAT CREATED THE DEVICE
THAT WAS- A POORLY CRAFTED IN
ALWAYS PROBABLY SOMEWHERE IN
CHINA THAT. IT WAS BEYOND
REACH- BUT THE FACT THAT AMAZON
HAS BEEN KNOWN TO AND I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE NUMBER THOUSANDS
OF PRODUCTS THAT HAVE KNOWN
DEFECTS WITHOUT ANY ANY SENSE
OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE SALE
OF THOSE PRODUCTS BUT THEY
BENEFIT FROM THE SALE AND AGAIN
THIS JUST PUTS THIS ON THE SAME
FOOTING WITH OUR BRICK AND
MORTAR BUSINESSES SO- THERE
SUCH MORE I COULD SAY BUT WE
HAVE A VERY COMPETENT AUTHOR
HERE WHO CAN SPEAK FOR HIMSELF
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER.
CONCERNS AND- WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR MORNING AND THEN
SENATOR BORCHERS. THE YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU I'M SORRY I
MISSED THE AUTHORS INTRODUCTION
OF THE BILL THAT I HAVE READ
THE ANALYSIS AND- JUST CURIOUS.
HAS THIS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN
ANY OTHER STATE TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE. TO MY KNOWLEDGE NO
THIS IS WOULD BE A FIRST I
THINK OTHER STATES HAVE LOOKED
AT THIS AND THURMOND. DIFFERENT
CASES IN THE COURTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY BUT BUT NOT ANY
CONSISTENT POLICY THREAT SO I
WOULD ASSUME AS USUAL IN THIS
AREA THAT A LOT OF STATES WILL
BE WATCHING TO SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIA DOES. AND ONCE WE
CAN GET THIS PAST THEN I THINK
OTHERS WILL TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
MODEL AND FOLLOW SUIT THANK YOU
CAN I WOULD JUST COMMENT IT WAS
POINTED OUT THAT MOTHERS ACTIVE
LITIGATION AND SHOULDN'T WE
WAIT I THINK ONE OF THE RULES
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS TO DEFINE
POLICY. WHERE THERE MAY BE
CONFUSION IN THE MARKETPLACE-
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BENEFITS HERE AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR I THINK THE CHAIR JUST
CLARIFY THIS IS WELL. A
PLATFORM THAT CONNECTS BUYER
AND THE SELLER. SUCH AS AN EBAY
EXAMPLE- THEY AREN'T COVERED BY
THIS BILL OR THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THEY ARE.
BUT THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THEY WILL BE SO WE
TRADITIONALLY THINK OF. EBAY AS
JUST AN AUCTION SITE WE
TRADITIONALLY THINK OF AT SEA.
AS JUST CONNECTING. MY MOTHER
WHO MAKES FELTED BOOTIES AND
PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO BUY
THOSE HOWEVER. THE BUSINESS
MODEL THAT THEY ARE MORE AND
MORE MOVING INTO IS THEY ARE.
BRINGING IN BRAND NEW PRODUCTS
AND SEEKING SUPPLIERS AROUND
THE WORLD SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY FUNCTION. LIKE ANY BASE
CASE AN AUCTION HOUSE OR
ENTITIES CASE JUST FACILITATING
THE MOVEMENT OF HANDMADE GOODS.
THOSE TRANSACTIONS WOULD NOT
APPLY HERE BUT WHERE THEY ARE
ACTING. LIKE AN AMAZON DOES
FACILITATING THE DISTRIBUTION
INTO CALIFORNIA OF GOODS THAT
ARE POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS YES
IT WOULD APPLY TO THEM THANK
YOU IN I GUESS. THE SAME WITH
THE CRAIGSLIST EXAMPLE THAT
SOME BOOKS THIS IS VIA IS AS
WELCOMING ONLINE CLASSIFIED AD
RIGHT SITUATION AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO EXEMPT THOSE KINDS OF
TRANSACTIONS WITH THEIR THE-OPTIONS THE CLASSIFIED ADS IN
THE OTHERS IN FACT WE'VE TAKEN
AND- TAKING AN AMENDMENT. THAT
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT ADVERTISING
IS NOT RECEIVING BENEFIT
BECAUSE THAT RECEIPT THE
BENEFIT IS A TERM OF ART THAT'S
BEEN USED IN A LOT OF THESE
CASES GOING BACK FOR DECADES.
IT'S AN AMENDMENT THAT WAS
ASKED FOR BY I BELIEVE FACEBOOK
BUT ONE THAT TO ME MAKES ACTION
MAKES NO SENSE BECAUSE WHAT IF
THINGS WERE TRYING TO DO IS
EQUATE. THESE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES WITH A BRICK AND
MORTAR AND NOBODY. WHATEVER
SUGGEST THAT IF FACEBOOK PUT UP
AN AD FOR A NEWSPAPER PUT UP AN
AD OR A MAGAZINE PUT UP AN AD
FOR. A WALMART AND A PRODUCT
THAT'S BEING SOLD THERE THAT
THE FACT THAT THEY TOOK THE AD
REVENUE WOULD MAKE THEM LIABLE
UNDER STRICT LIABILITY THEY'RE
NOT A RETAILER AS THE COURTS
HAVE DEFINED SO WE'RE WE'RE
STARTING IN IN IS WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT THIS MEANS WE'RE STARTING
TO STEP INTO AREAS THAT THAT
ARE NOT NECESSARILY THAT
HELPFUL BECAUSE AN ADVERTISER
IN THE BRICK AND MORTAR CASE
WOULD NEVER BE. BROUGHT IN. AS
IN THAT SENSE AS AS A PARTY FOR
STRICT LIABILITY CASE. IT WOULD
BE THE- RETAILER SO. WHAT
THINGS WERE TRYING TO DO IN
THIS BILL IS QUITE THE ONLINE
MARKET PLACES IN THE BRICK AND
MORTAR. AS MUCH AS WE CAN. AND
NOT CREATE ADDITIONAL KIND OF
EXEMPTIONS AND LANGUAGE AROUND
THIS A MAN JUST. GIVEN THE
SAUSAGE MAKING THAT WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH. WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AS MANY OF THE CONCERNS
AS WE CAN BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT CREATING
THESE OTHER CATEGORIES. AND MY
WORRY IS THAT IF WE DO THEN
WHEN NEW TECHNOLOGIES COME
ONLINE IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE COURTS OR FOR
THE LEGISLATURE. TO SORT OUT.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT NEW.
BUSINESS MODEL WAS INTENDED TO
BE COVERED HERE SO THE MORE
WE'RE SAYING IF YOU'RE
FUNCTIONING ONLINE FOR YOUR
FUNCTIONING BRICK AND MORTAR
AND YOU ARE THAT RETAILER AND A
CONDUIT FOR THAT PRODUCT BEING
DELIVERED TO. A CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN AND A CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN GETS INJURED STRICT
LIABILITY WILL BE ATTACHED SO
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP IT
LITERALLY THAT SIMPLE BUT IT'S
THE OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A COMPLEX
WORLD AND TRYING TO MANAGE ALL
OF THE- CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BROUGHT TO US SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO PARSE SOME OF THAT
OUT WELL I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
THOSE DETAILS. THANK THE CHAIR
COMMENTED EARLIER WERE OFTEN
PLAYING CATCH UP IN TERMS OF
THE WORLD OF TECHNOLOGY MOVING
FORWARD AND NEW PLATFORMS NEW
METHODS OF MARKETING PRODUCTS.
OUR OLD BRICK AND MORTAR LAWS
DON'T ALWAYS CATCH UP OR DON'T
ALWAYS SUPPLY I THINK THE
AMAZON EXAMPLES. OF PEOPLE HARM
TO BUYING THE PRODUCTS THEY BUY
THROUGH AMAZON AMAZON IS THE
SELLER EVEN IF THEY'VE BOUGHT
IT FROM A MANUFACTURER- IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE TO ME THAT. THE CONSUMER
SHOULD HAVE THAT REMEDY AND
THAT JUST BECAUSE IT WAS SOLD
BY. A SELLER WHO ALSO SELLS THE
THEIR PRODUCTS NOW THAT THEY
ARE THE VENDOR OF THE PRODUCT
ONLINE THAT THEY SHOULD SOMEHOW
BE EXEMPT FROM. THE PROTECTIONS
THAT CONSUMERS FACE IF THEY
BOUGHT THE SAME PRODUCT WALKING
INTO A BRICK AND MORTAR. RETAIL
UNITS SO- MY PREACHING OR WORK
ON THIS MADAM CHAIRMAN THAT
DIDN'T MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SENATOR
BORCHERS. THANK YOU. I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. THIS ISSUE ON A
COUPLE LEVELS WE DISCUSSED. A
COUPLE ISSUES PRIOR WHETHER OR
NOT THIS HAD- IN ADEQUATELY
COVERED CONNECTION. AND IT IS
IT IS IT WILL TAKE A DRINK. I'M
SORRY THAT WE WILL TAKE A DRINK
YES EXACTLY HA HA HA. AND IT'S
FUNNY ENOUGH I THINK THIS HAS-
IN ANCILLARY CONNECTION BUT
IT'S NOT ONE THAT I THINK IS
HELPFUL. IS THAT EARLIER WE
WERE DISCUSSING ON HOW WE
PROTECT HOUSES FROM BEING
FORECLOSED UPON. PROTECTING
RENTERS IN MAKING EMERGENCY
ALLOWANCES FOR HIS
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES. AND SO I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HERE IS.
ATTACHING STRICTLY ABILITY TO A
BUSINESS FOR EXAMPLE THAT MAYBE
HAD BRICK AND MORTAR ON MONDAY.
SHUT DOWN. IT IS NOW SURVIVING
WITH ONLINE SALES. I CAN I CAN
IMAGINE THAT THE MARKETPLACE IS
JUST FULL OF THESE INSTANCES
WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE TRYING TO
SURVIVE THIS PANDEMIC. AND BY
ADDING IN THE STRICTLY ABILITY
COMPONENT. NOT ONLY DOES OUR
BUSINESS MODEL GO COULD GO
SIDEWAYS I SUPPOSE THERE ARE
OVERHEAD IN INSURANCE
EXPECTATION WILL TAKE THEM
SIDEWAYS AS WELL. IS THIS NOT
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THIS TO
COME BACK IN JANUARY. NO SENATE
BECAUSE I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE
IT IS AND I WOULD ARGUE IT IS
RESPECTFULLY ONLY BECAUSE WE
LITERALLY SPENT FIVE AND A HALF
HOURS. DECLARING HOW IMPORTANT
IS WAS TO MAKE EMERGENCY
ALLOWANCES FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE T. TO LOOK
AFTER THEIR FAMILY AND STAY IN
THEIR HOMES. THIS IS NOW TAKING
THE LIVELIHOOD OF SO MANY SMALL
MOM AND POP OPERATIONS THAT ARE
RELYING ON ONLINE SALES SINGLE
MOMS. FRIENDLIES IN IS ADDING A
STRICT LIABILITY COMPONENT.
THAT I THINK YOU COULD PRETTY
MUCH DERAIL THE FUTURE OF THOSE
SMALL OPERATIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE WILLING
TO TAKE ON THOSE LIABILITIES
BUT YOUR POINTS ARE. ABSOLUTELY
ON THE MONEY I THINK WE GET A
BUNCH OF CRAP FROM OVERSEAS.
THAT'S EITHER FRAUDULENT POORLY
MADE AND FIGHTS BROUGHT INTO
THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT A CLEAR
NEXUS OF WHO IS BEHIND IT
PEOPLE IN AMERICA GET HURT.
THERE'S NO ONE BUT A PO BOX IN
AN EMAIL ADDRESS OUTSIDE OF
BEIJING. THAT'S A PROBLEM. MY
ISSUE IS TIMING. SHOULDN'T THIS
WAIT UNTIL JANUARY AND GO
THROUGH THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE
CYCLEBECAUSE IN THIS EMERGENCY
CONTACTS I THINK THIS WOULD
ONLY HURT US EVEN THOUGH I
THINK YOUR POINTS HAVE SOME
MERIT DOWN THE ROAD AND THAT'S
WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THIS BE BROUGHT BACK THANK YOU
SO NOTED LET ME LET ME. IF YOU
WANNA OPEN FOR IF YOU WANT TO
RESPOND BRIEFLY THE BILLS
BEFORE US IT'S BEEN WELL
DISCUSSED IT'S GOT AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
IT EITHER WE'RE GOING OF ALL
FORTY THE MOVE IT FORWARD OR OR
NOT IT IS BEFORE US TODAY WE
WILL HEAR IT SO IF YOU WANT TO
JUST COMMENT BRIEFLY YOU CAN IF
YOU WANT WITH YOUR
INTELLIGENCE. BECAUSE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SOME THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENT.
MISPERCEIVED WHAT THE SENATE
BECAUSE THAT MOM AND POP. WHO
HAD A BRICK AND MORTAR. THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO STRICT LIABILITY AS
IT IS THE WORK THEY WORK NOW
THERE ARE THEY CREATING AN
ONLINE MARKETPLACE NO. THEY'RE
TRYING TO SELL THEIR PRODUCTS
THROUGH THE ONLINE MARKETPLACE
TO THAT EXTENT. SINCE THERE
WILL BE A RETAILER THEY STILL
KERRY THAT LIABILITY. SO LIKE
WE SHOP. YES BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO AN ONLINE
MARKETPLACE THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO CREATE THE MARKET PLACE
THEY'RE GONNA SELL IT THROUGH
AN AMAZON COURT AT C. OR AN
EBAY BECAUSE THE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY EXISTS.
SO IN THAT CASE. THIS IS
ACTUALLY MORE PROTECTIVE IN THE
REASON IT'S BALLOT NOW. IS
BECAUSE MORE MORE PEOPLE ARE IN
FACT SHOPPING ONLINE AND
GETTING PRODUCT FROM WHEREVER
AND- WITHOUT THE SAME
EXPECTATION OF SAFETY THAT THEY
WOULD IF THEY GO DOWN. TO THAT
BRICK AND MORTAR SHOP. SO THAT.
MOM AND POP DISTRIBUTOR WITH
THAT STORE IS GOING TO CARRY
THAT LIABILITY BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE RETAIL WHETHER THEY'RE
RETAILING ONLINE. FOR THEIR
RETAILING THROUGH THEIR BRICK
AND MORTAR EITHER GOING THROUGH
EBAY. NOT YET WELL BUT YOU
THINK THAT YES BECAUSE WHAT
EBAY WILL TELL YOU. IS DON'T
SUE US. SUE MOM AND POP. WHEN
EBAY IS BROKERING TO ME WHEN
THE WHEN THE MOM AND POP IS
BROKERING USING THE EBAY
PLATFORM THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE PROCURING PRODUCT
THEY'RE SELLING PRODUCTS USING
EBAY TO EFFECTUATE THAT AUCTION.
WELL IF IT'S AN OPTION WITH THE
AUCTIONS ARE ENSURED THAT THE
DIRECT SALE OF YOU CAN PURCHASE
IT NOW OR CHOOSE IT LATER SO
THINK ABOUT IT RIGHT THAT'S THE
SAME SITUATION THAT YOU
DESCRIBED ABOUT. CHINA THOSE
COMPANIES IN CHINA. DON'T HAVE
ANY LIABILITY BECAUSE THERE.
ACTUALLY JURISDICTION WE CAN'T
GET TO THEM. SO IF AND WHAT
AMAZON WOULD ARGUE SO IF MOM
POP. THEIR PRODUCT UP TO SAIL.
THROUGH AMAZON AND THEIR
PRODUCT HARM SOMEBODY AMAZON'S
GONNA SAY DON'T TALK TO US
RIGHT WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO BECAUSE THEY ARE
THAT FACILITATOR. YOU GO AFTER
MOM AND POP IN THE CASE OF THE%
CHINESE COMPANY THAT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING BECAUSE THEIR EXPOSURE
SECTIONAL. BUT THAT'S A FALSE
PROMISE YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE
CREATING CONSUMER ADVOCACY
PULLED ON WE'RE NOT GOT WHAT
WHAT SHOP SESSION WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE A DEBATE HERE ON
THIS YOU CAN ASK A QUESTION.
THE MAJOR POINT. I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON AND WE HAVE SOME
MORE. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR DORADO. YEAH YOU KNOW
WE'VE JUST HAD TWO OTHER BILLS
COME BEFORE IS ALL RELATED TO
WHAT THE RULES ARE FOR ONLINE.
THE SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES AND
HOW OF ON LINE IS USED- IN THAT
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS ONLINE
IS USE FOR THAT- THERE IS WE
HAVE TO CATCH UP AT I MEAN IT'S
KIND OF EMBARRASSING THAT
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE NO ROLE
LIKE THIS HAS BEEN. PASSED
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO CATCH UP ON
IT'S THE SAME THING THE IMPACT
THAT ALL OF THESE COMPANIES ARE
HAVING ON CONSUMERS ON
EMPLOYEES. ON REVENUE OF TWO
GOVERNMENT IT KEEPS GOING ON
AND ON I MEAN AMAZON IS A
TRILLION DOLLAR COMPANY A
TRILLION DOLLAR COMPANY AND YOU
CAN'T USE THE FACE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES TO DEFEND THE
COMPANY THAT'S WORTH A TRILLION
DOLLARS SO I. I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE DONE I
APPRECIATE HOW- DETAILED YOUR
OF YOUR ANALYSIS AND BE ABLE TO
EXPLAIN THAT TO US BUT FROM A-
YOU KNOW BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
ALL THE DETAILS THE WAY THAT
YOU DO A STUDY IN THE WAY THIS
IS HOW I SEE IT SO. I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR BURKE. THANK YOU
MANAGER- A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR I APPRECIATE TO THE
GAME OF CATCH UP AS THE
TENDERIZER RIGHTLY NOTED- AND
TEMAS BOLGER- I WAS HEARTENED
TO SEE YOU GET SEVEN AT LEAST
THE BEGINNINGS OF REMEDY WILL
SEE WHAT'S APPEALED ON ON THE
CASE- BUT THAT WS IT- VERY
ENCOURAGING PRESS IN TO SEE THE
COURTS THEMSELVES BEGIN TO ACT
HERE. THE WAY I STARTED TO FIND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE TODAY- IS THAT THE COURTS
ACTUALLY HAVE STARTED TO MOVE
AT LEAST IN OUR JURISDICTION
TOWARDS A STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARDS FOR PRODUCTS THAT ARE
FURNISHED BY AMAZON OR UNDER
THAT SORT OF WAREHOUSING WITHIN
THE WAREHOUSING STREAM
BASICALLY BEING IN SOME KIND OF
FACILITY OR HAVING. SOME OTHER
CONTACTED IT SEEMS TO ME MAYBE
THE AUTHOR COULD CLEAR BUT
REALLY THE REMEDY THAT THAT IS
LACKING RIGHT NOW IS MORE FOR
THE KINDS OF PRODUCTS THAT
MAYBE DON'T GO THROUGH SAY AN
AMAZON WAREHOUSE BUT STILL HAVE
THAT. AMAZON BRAND OVER IT THAT
THAT SORT OF IMPLIED WARRANTY
OF YOU KNOW FITNESS- OR THOSE
SORT OF OTHER COMMON LAW THINGS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET
AROUND- AND I'M JUST WONDERING
YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN SORT OF
DESCRIBE I GUESS. WHAT THE
BOLGER CASE WHICH INTERESTINGLY
WAS JUST DECIDED WHAT A WEEK
AGO OR SO RIGHT ON THE EVE OF
HIS HEARING BUT WHAT WHAT THAT
COVERED BUT ALSO WHAT IT WHAT
IT DIDN'T COVER AND WHY WHAT
WHY YOU TO ARGUE FOR THIS BILL
IN IN LIGHT OF THAT CASE
ALREADY BEEN ON THE BOOKS.
RIGHT AND THAT'S A- THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION SAID. DE THE
BOLGER CASE WAS ABOUT THE
FULFILLED BY AMAZON CATEGORY OF
BUSINESS AN AMAZON. AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT ALL THAT CASE WAS
ABOUT THE REASON WE NEED TO
TAKE THE STEPS IS THE COURTS
ARE GOING TO STEP BY STEP LOOK
AT EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE WHICH
ARE GOING TO TRY TO BE
DISTINGUISHED. BY COMPANIES
LIKE AMAZON AND AMAZON IN ANY
WHEN YOU READ THE BOLGER CASE
AMAZON COMPARED ITSELF TO
SHOPPING MALL. TO CREDIT CARD
ISSUER TO A TRUCKING COMPANY TO
INTERNET SEARCH PROVIDER TO
NEWSPAPER RUNNING CLASSIFIED AS
THE THEY TRIED ALL THOSE
ARGUMENTS AND THE BOLGER COURT
REJECTED THEM OUT OF HAND. I
WON THE ARGUMENT SAID IT WAS A
BROUGHT UP WAS WAS IF YOU
PROVIDE LIABILITY HERE THEN YOU
COULD BE PROVIDING LIVE REALLY
TO ALL OF THOSE OTHER
CATEGORIES. AND IF A FOOTNOTE
COULD CHUCKLE THE FOOTNOTE
CHUCKLED SAID THE DISTANT
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THOSE ARE
VERY SIGNIFICANT. I'M IS WE
HAVE ONE CASE HERE THAT THIS IS
BENDIS DECLINE OR DECIDED THERE
WILL BE MANY MORE AND IN FACT
IN THAT CASE INTERESTINGLY
AMAZON CLAIMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE THE BEST.
WOULD BE BEST POSITION TO
ASSESS THE COVERING VEILING
POLICIES INCLUDING CONSUMER
INTEREST INDIAN PRODUCTS AND
ALL THAT SO AMAZON WAS ARGUING
THAT THEY SHOULD COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE COURT OF COURSE
WAS OFFENDED BY THAT. AND SAID
NO WE CAN DECIDE THIS JUST FIVE.
SO AMAZON WHAT IS TO COME
LEGISLATURE. IT'S IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND CAN I JUST A
FOLLOW UP THERE CAN I EAT YEAH
I DON'T KNOW VAN ZANDT ITSELF
WHAT HAS TESTIFIED HERE WERE IN
FOR A- IT'S MORE THE
ASSOCITION LEADING US AYE MR
MCCABE LEADER BUT- I'M
WONDERING WHAT WHY YOU THINK
THAT. CITY THAT THERE'S NOT
SUFFICIENT CONTROL FOR. THAT
SORT OF A SUBSTANTIAL ENOUGH
ROLE FOR THE AMAZONS OUT THERE
TO BE SUBJECT TO THIS KIND OF
LIABILITY LIKE WHY WHY THEY ARE
DIFFERENT FROM SAY- THE MOM AND
POP IS AS THE AUTHOR PUT IT
WELL YOU HAVE TO ASK I WAS ON
THAT QUESTION THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE ARGUING IS THAT THEY'RE
DIFFERENT AND STRICT LIABILITY
SHOULD ATTACKED. IF THEY SAID
YEAH WE'RE A RETAILER LIKE TO
STRICT LIABILITY LAWS DESCRIBE
WHICH WE THINK THEY ARE WE
WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION THEY ARE AND THEY
SHOULD BE THAT'S THE POINT OF
THIS BILL. WE BEEN TALKING
DEBTS EVEN TALKING EVEN WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO ANOTHER'S
AMAZON OFFERED US SOME
AMENDMENTS YESTERDAY
INTERESTINGLY THEY'RE CONCERNED
AT THIS IS TO NARROW AND THEY
ACTUALLY WANT US TO BROADEN IT
SO WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS. WERE THAT THEY
OFFERED I'M NOT SURE WE WANT TO
BROADEN THIS AT THIS POINT
WE'RE TRYING TO BE VERY CAREFUL
THAT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS.
ONLINE MARKETPLACE BRICK AND
MORTAR RETAILER. TREAT THEM THE
SAME AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
SAYS IF YOU'RE AN ONLINE
MARKETPLACE YOU ARE A RETAILER.
UNDER THE STRICT LIABILITY LAWS
AND HAVE THE SAME DEFENSES.
RIGHT AS A RETAILER. WOOD IN
THAT SAME CIRCUMSTANCE SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE TO A QUICK THOSE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
THESE LARGE COMPANIES THAT ARE
DOING THESE DISTRIBUTIONS THAT
ARE BRINGING IN FACT
RESPONSIBLE FOR BRINGING.
DANGEROUS PRODUCT INTO
CALIFORNIA. THAT WOULD HAVE
THAT THIS PRODUCT HAVE NO
AVENUE TO GET INTO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE NO BECAUSE OF THE
STRICT LIABILITY NO OTHER
RETAILER. WOULD BRING THEM IN
THEY HAVE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
THEY LIVE WITH THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR. DECADES
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT. SO NOW
BECAUSE UNDER THE GUISE OF
ONLINE MARKETPLACE. WE'RE
DIFFERENT WHICH THEY'RE NOT.
THEY NOW ARE INTRODUCING
DANGERS PRODUCT IN THE
CALIFORNIA. AND CALIFORNIANS
AND WHO WERE INJURED. HAVE NO
REMEDY THERE'S NO ABILITY TO GO
AFTER THE ORIGINAL MANUFACTURER
THROUGH THAT CHECK SO JUST LIKE
IN THE BRICK AND MORTAR. THEY
GO AFTER UNDER STRICT LIABILITY
THE RETAILER IN THIS CASE ON MY
MARKET PLACE WHO THEN HAS THE
ABILITY TO GO AFTER GO UP THAT
CHAIN. TO THE MANUFACTURER.
THAT'S WITH ASSISTING SO ARE
YOU CONCERNED AT ALL THOUGH
ABOUT LIKE LETTINGTHEM
MANUFACTURERS OFF THE HOOK SO
TO SPEAK THAT THAT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE PROPER INCENTIVES
HERE THEN TO FILL BECAUSE
THEY'RE BECAUSE THEY'RE LIABLE
TO THE RETAILER. RIGHT THAT'S
THE CHANGE RIGHT. EITHER IN
COUNTRY THEY'RE GONNA BE THANK
YOU THEY'RE OUT OF COUNTRY THEN
THAT YET THE CONSUMERS THE ONE
BEARING THE LOAD WHICH IS WHY.
WE ARE STRICTLY ABILITY POLICY
IN THE FIRST PLACE- YOU CANNOT
BE I APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE
HERE LOOK I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THE IT THERE IS SOME MURKINESS
TO ME IN THIS SPACE WHERE
THERE'S NO REAL- CONTROLLED AND
NOTHING'S REALLY IN THE
DISTRIBUTION CHANNEL FOR
INSTANCE FROM THE MARKET PLACE
I KNOW THAT THAT'S THE PARTS
THAT THE COURTS HAVEN'T REALLY
pSTEPPING IN HERE SO. I'M HOPING
YOU WE CAN JUST I WANNA TRY TO
GET A CLEAR PICTURE ON THAT
BEFORE THE FLOOR BUT I LOOK I
THINK THIS BILL ISN'T NECESSARY
RIGHT NOW I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT AT SOME
POINT STAND UP TO- YOU KNOW FOR
OUR MOM AND POP BUSINESSES AND
I SAW MISTER CAPITEC WE CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THESE- INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES OUT THERE FRANKLY
AND- I'M CONCERNED THAT WE'RE
BASICALLY PUTTING OUR
INDUSTRIES AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE AT THIS POINT IN
THIS COUNTRY. WHERE A CHINESE
MANUFACTURER CAN MAKE FAULTY
PRODUCT AND RUN OFF SCOT FREE
AT LEAST SOME OF THEM IS BOLGER
WITH THE LIABILITY AND THEN
MEANWHILE YOU KNOW WE START
MAKING BATTERIES EVER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HOPE WE DO-
YOU'RE DARN SURE WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE FOR THAT UNDER OUR STATE
LAW SO I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S A FEW REASONS TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND I APPRECIATE.
THE WORK TODAY THANK YOU
SENATOR IT AND POINT TO PAGE
NINE OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH
DESCRIBES SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS OF THE COURTS USE
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO DECIDE
WHO'S GOING TO HAVE STRICT
LIABILITY BECAUSE THERE ARE
DEFENSES THAT A RETAILER CAN
HAVE TO STRICTLY ABILITY
DEPENDING ON THE CONTEXT THAT
THEY HAPPENED AND THEIR ROLE IN
THAT PRODUCT MOVING. TO THE- TO
THE CONSUMER. SO ALL OF THAT'S
WHY THE STAFF. AND WE DON'T
WANT INTERFERE WITH THAT
BECAUSE THE COURTS WANT TO WE
THINK THE COURTS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO STILL USE THAT ANALYSIS
AND USE THOSE TERMS. AND APPLY
THEM SO ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
THAT ONLINE MARKETPLACE IS A
RETAILER. UNDER THIS EXISTING
CONTEXT AND AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER IF AMAZON DOES HAVE.
SOME LIABILITY NOW. THEY WILL
US AT LEAST WE ANTICIPATE
THEY'LL TAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESPONSIBILITY SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. THESE PROBLEMS HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND THEN. I
THINK THAT'S PART OF THE POLICY
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADVANCE
HERE WE HAVE A SENATOR ON BURKE
AND THEN I THINK WITHOUT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS WILL ASK YOU
TO CLOSE SENATOR UMBERG. OF
THANK YOU VENTURE OUT SO NUMBER
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INTERACTION WE'VE HAD ON THIS
MATTER I HAVE A QUESTION FOR IS
MR MCHALE LEAST THOUGH HE'S
HIDING THERE I SEE A MISSED
MAKAYLA OR MIST COVERED I HAVE
A- QUESTION CONCERNING
CHAINSAWS WHICHEVER. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT. SO
VETERANS OMINOUS RISING ONE OF
THEM ACTUALLY GOTTA TALK ABOUT
CHAIN SAWS SO IF I BUY A CHAIN
SAW ON AMAZON MANUFACTURED IN
CHINA WITHOUT ANY OTHER CONTEXT
UNITED STATES IN AND IT
MALFUNCTIONS A CHAIN BREAKS AND
HARMS ME WHAT WHAT'S MY
RECOURSE. WELL IS THERE ANY
DISPOSAL RIGHT MADAM CHAIR FIVE
YES PLEASE- IS THERE ANY
DISTINCTION BETWEEN A BRICK AND
MORTAR FACILITY VERSUS THE
ONLINE MARKET PLACE IN YOUR
EXAMPLE. NO OF MY EXAMPLE IS
I'M BUYING A CHAIN SAW FROM A
CHINESE MANUFACTURER THEY KNOW
THE CONTEXT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OTHER THAN THROUGH AMAZON WHAT
WHAT RECOURSE DO I HAVE IF IT
BREAKS. IF IT HARMS ME. HI I
DON'T KNOW THE REACH OF OUR
CURRENT LONG ARM STATUTE
WHETHER OR NOT CALIFORNIA COULD
GET JURISDICTION. OVER THAT
COMPANY IN CHINA OF COURSE IF
THEY IF THE CHINESE COMPANY
SOLD YOUR- A CHAIN SAW IN. AND
AMY'S OR SOMETHING OR A HOME
DEPOT. ARGUABLY IT WOULD BE THE
SAME ISSUE. WELL THAT IS TAKING
A VERY SYMPATHETIC WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I THINK THAT SB THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO IS TAKING A VERY.
EASY OUT. WHICH IS WHAT JUST
MAKE A MALL STRICTLY LIABLE.
BUT I'M NOT SURE BUT BUT BUT
YOU IT RECORDS YOU HAVE
RECOURSE AGAINST HOME DEPOT.
WITH WHEN I. WHEN AMAZON SELLS
CHAINSAWS ON LINE. OR OTHER
PRODUCTS ONLINE THAT ARE
MANUFACTURED IN A JURISDICTION
OUTSIDE THE REACH CALIFORNIA.
DO THEY INFORM THE CONSUMER
THAT IF THIS THING BREAKS IF MY
CHAINSAW BREAKS AND- HARMS ME.
I'LL HAVE VIRTUALLY NO RECOURSE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW AMAZON
OPERATES EXACTLY AND I DON'T
REPRESENT THEM THEY HAVE A
LOBBYIST OF THEIR OWN WHO COULD
PERHAPS ANSWER THAT I'M SORRY
I'M PICKING ON YOU I DON'T MEAN
TO PICK ON NO NOT AT ALL AYE
AYE AND IF THEY DO HAVE A
LOBBYIST THEIR OWN I SUSPECT
THEY COULD AFFORD TO HAVE THEM
HERE IN THE QUESTION THEN IS
WHY AREN'T THEY HERE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THIS
BILL. DOES MENTION THEM SEVERAL
TIMES FOR JUST THE REASON I
THINK THAT SENATOR UMBERG
MENTIONED IS THAT. THEY WOULD
THEY ARE LIKELY TO BE SELLING
THEIR CHAINSAW SO THE QUESTION
IS WHAT WOULD THEY WOULD THEY
HAVE ANY LIABILITY IN AND IF
THEY FEEL THAT THEY DON'T ON
WHAT BASIS DO THEY FEEL THEY
DON'T OR DO THEY INFORM THE
CONSUMER OR DO THEY INFORM TO
CONSULT THE- CONCERN THAT I
HAVE. IS THAT. IN THE BILL- AS
I UNDERSTAND SEWER STONE. YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CRAIGS LIST CROWD. IS NOT
CAPTURED BY THIS BILL WHERE YOU
HAVE DIRECT CONSUMER CONSUMER-
INTERACTION WHERE THE PLATFORM
MERE IT MERELY ACTS AS A
CONDUIT NOT. A OR A FACILITATOR
VERSUS AN AMAZON TYPE MODEL IF
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO IN ENSURE THAT
WHERE. A CRAIGSLIST WHICH ACTS
LIKE A CLASSIFIED AD SECTION
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF REVENUE
AS A NEWSPAPER WOULD WHEN THEY
DO CLASSIFIED ADS BUT THE
TRANSACTION THEN HAPPENS
HUNDRED PERCENT. OUTSIDE OF THE
SPHERE THEY DON'T CARE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY ROLE IN THAT.
THAT CLASSIFIED ADS TYPE
TRANSACTION WHICH DOES TEND TO
BE. SOME PEOPLE SELLING USED
PRODUCTS ARE HAVE TOO MANY
THINGS IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT MEANT
TO BE A MAJOR COMMERCIAL
DISTRIBUTION MECHANISM TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT BECOMES A MAJOR
COMMERCIAL DISTRIBUTION.
MECHANISM LIKE THE AT SEASON
EBAY'S HAVE BECOME BECAUSE
THEY'VE MOVED ON BEYOND THE
PURE AUCTION SITE AND IF YOU'RE
CRAFTING SITE. WHICH IS HOW
THEY STARTED THEN THEY COULD BE
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL HERE'S
HERE'S MY CONCERN IS BOTH FOR
THE COURTS AS WELL AS FOR.
SOMEONE WHO'S THINKING ABOUT
ENTERING THE SPACE IT IS THAT
IN OTHER IS THE LAW. WE HAVE
GUIDANCE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
WANT TO FORM. YOU CAN SEE HERE
HERE ARE THE FACTORS THE
COURT'S GOING TO LOOK AT TO SEE
WHETHER YOU'RE PROTECTED IF YOU
WANT TO MAINTAIN YOUR PRESENCE
OUTSIDE THE CALIFORNIA. TERMS A
MINIMUM CONTACTS HERE'S
BASICALLY THE CHECKLIST THAT
YOU CAN LOOK AT. SO IS YOU AND
I DISCUSSED I THINK IT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
GUIDANCE BOTH TO THE COURTS AS
WELL AS TO. POTENTIAL
ENTREPRENEURS WHO WENT INTO
THAT SPACE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU. ARE DONE NOT PROHIBITING
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN SELLER
AND BUYER. THAT WOULD BE ONE
FACTOR IF YOU ARE NOT PROVIDING
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION IF THE
IF THE EXCHANGE HAPPENS THROUGH
A THIRD PARTY VENDOR COMPLETELY
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER FACTOR IF
FOR EXAMPLE. YOU LIST THE
LOCATION N. DO DISCLOSE THE
CONSUMER THAT THAT YOU ARE
SIMPLY A CONDUIT THAT WOULD BE
ANOTHER FACTOR SO IF WE PROVIDE
FACTORS SO THAT THE CRAIGS LIST
AND- TO THE EXTENT THAT. THE
DEAD SEA IS WANTS TO MOVE BACK
INTO THE REALM WHERE THEY ARE
MORE CRAIG'S LIST D. VERSUS
MORE AMAZON E. THEY CAN DO THAT
THAT WE ACTUALLY GIVE SOME SORT
OF. GUIDANCE AND SO I KNOW YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT WORKING ON
THAT AND- YET WE TALKED ABOUT
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE. AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE JURISPRUDENCE
AROUND STRICT LIABILITY. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE BASE SUMMIT CASE
THE COURT SISTER CLUB BILLY
ALSO APPLIES WEARING NON
MANUFACTURING PARTY IS THE
VERDICT CHEYNA DISTRIBUTION. OF
THE PRODUCT PLAYS AN INTEGRAL
ROLE IN THE PRODUCING AND
MARKETING ENTERPRISE OF A
DEFECTIVE PRODUCT AND PROFITS
FROM THE PLACING OF THE PRODUCT
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE. SO IN A
LOT OF THE STATEMENTS IN THE
JURISPRUDENCE IN THE VARIOUS
CASES THERE ARE EXACTLY THOSE
TESTS. I WORRY ABOUT. CREATING
BECAUSE IT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO CREATE THESE DISTINCTIONS
AROUND ONLINE MARKETPLACES
BECAUSE THEN THE NEXT TYPE OF
BUSINESS MODEL THAT COMES UP
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO CREATE A
NEW SET OF LISTS FOR THEM I
THINK WE CAN RELIABLY RELY ON
WHAT THE COURTS HAVE DONE IN
THE JURISPRUDENCE AROUND STRICT
LIABILITY AND BY SAYING IF YOU
ARE BRINGING THE PRODUCT INTO
CALIFORNIA FACILITATING THAT
BRING THAT PRODUCT TO THE
CALIFORNIA. BY THESE EXISTING
STANDARDS YOUR RETAILER AND
WHEN YOU'RE A RETAILER WE KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS AND- BY THE WAY
BEING A RETAILER UNDER STRICT
LIABILITY HAS SEVERAL DEFENSES
TO IT THAT THAT RETAILER CAN
BRING UP AND SAY YOU CAN'T
TREAT I DON'T GET STRICT
LIABILITY THIS CASE BECAUSE
THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN IN THE
BRICK AND MORTAR. THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN AN ONLINE. MARKET
PLACE IT CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE
THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
WE'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
TREAT. THESE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES THE SAME IS WE'VE
TREATED. THE BRICK AND MORTAR
COMPANIES FOR DECADES. IN A
STRICT LIABILITY CONTACTS BUT
I. AND I AGREE WITH YOU WE WANT
TO TREAT AN AMAZON. LIKE A
BRICK AND MORTAR ENTITY YEAH
BUT THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT MODELS IN THERE MAYBE
IN THE FUTURE DIFFERENT MODELS.
THAT WE DO THAT I DISAGREE I
THINK WE SHOULD DISTINGUISH I
THINK WE SHOULD. SET OUT SOME
PARAMETERS SO THAT THERE IS
SOME STABILITY SO THAT SO THAT
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO COME INTO
THE SPACE. CAN LEAST HAVE SOME
GUIDANCE. BUT IF WE'RE SIMPLY
GONNA LEAVE IT UP TO THE COURTS
TO SAY HEY YOU KNOW GO AHEAD
TAKE YOUR CHANCES AND SEE WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
SAYS. I THINK THAT NHIBITS I
THINK THAT INHIBITS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND I THINK IT
INHIBITS- THE ABILITY FOR
CONSUMERS ACTUALLY INTERACT
WITH ONE ANOTHER THAT'S MY
VIEW- IT CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT IT EXCUSE ME. BUT LET'S
STOP FOR A SECOND I'LL LET YOU
ANSWER THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES BUT
I DON'T WANT TO. ENGAGE IN ANY
FURTHER COLLOQUY HERE I THINK
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE. TO
DECIDE IN THE AUTHORS TAKEN
RESOLVE THOSE QUESTIONS A CORD
STILL HAS THE DISCRETION TO
ENSURE THE LONG STANDING
PRINCIPLES. OF STRICT LIABILITY
APPLY. SO THERE WILL BE IN SOME
INSTANCES. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSERT THOSE DEFENSES AS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN ASSERTED. WE ARE
JUST TRYING NOW TO ANALOGIZE.
AND TO PUT INTO THE SAME
FRAMEWORK. THE ONLINE PLATFORMS
AS THEY DO BUSINESS S. AS WE
HAVE WITH THE BRICK AND MORTAR
AND- WITH THE WITH THE
DISTINCTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DRAWN BETWEEN. THOSE WHO ARE
SELLING SECOND HAND PRODUCTS OR
JUST DOING ADVERTISING CLEARLY
THEY ARE NOT EXACTLY THE SAME.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
THEY ARE THE SAME IN CERTAIN
DUTIES THE SALE THE RETAIL
ASPECTS OF WHAT A BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES AND WHAT AN-
ONLINE MARKET PLACES THEY WILL
BE HELD TO THE SAME STANDARDS
AND IN THOSE AREAS WHERE THEY
ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE SAME.
THE AMENDMENTS AGAIN GIVE THE
COURTS THE DISCRETION TO APPLY
STRICT LIABILITY WERE
APPROPRIATE AND THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE LAWSUIT SO SENATOR
UMBERG WHEN HE DECIDED HAD
ENOUGH OF THIS PLACE AND GO
BACK TO PRACTICING LAW BE SOME
GOOD LITIGATION FOR YOU TO. TO
PURSUE BUT- THE I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS GIVE DISCRETION TO
LOOK AT WHETHER THE FACTS OF
THE CASE JUSTIFIES STRICKLAND
ABILITY OR DO NOT IT JUST. PUTS
IT IN THE SAME POSITION BRICK
AND MORTAR. IN LOTUS I'M GONNA
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE BUT
I HAVE- CONCERNS- THAT I THINK
CAN GET RESOLVED- AND MAYBE NOT
BUT I THINK THEY CAN GET
RESOLVED AND I HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS BEFORE THIS HITS
THE FLOOR YEAH I'M I'M HAPPY TO
AND IF YOU HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS LET ME KNOW LET'S.
LET'S LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
ALL RIGHT. A BRIEF CLOSE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE SIGNAL FOR I'M SORRY
SENATOR. MELINDA IS I DIDN'T
SEE YOU THERE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I. WE ONLY HAVE WE HAVE
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS. I'M FOR
THE AND RECESSION YOU GONNA
HAVE TIME TO MAKE. THE CHANGES
NECESSARY TO. EVERYONE PRIOR TO
THE CLOSE OF SESSION. EIGHT
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE WHAT'S BEING
OFFERED TO THE BILL COULD GO
FOR OKAY I'M JUST THE BILL
COULD GO FORWARD TODAY UNDER
THE ASSUMPTION THAT SOME
CHANGES WILL BE MADE BUT THOSE
CHANGES MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO BE
MADE. WELL I AM NOT CONVINCED
THOSE CHANGES ARE NECESSARY
OKAY BUT IF I AM CONVINCED OF
THOSE CHANGES ARE NECESSARY YES
WE DO IN FACT HAVE TIME. IN
THIS IS AN AREA THAT'S GOD THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING TO
JUST HAVE ONE BILL. ON THIS
THERE WILL BE AS THE MARKET
PLACE CHANGES AS WE SEE
TECHNOLOGY. MOVING DIRECTIONS
SO WE HAVEN'T BEEN CAMPAIGN TO
IS PAID I'M SURE THESE ISSUES
WILL BE. BROUGHT UP. IN
WHATEVER ITERATION WE FIND
OURSELVES I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU BUT- LEARNING WOOD
GIGABYTES ARE AND ALL THIS KIND
OF SERVICE SOMETHING I. NEVER
KNEW AND WAS NEVER ANTICIPATED
THAT WE WOULD BE LEARNING ABOUT
THEM SO I ASSUME THEY'LL BE THE
NEXT ITERATION. OF THESE KINDS
OF PLATFORMS- IN THAT THERE
WILL BE NEW THINGS THAT COME UP
WHAT WHAT THIS BILL I THINK
TRIES TO DO IS TO PUT IN A
FRAMEWORK- THE LOSS OF ABOUT
STRICTLY ABILITY THAT APPLY.
EVEN THOUGH THESE MARKET PLACES
ARE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT IN
CONCEPT. THERE ARE NO BRICK AND
MORTAR SHE GO ON TO YOUR
COMPUTER YOU CAN ORDER BIRTHDAY
CARDS GREAT IDEA FOR FAMILY
THAT YOU. YOU DON'T WANT TO
SENDING BACK THE GIFT YOU GIVE
THEM SO YOU GIVE A GIFT CARD
YOU CAN DO THAT IN. GET OFF TWO
MINUTES- NOT ANYTHING YOU EVER
THOUGHT OF BEFORE. BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THERE
ARE SOME BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES AND THAT'S WHAT I%
THINK THIS BILL. TRIES TO DEAL
WITH SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE I
THINK OF. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CONCLUDED CAN I THINK. WE'RE SO
IN LOVE WITH THIS NOTION OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE THINK THAT'S
THE ONLY INNOVATION THAT HAS
HAPPENED IT HASN'T AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
GOODS. AND HOW PRODUCTS GET TO
MARKET OVER MELANIA IT'S
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY. WE
WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE AMWAY MODEL
DISTRIBUTION WE WOULD BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION. IF YOU LOOK
AT AVON AND SOME OF THAT THE
INTERESTING KINDS OF THINGS
THAT ENTREPRENEURS CAME UP
WITH. WITHOUT THESE. NEW TOOLS.
THESE ARE JUST NEW TOOLS THAT
THEY DON'T CREATE. ANYTHING
ELSE IT ULTIMATELY NEW EXCEPT
FOR THE ABILITY TO MORE QUICKLY.
COME UP WITH DIFFERENT WAYS OF
DISTRIBUTING SO I THINK IT'S UP
TO US. TO NOT INHIBIT. THAT
ENTREPRENEURIAL IS A TEN NOT
INHIBIT THOSE IDEAS BUT BE VERY
CLEAR. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
DOES IS IF YOU'RE FACILITATING
BRING PRODUCT IN THE CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S DANGEROUS YOU CAN BE
SUBJECT TO STRICT LIABILITY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IN THE COURTS
ARE CLEAR ABOUT THIS ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S REALLY NO OTHER
AVENUE. TO SEEK REDRESS. THAT'S
ONE OF THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
FACTORS THECOURT'S USE TWENTY
THINK COURTS REALLY DO HAVE
FACTORS TO BE LOOKED AT IN
INDIVIDUAL CASE. AND WE WANT
THEM TO OR WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
AMEND THE STATUTE AND AMEND THE
STATUTE AND THE STATUTE AND
IT'S GOING TO BE A THOUSAND
PAGES. LONG AS NEW BUSINESS
MODELS COME UP THAT'S NOT
PRODUCTIVE. ABOUT BEING CLEAR.
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DUCK RESPONSIBILITY IF
YOU BRING A DANGEROUS PRODUCT
IN THE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME CAN I ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU THE MOTION-
IS DETECTED WILL BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR DID
WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR
MONNING HAS MOVED THE BILL. AND
MADAM CONSULTANTS WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A
SENATORS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BURGESS. AND IT
ALSO. I WITH NO CONDITIONS DID
ALSO HI GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
MELENDEZ. MORNING HI MONNING
AYE STERN. BUT I STERN I AM
BURKE AMBERG I WHY CAL SKI HI I
KASKY I'D THAT SEVEN TWO TWO
AND LEAVE ROLES OPEN NO- THIS
CENTER BORDER SYNDICATED HE
WOULD NOT BE COMING BACK INTO
THE CLOSER ROLE SO THE VOTE IS
SEVEN OUR EYES NO. NOSE INTO
EXTENSIONS. AND TO SO THAT BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY STONE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER ITEMS. YOU CAN ADD ON-
YES WE WILL ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK THROUGH
THE BILLS TO OPEN THE ROLES IN
THE ONLY THE ONLY BILL IS FILE
ITEM THREE. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE GONZALEZ THE VOTE COUNT IS
SEVEN TWO ZERO. SURE VOTING R.
I. IN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ NARROW MINING NINE
MINING I THAT'S EIGHT TO ONE.
EIGHT PIES ONE NOW. YES HE WAS
HERE HE VOTED YES ALL RIGHT ON
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY NINE OF THE
VOTE IS EIGHT TO ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE.
CHANGEABLE ALL RIGHT WELL WE'VE
CLOSED THE ROLE WE ARE TO CLOSE
RULE NINE. AND OKAY OKAY. AND
THEN THIS LAST ONE IS VERY
CLOSE WE CLOSED SEVERAL. I KNOW
I WAN'T HAVING. DID YOU ONE
WELL KNOWN AS HER WHICH- LIKE
WE CAN'T OPEN IT BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S LEFT I DON'T THINK.
OUR I'M SORRY I'M SORRY RIGHT
ARE AT THE- HI THERE WITH THAT
AND A GREAT THANKS TO THIS
EXTRAORDINARY STAFF OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WE ARE
ADJOURNED.